OPERATING
SEGMENT FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
BAKERSFIELD TO A SHORTER
BUILDING BLOCK HIGH SPEED RAIL
LINE FROM WORST TO BAKERSFIELD.
THE AUTHORITY ESTIMATES THIS SO
CALLED CENTRAL VALLEY LINE WALK
EIGHTEEN POINT THREE BILL
DOLLARS TO BUILD MONEY THE RAIL
AUTHORITY ALREADY HAS IN HAND
AND WILL BE OPERATIONAL BY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. AS WE ALL
KNOW IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE
VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION ONE
A. TO PROVIDE NINE BILLION IN
BONDS TO HELP BUILD A FIVE
HUNDRED MILE LONG HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM FROM SAN FRANCISCO
TO LOS ANGELES. AT THAT TIME
THE ESTIMATE FOR THE FULL COST
OF THE PROJECT WAS FORTY FIVE
BILLION AND WAS TO BE COMPLETED
BY TWENTY TWENTY. PROPOSITION
ONE A PRESCRIBE SPECIFIC. AND
DESIGN REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM
INCLUDING THAT IT MUST BE
ELECTRIFIED. BE CAPABLE OF SO
STATUS BEATS OF NO LESS THAN
TWO HUNDRED MILES PER HOUR AND
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO TRAVEL. TO
ACHIEVE TRAVEL TIMES BETWEEN
SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES OF
TWO HOURS AND FORTY MINUTES.
SINCE THAT TIME WE HAVE SEEN
NUMEROUS VERY PATIENTS ON WHERE
THE RAIL LINE WOULD BE BUILT
AND WHEN WE COULD EXPECT A
COMPLETED SYSTEM. ALTHOUGH THE
GOVERNOR REMAINS COMMITTED TO
BUILDING THE FULL SYSTEM HE
STATES THAT IS NEW PLAN. IS
ABOUT WHAT THE STATE CAN DO
WITH THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
TODAY'S HEARING IS ABOUT
GETTING A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE AUTHORITIES PLAN
INCLUDING ALL OF ITS MISSING
PIECES. THE RISKS. THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THE TRADE OFFS THAT
MUST BE MADE. AND OPINIONS OF
EXPERTS OUTSIDE THE DIRECT FEAR
OF THE AUTHORITIES INFLUENCE.
SO THAT WE THE LEGISLATURE CAN
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF THIS PROJECT. WE
WILL HEAR TODAY FROM VICE CHAIR
OF THE AUTHORITY BOARD OF
DIRECTORS TOM RICHARDS AS WELL
AS DIRECTOR BRIAN KELLY. WE
ALSO HEAR FROM DANNY CURTAIN
ONE OF THE ASSEMBLY IS
APPOINTEES TO THE AUTHORITY
BOARD. MARK EVANS CEO OF THE
EARLY TRAIN OPERATORS HERE TO
PRESENT SOME OF HIS FINDINGS TO
THIS COMMITTEE AND WE WILL HEAR
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PEER REVIEW GROUP. TO PROVIDE
EXPERT ANALYSIS OF THE PROJECT.
FINALLY WE WILL HEAR FROM
REPRESENTATIVES OF OUR REGIONAL
PARTNERS WITHOUT WHOM HIGH
SPEED RAIL SIMPLY COULD NOT
WORK. MEMBERS AS CHAIR FRAZIER
HAS SAID BEFORE PROCEEDING WITH
THIS PROJECT WILL NOT BE FOR
THE FAINT OF HEART SO LET'S GO
INTO IT FULLY INFORMED AND WITH
A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
IT WILL TAKE. I'D LIKE TO NOW
ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS. UGH I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE EVERYONE
BEING HERE- THE- SECRET THAT I
AM A SKEPTIC OF THIS PROJECT-
AND CERTAINLY THE CHALLENGES
THAT LIE AHEAD OF US IN THE USE
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS. I WAS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO ME. AS
WE MOVE FORWARD HOW WE HAVE A
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
DEADLINE- THAT- NEED TO BE MET
BEFORE FEDERAL FUNDS- MAYBE
CALL BACK. IN SO I WOULD BE
OBLIGATED. SO HOW DOES THAT
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY- SEEK
TO EVEN ATTEMPT TO. REACH THAT
MILESTONE SO- I HAVE A LOT OF.
QUESTIONS I THINK STILL THAT
LEFT TO BE LEFT TO BE
UNANSWERED BUT LOOK FOR TO- TO
THE QUESTIONS AND THE ANSWERS
FROM- FROM FROM NICE TO
AUTHORITY THANK YOU MUCH. THANK
YOU MISTER FONG ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IN ANY OPENING COMMENTS. SURE
JUST BRIEFLY I'M LAURA FRIEDMAN
I REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT
INCLUDES BURBANK IN THE BURBANK
AIRPORT WHICH IS A LOCATION
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO THE FUTURE
OF THIS PROJECT- SHOULD IT MAKE
IT THAT FAR- IT'S INTENDED TO
BE POSSIBLY THE MAIN HIGH SPEED
RAIL- TERMINAL FOR THE LOS
ANGELES AREA. I'D ALSO COULD
PART OF WHAT'S CONSIDERED THE
BOOK AND PROJECTS IN LOS
ANGELES THAT RECEIVED SOME
FUNDING THROUGH HIGH SPEED RAIL
BEING THE ROOTS OF THAT RIGHT
NOW OUR METRO ROUTES BETWEEN
BURBANK AT ANAHEIM- I LIVE IN
AN AREA THAT IS VERY HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY TRAFFIC CONGESTION.
I'M BY AIR QUALITY ISSUES AS
AREA IT'S AS WELL. I CONSIDER
MYSELF TO BE A VERY STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR MASS TRANSIT AND
ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORTATION TWO
CARS ARE SO I'M VERY INTERESTED
IN TRAINS IN GENERAL AND USE
AND EXPANDING OUR RAIL LINE
WHETHER IT'S- WITH LIGHT READ
RAIL AND SUBWAYS ARE THAT TYPE
OF REAL AND URBAN AREAS BUT
ALSO BEING THE- A CLEANER AND
MORE CONVENIENT AND SAFER
ALTERNATIVE FOR PEOPLE TO GO
FROM POPULATION CENTERS OF
POPULATION CENTER ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. OF MY QUESTIONS ARE
GOING TO BE AROUND HOW THIS
PROJECT FITS INTO OF FITS INTO
THAT- HOW OLD THIS PROJECT TO
HELP REDUCE CONGESTION ACROSS
THE STATE AN AIR QUALITY AND
THAT IF WE DO GO FOR WHAT THIS
PROJECT TO KNOW WHEN WE GO
FORWARD. HOW TO BEST UTILIZE
DOLLARS TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR CARS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE GIVE PEOPLE A MORE
CONVENIENT. ALTERNATIVE TO
DRIVING AROUND THE STATE SO
THAT'S WHERE MY FOCUS IS GOING
TO BE AND I'M REALLY HAPPY TO
SEE SUCH A BIG TURNOUT I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN HEARING FROM THE
EXPERTS I'VE ONLY BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THREE YEARS SO
THIS IS A RELATIVELY. NEW TO
ME- AS YOU KNOW THE ONE WHO'S
ASKED TO BE A POLICYMAKER AND I
KNOW A LOT OF YOU WHO. ARE HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK HAVE MANY MANY
YEARS WITH THIS PROJECT. AND
OTHERS SO I'M INTERESTED IN
HEARING FROM ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND ALL OF THE
EXPERTS I WANT TO THANK. MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BEING HERE AND
ALSO- TRANSPORTATION CHAIR JIM
FRAZIER FOR CONVENING THIS
MEETING. EVEN THOUGH HE'S NOT
ABLE TO BE WITH US HERE TODAY
HERE WITH US IN SPIRIT. THANK
YOU. I'D LIKE TO ASK THE- PANEL
TO COME FORWARD MEMBERS AS IF
YOU KNOW WE'VE ASKED THAT THOSE
PRESENTING TO KEEP SHORT AS I.
HOPE TO KEEP THIS MORE OF A
QUESTION DRIVEN HEARING. FEEL
FREE TO INTERRUPT AND ENGAGE
OUR PANELISTS AS NEEDED I WANT
US TO GET TO THE HEART OF
THINGS TODAY AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
AND FOR THE PUBLIC THERE WILL
BE AMPLE TIME TO HEAR FROM THE
FOLLOWING PANELS. BECAUSE I
SUSPECT MANY OF YOU WILL WANT
TO. SPEAK I'D ASK YOU TO MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS COMPLETE BUT
SUCCINCT. AND TO THE EXTENT YOU
CAN HELP US FOCUS ON THE
SPECIFIC SPECIFIC ITEMS WE WILL
BE DISCUSSING TO PAY. THAT
WOULD BE APPRECIATED. WITH THAT
LET'S BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING.
DIRECTOR KEVIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M
BRIAN KELLY AND THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. HERE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. OF MY
COMMITTEE VICE CHAIRMAN TOM
RICHARDS IS IN ROUTE.
APOLOGIZES HERE YET BUT HE IS
AN- IN ROUTE TO THIS HEARING HE
MAY. ALSO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS. THE
COMMITTEE WHEN HE GETS HERE- I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR COMING
DOWN. I KNOW HOW BUSY IT IS
WHEN YOU'RE LEGISLATOR. AND
THAT'S TAKES TIME OUT OF YOUR
SCHEDULE TO COME HERE. TO OUR
THE PROJECT TODAY SEE WHAT
WE'RE BUILDING IN THE VALLEY-
IT'S GREATLY APPRECIATED IT SO
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME. TO COME DOWN HERE. I
THINK THE BIGGEST CHANGE WE
MADE- SINCE I TOOK OVER AS THE
CEO OF THIS- AUTHORITY IN.
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAS
REALLY IN THE MIDST OF THE-
ANNOUNCEMENT OF. A COST AND
SCHEDULE ISSUES ON THE PROJECT
AND TO ME THAT WAS THE-
BEGINNING POINT OF US SAYING
LET'S TAKE A NEW LOOK. AT HOW
WE WILL FOR THIS PROJECT AND
SO. FIVE IN THE MIDST OF THAT-
ASSESSING. WHAT WE SEE OUR
REVENUES- IS BEING OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT. TEN YEARS
OR SO WITH THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM GOING UP TILL- TWENTY
THIRTY- AND OUR BOND DOLLARS
ARE STILL AVAILABLE TO THIS-
PROGRAM UNDER PROPOSITION ONE
A- THE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON OUR BOARD- WE
MOVE MOVE TOWARD A FLAT. FEE OF
DOING THIS LIKE YOU BUILD MANY.
TRANSIT PROJECT IN THE STATE
AND THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE ALL
THE FUNDING YOU NEED. IN HAND
TO BUILD EVERYTHING. YOU BUILD
ANOTHER BUILDING BLOCK
APPROACH. AND THAT'S BEEN THE
OF PRINCIPLES YOU FORTY SINCE
BEFORE I GOT HERE- BUT REALLY
WITH THE- THE- ACOSTA SCHEDULE
ISSUES. THAT EMERGED ADJUST
WHEN I STARTED ON THIS PROJECT.
THAT WE SHOULD STARTED. EARLY
INTERMONTANE EXCITEMENT WHEN WE
CAN- IN THE VALLEY- AND THEN
WORK TOWARD EXPANDING THAT-
THAT PROGRAM FURTHER BEFORE I
GO ANY FURTHER. LET ME TO MY
BOARD VICE CHAIR RICHARDS AND I
THINK BEFORE I SAY MUCH ELSE
LET ME DEFER TO HIM. TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. YEAH. THE FIRST
PAULA JUDGE I WAS WAITING FOR
YOUR LETTER THANK. APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT. LET ME A WELCOME YOU
HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS TOM RICHARDS I'M THE
ONE WHO'S LIKE TODAY MY NAME IN
DHAKA. AS YOU MAY KNOW- OR
CHAIR WHICH HERE MOST OF LAST
WEEK- LEADING THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIC SUMMIT. IF YOU ALSO
KNOW EARLIER THIS YEAR THE-
GOVERNOR INTRODUCED HIS
ADMINISTRATION'S- THOUGHTS WITH
REGARDS TO THIS PROJECT- WHICH
INCLUDED A BILL BOB BLOCK
APPROACH. THE APPROACH IS TO
GET HIGH SPEED RAIL OPERATING
ON SHORTER SERVICE IS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE AND DISCUSSED
BAKERSFIELD MERCED. EXCUSE ME.
I IN MAY- OUR MANAGEMENT AT
HIGH SPEED RAIL PUT PRODUCED-
FOR YOU IT'S A BI ANNUAL.
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT. THAT WAS
ON MAY THE FIRST AND IN THAT
REPORT I ENDORSE THE IDEA OF A
BUILDING BLOCK APPROACH AND
SPECIFICALLY DISCUSSED THE
BENEFITS OF THE BAKERSFIELD
MERCED EARLY SERVICE SEGMENT.
LATER THIS SPRING. IN NOW JUNE
THE FINANCE AND AUDIT COMMITTEE
OF WHICH I CHAIR ALONG WITH TWO
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WHICH IN WHO INCLUDED
ERNIE CAMACHO FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND NANCY MILLER
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. TASK
OUR FINANCIAL ADVISORS FORTY
KPMG TO PRODUCE A BUSINESS CASE
REPORT. FOR THE BAKERSFIELD
MERCED SEGMENT. AND TO IN THAT
REPORT TO ADDRESS THE BENEFITS
AND THE OTHER. IF YOU SURROUND
AN EARLY SERVICE BETWEEN
BAKERSFIELD MERCED LATER THAT
DAY THE DIRECTOR CAMACHO. HEY
INTRODUCED EIGHT AN ACTION OR
MOTION WITH THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS THE PURPOSE OF WHICH
WAS TO TASK THE EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR. TO LOOK INTO A
COMPLETE SIDE BY SIDE STUDY OF
OPTIONS OF EARLY SERVICE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. BOTH OF THESE
STUDIES ARE UNDER WAY THEIR
COMPLEXES SIGNAGE. AND WE
BELIEVE HER I BELIEVE AT LEAST
THAT THEY WILL FORM THE BASIS
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY A
BUSINESS PLAN. I WOULD LIKE AT
ALSO AND I BELIEVE YOU'RE WELL
AWARE THIS THAT IT IS A BORED
EXISTING. ACTION I IN APPROVAL
OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN. THAT IT INDOORS
THE INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT
BETWEEN BAKERSFIELD AND SECOND
VALLEY SLASH BAY AREA. OTHER
AREAS OF ONGOING FOCUS FOR OUR
BOARD- OUR COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL GRANTS THAT WE HAVE
WHICH REQUIRES YOU KNOW
COMPLETION BY DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWO. THE
ACCELERATION OF CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES ROW ACQUISITION
THIRD PARTY AGREEMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT. THESE ARE THE
ACTIONS ARE THE ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE BORDER ACTIVELY INVOLVED
WITH AND CONCERNED ABOUT I
WANTED TO ADDRESS THOSE WITH
YOU BRIEFLY AND THEN TURN OVER
THE BALANCE OF THE PRESENTATION
ON THE PROJECT UPDATE TO SCO
KELLY RIGHT. THANK YOU TOM.
WELL I THINK I'LL JUST MOVED
OUT TO EXPEDITE THINGS HERE TO
A PRESENTATION THAT WE PREPARE
FOR THIS COMMITTEE- HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL MOVE ALONG AS I CLICK
THESE BUTTONS YES I'M SO THIS
IS INTENDED TO JUST SORT OF
GIVE YOU A STATUS CHECK OF
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW IN THE
PROJECT IN TERMS OF OUR A
GLOBAL GOALS AND OBJECTIVES-
AND ALSO TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
THE STATUS OF ELECTRIFIED HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA TODAY.
SO THE FIRST IMPORTANT POINT
FOR US IS WHAT WE START WITH AT
THE AUTHORITY WE START WITH OUR
MISSION AND OUR MISSION IS
CLEARLY FIND THE LAW. ARE
MISSED IS BUILT. UP HI SIR. YOU
KNOW WHAT. IN A NON CAPABLE OF
SYSTEM SPEAKS OF TWO HUNDRED
MILES PER HOUR OR GREATER AND
THE STAFF IN THE BOB BILL THREE
IN OTHER LESSONS OF LAW AND
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT NOW IT IS
ROLL STOCK THE WE ALWAYS
DRIVING BOARD THAT IT GIVES YOU
BUILDING BY THE- SYSTEM THAT
MEETS THOSE SPEEDS AND THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT OBJECTIVE BECAUSE
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY IF YOU GET
ON CONVENTIONAL RAIL FROM THE
LA BASIN IN THE TROUT TRAVEL TO
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
THAT'S A TWELVE OR THIRTEEN
HOUR TRIP. IN IN TWENTY TWENTY
OR TWENTY NINETEEN THAT'S A BIT.
WE WANT TO GET THAT TRIP DONE
IN UNDER THREE HOURS AND WE
THINK WE CAN'T- SO THAT IS THE
MISSION OF THE VOTER CENTERS ON
AND THAT IS THAT IS HOW WE MOVE
NOW THEY- STATED EARLIER. WE
DON'T HAVE ALL THE FUNDS IN
HAND AND WE NEVER HAVE. TO BILL
ALL OF THAT SYSTEM WE'VE NEVER
HAD ALL THE MONEY WE NEED TO
BUILD IT ALL SO THE APPROACH IS
TO BUILD IT IN BUILDING BLOCKS-
WHICH IS. TRADITIONALLY HOW YOU
BILL TRANSIT SYSTEMS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THERE ARE
THREE PRINCIPLES THAT HAVE
GUIDED THE BOARD'S DECISIONS IN
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD IN A
CONSTRAINED FUNDING ENVIRONMENT
FIRST. INITIATE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA. AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. MAKE STRATEGIC
CONCURRENT INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL BE LINKED OVER TIME AND
PROVIDE MOBILITY. ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME. AND
POSITION OURSELVES TO CONSTRUCT
A DIVISIONAL SEGMENTS. AS
FUNDING BECOMES AVAILABLE. NOW
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD. MOST
DON'T APPRECIATE TOWARD THE TO
THE JACKET. AND THE SHOW THAT.
HERE. INTO THE STATUS OF THE
PROJECT. IS IT YES THE GREEK.
SEGMENT ON THIS OR ARE WE
PROJECT BERMAN. STATE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE MILES REP ANTS. NINE
OF THOSE. EARLY UNDER STRUCTURE
JUST LAST WEEK WE AS WE PLEADED
FARM WORK THE DOW DOWN
BAKERSFIELD. THE TEXAN BAR
MIDDLE DOCUMENT THAT WE WILL BE
EXTENT. INSTEAD IS A THE FIFTY
MILE. A RAILING. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION WE HAVE A NEW
PLAYER REAL AN ENEMY. THERE IS
A CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA I WHICH-
I LIKE WELL IN THE LAWSUIT IT
WAS. INTO THE REGION A LINE. TO
VICTOR THAT IS UP AN EIGHTY
MILE STRETCH IN A HUNDRED MILES
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
PROJECT. MATIC ENGINE IT
BROUGHT TO LIFE. FIRST IS
MANAGED NO NO. IT IS NOT OPEN
ON OPERATE BY ENTITIES. ARE
VERY REPUTABLE THE TRAIN
STATION LINE IS ALL. TODAY AN
URGENT IS THE SITE COMPANY.
VIRGIN IS COURSE THE RICH.
NUMBER ONE SPOKE TO ME SO THE
PLAYERS IN THE TRANSFER SINCE.
YEAH THAT PROJECT. SENIORS WHAT
TAKING A MINUTE. THE SERVER TO
HIGH SPEED UP TO FIVE. SO THEY
ARE BATTLING THE TO FIVE LINE.
WHILE THE FOR THAT PROJECT THE
MONEY COMING INTO THE BILL FOR
THE CATHOLICS BUT THERE'S IS ME
FROM THE EVIDENCE. THIS IS
TRULY A PUBLIC PRIVATE SHIP.
AND THREE IS THIS PUBLIC THE
PARTNERSHIP THE FIRST IS- THEY
HAVE SOUGHT FROM OUR TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE WITH THE
STATE OF ACCESS TO LOW COST
CAPITAL AND IT'S NOT THE SAME
THROUGH OUR INFRASTRUCTURE BOND
BANK AND THEY HAVE BEEN
APPROVED AT BOTH LEVELS- TO
MOVE FORWARD- WITH ACCESS TO
LOW LOW COUNTS ARE TAX EXEMPT.
BONDING AUTHORITY WHICH LOWERS
ACOSTA CAPITAL SO THAT'S
OCCURRED THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY ITSELF IN THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY HAS
ENTERED AN AMMO YOU- WITH
VIRGIN TRAINS WERE WE WILL
DISCUSS OF THINGS LIKE
RESERVATIONS TICKETING- THE
QUICK MEANT INTEROP ABILITY OF
THINGS WE CAN DO TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN SHARE EACH OTHER'S
LINES. REALLY PERHAPS PROVIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CAN BOTH
RIGHT ON- IN SO THAT IS THAT IS
AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT- TOWARD
THAT AND- YOU AND LASTLY AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR THE
PROJECT THE SECRETARY THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. HAS TO
PROVIDE THE RIGHT AWAY. TO
CONSTRUCT THAT PROJECT THAT
PROJECT AND I'M VERY JEALOUS OF
THIS POINT HAD PROJECT IS BEING
CONSTRUCTED ON ALMOST ENTIRELY
PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY. OWNED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
AND SO- THAT IS AN ELEMENT-
WHERE THE STATUS PARTNERING ALL
OF THOSE FRONTS TO MOVE THAT
THAT PROJECT FORD SO IN THIS
PICTURE HERE. THE GREEN IS WERE
RENDER PROJECT DEVELOPMENT THE
DOTTED LINES ARE WHERE WE ARE
STILL WORKING THROUGH OUR
TERMINAL SAYS. EVERYONE KNOWS
THE TERMINAL PROCESS IS
COMPLETE. THIS BUT THINGS LOOK
WHAT EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS. EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS COULD BE UNDER
CONSTRUCTION. ALL THESE
SEGMENTS VIRGIN AND THE SECOND
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE HIGH
SEVENTY MILES IN THE ALLEY
FIFTY MILES. IF YOU OWN WAY.
ONE IS OF IS ONE SYSTEM. WOULD
HAVE JUST AS WELL PHONE ON THE
OF MILES YOUR CONSTRUCTION DARK
ONE NOW THE COMPLETED LOOK THAT
WERE DONE BEFORE. REPRESENTS
THE PATIENT ALL THE YOU MENTAL.
THIS IS SO WHAT THIS MEANS NEXT
TWENTY MONTHS RETURN FIFTY
MILES OF ELECTRIC AND ICE
ROLLER STRUCK. FOR YOU ALL THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. ALL OF HIS WORK
BETWEEN INFERENCE GO A LOT
ANGELS CANNOT BECOME. OUR
FUNDING PARTNERS ALL OVER THE
STATE TODAY NOT JUST IN OUR
INVESTMENTS IN THE VALLEY BUT
ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WERE IN FOR ABOUT
ONE POINT THREE BILLION NOW
INCLUDING FOR FORTY ONE MILLION
FOR THE LOS. ANGELES UNION
STATION. TAKING GREAT. WHEN THE
BENEFITS OR CAUGHT A HOT GRILL
WHEN YOU GET THERE. OF THE
PAINS. THE FREE WILL TO THAT
MISSION. I READ ALL IN FULL
PROVIDE. THEY'RE **** THE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ALL OF THE ENVIRONMENT
WORK ON YOUR DOOR. THEY'RE
BUILT. UP A BANK. ALL OF THE
WORK DOWN ALSO. US MET LOPES ON
OTHERS FIND OUT HOW TO WORK.
THEN A WORK THAT SEGMENT- WE
MADE THE SEVEN BILLION THE
FIRST OF THE HARD AT WHAT TIME
THE HIGHEST RATE PUBLIC SAFETY
TURN PROGRESS DEBORAH PROJECT
CALIFORNIA. HAD RUN RENTS. AND
IN LOS ANGELES. BIGGEST CHUNK
OF THAT IS SEVEN HUNDRED
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS THERE
WE ARE COMMITTING IN BOTH PROP
ONE A BOND FUNDS AND CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS TO ELECTRIFY. THE
CALTRAIN PROJECT BETWEEN
SENTENCES. FRANCISCO YOU'RE
DOING I'D BE ONE WILL PROVIDE
EARLY IF IT'S TOO EARLY TO
IMPROVEMENTS. AND OPERATE
REMOVED. AN UPDATE WITH A
TICKET RANGE AND THIS ALL TO ME
THE COURT THAT WE SHARE WHEN WE.
AND UNLIKE THE WORK FOR. DURING
THE QUARTER WELL SIMILARLY THIS
UP HELLO. TWO NINE THREE
DOLLARS BERMAN IF YOU WERE.
BETWEEN TELLS A PERCENT. GO IN
AS A THAT IS A WAY DRAFT MILK I
COMMENCED. TWENTY TWENTY WE'LL
BE TO THE FINAL ENVIRONMENTAL
DIE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS.
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS OF
BAD TO THE SALMON GRADES
RATIONS. IN A I READ PUBLIC
SAFETY. LIKE THE WE ARE FUNDING
RESULT A COLD OR IN THE MORNING
WHAT WAS YOUR- THREE DOLLARS
PROBLEM A FOUR. CAN I TAKE
PRIDE. NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HERE
IS WHAT SO. BRING FOR ONE POINT.
AND THEN FINALLY THIS IS OUR
SCHEDULE ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS UP AS YOU SEE ON THE
LEFT COLUMN IS ARE PROJECTS
SEGMENT. AS I MEANT EARLIER.
EAST BOUND AS WELL WE'VE
COMPLETED OUR WORK COME FROM.
IN CLOSELY WITH A DIFFERENT
ACCOUNT KERN WHAT THAT MIGHT
MEAN LOOK LIKE IT WAS THIS
WOMAN. AND WE COMPLETE THAT
WORK AT THE LAST DAY OF OCTOBER
SIGN UP. IN THE WORLD WELL I
GUESS THAT. THESE ARE ALL LIST
IN ORDER IS YOU CAN BE THIS
VALLEY BY THE MERCED PATCHES.
BIG BILL THE PALMDALE THANKS A
BUNDLE BURBANK AND IS IT SAID.
FINALLY LOS ANGELES I'M AS YOU
CAN SEE IT IS THAT ON ALL OF
THE DROP IN BAR DOC WILL BE
BASED IN TWENTY WORK FINAL AS
THE GETTING A DATE OF
CERTIFICATION OF THAT WELL THE
MAN BY THE. THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. ASCOM IS A PORTENT. JUST
RELATIVES FEDERAL. THIS WORK
MUST BE DONE. FUNDING I
AGREEMENT THE END NEEDS TO AND
NOT LAST REFLECT THE AMOUNT OF
BLOAT YOU WILL BE OUT OF WORK
NUMBER OF MONTHS HAVE. THAT
WILL GROW. I HAD A GOOD WE ARE
TERMS. BUT ON THE WIND IN CALL
THREE THAT SOME MONTHS HAVE.
FRONT OF THE RULES GET. I'LL
SAY IT HEARING A MATT. WE WILL
HAVE CHALLENGES THIS IS A MEGA
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT OF THE
OTHER ONE PRIOR TO THIS AND ON
THE MOST FAMILIAR WITH HIS WORK
WHEN I WAS THE SECRETARY OF A
TRANSPORTATION OVER THE BAY
BRIDGE THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA AREA. AND MEGA PROJECTS
HAVE CHALLENGES OUR OBJECTIVE
IN OUR DUTY IS TO BE VERY CLEAR
ON WHAT THOSE CHALLENGES ARE
AND TELL YOU WHAT OPPORTUNITIES
WE HAVE AND HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
THOSE CHALLENGES. A TO MOVE
FORWARD IN SO- THAT'S KIND OF A
HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY WHERE THINGS
STAND TODAY AND WITHOUT A MAP
TO CONCLUDED OPEN TO QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR KELLY AND
VICE CHAIR RICHARDS IF I CAN
I'D LIKE TO START WITH
QUESTIONS AND PASS IT OFF TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN. I'D
LIKE TO ASK WHAT DO WE EXPECT
TO SEE IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN. I THINK IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN-
SOME OF WHAT YOU SAY WHAT YOU
WILL SEE IS WHAT- BOARD MEMBER
RICHARDS INDICATED- WE HAVE. A
COUPLE OF REPORTS THE WE ARE
WROTE WORKING THROUGH RIGHT
NOW- I THINK THOSE ARE GOING TO
DRIVE SOME OF OUR
DETERMINATIONS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN- I THINK
YOU WILL SEE US DRIVING FORD
ON- GETTING THE WORK DONE IN
THE VALLEY- AND- A PLAN IN
PROGRAM. IS A SORT OF INDICATED
IN THIS. POWER POINT
PRESENTATION TO COMPLETE ALL OF
THE WORK- THAT WE HAVE TO GET
DONE TO MEET OUR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO OR A GRANT REQUIREMENTS
FIRST. AS OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY.
THEN SECONDLY MOVING TO AN
INTERIM OPERABILITY SEGMENT.
AND THEN THIRD COMPLETING ALL
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK SO WE
CAN. OF FOCUS AND WORK ON. OF
ON CLOSING THE GAPS BETWEEN THE
VALLEY IN THE BAY AREA IN THE
VALLEY OF LOS ANGELES. GOING
FORWARD SO I THINK. YOU'LL SEE
THAT LAID OUT I GUESS THE- ONE
OF THE THING I'D SAY I WOULD
LIKE US IN THE BUSINESS PLAN
AND THIS IS. A SOMETHING WE
STOP THE WORK TO OUR BOARD OF
COURSE- BUT TO HAVE THREE D.
DISTINCT RAVAGES OUTLINED IN
THAT PLAN FOR THE VARIOUS
REGIONS. AND AGAIN I THINK WITH
THE EMERGENCE OF VIRGIN TRAINS
AND SO CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
INTERESTING OPPORTUNITY THERE-
AND THERE'S ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY THE BAY AREA WITH
THINGS THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
REGIONALLY SO. I THINK YOU'LL
SEE HERE'S WHAT WE INTEND TO DO
IN THE SHORT TERM WITH THE
MONEY WE HAVE. AND HERE'S OUR
LONGER TERM GOALS- TO EXTEND
ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
CALIFORNIA. CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THE- THE MO YOU. AND THAT WAS
RECENTLY ATTAINED AND HOW THAT
HELPS THE AUTHORITY YES THANK
YOU. IN JULY OF THIS YEAR- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GRANTED US
SOMETHING CALLED NEPA
ASSIGNMENT OF FORTY OF FOR
THOSE OF YOU BEEN IN
TRANSPORTATION FOR SOME TIME-
THIS IS THE AUTHORITY TO DO THE
FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
WORK- CONCURRENTLY WITH THE
STATE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW WORK
INSTEAD OF IT BEING TWO
DISTINCT. SEPARATE PROCESSES
ONE DONE HERE AND ONE DONE IN
WASHINGTON DC YOU HAVE TO DO
ABOVE BUT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS AND WORK THROUGH THEM
BOTH TOGETHER. SO NATIONALLY-
ABOUT FIVE OR SIX DIFFERENT
STATES HAVE BEEN DOING THAT ON
THE HIGHWAY SIDE CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THEM IN CALIFORNIA HAS
DONE VERY WELL IN TERMS OF
SAVING TIME AND MONEY TO THAT
PROCESS WE HAVE NOW BECOME WITH
THE GRANTING OF THIS. PROPOSAL
WE ORIGINALLY ASKED FOR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO- BUT IT WAS
GRANTED IN JULY OF THIS YEAR
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
WE ARE NOW THE FIRST RAIL
PROJECT IN THE NATION- TO GET
ME ASSIGNMENT WHAT IT MEANS FOR
US IS- I EXPECTED IT MEANS WE
WILL MOVE MORE QUICKLY- THROUGH
THE FEDERAL PART OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS.
AGAIN WE HAVE TO DO ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE DONE WE
NEED TO MAINTAIN A VERY GOOD
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS BECAUSE THEY
MAINTAIN SOME ROLE IN CONTINUED
REVIEWS- AND APPROVALS BUT
RATHER THAN SENDING EVERY
DOCUMENT BACK TO WASHINGTON DC
AND WAITING FOR A RESPONSE. A
WE CAN NOW WALK ACROSS THE
HALLWAY AND HAVE OUR FIRE
WALLED THE DEBATE TEAM DO THAT
WORK IN APPROVED THESE
DOCUMENTS SO WE DO EXPECTED TO
STATE SAVE TIME WE DO X.
EXPECTED SAVE MONEY. AND
CANDIDLY THE FIRST
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT THAT WE
CLEARED THE ROD TO BAKERSFIELD-
WAS THE FIRST ONE WE DONE UNDER
THAT NEED ASSIGNMENT. IT'S
ENCOURAGING TO HEAR WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN BECOME MORE
EFFICIENT TENDS TO BECOME
QUICKER AND SO- I'D LIKE TO ASK
NOW ABOUT THE NECESSARY SPEND
RATES TO MEET THE F. R. A.
GRANT REQUIREMENTS AND- WHAT IS
OUR CURRENT SPEND RIGHT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I DIDN'T I DON'T HAVE
IN FRONT OF ME THE EXACT- SPEND
RATE THAT WE HAVE ON THE-
PROJECT RIGHT NOW BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT. WE ARE REPORTING
QUARTERLY ON WHERE WE ARE IN
TERMS OF OUR EXPENDITURE RATE-
AND MEETING THE- THE ARE A
GRANT AGREEMENT THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE WE HAVE HAD. IS THAT
IN THE VALLEY AND THIS IS
LARGELY BECAUSE- WE COMMENCE
CONSTRUCTION PRIOR TO HAVING
ALL THE RIGHT AWAY AND HAND
HERE- IN ALL THE UTILITY
RELOCATIONS IDENTIFIED AND
MOVED- THAT HAS BEEN THE SORT
OF FIRST ORDER WORK THAT WE ARE
STILL GRINDING THROW. A HOWEVER
WE ARE IMPROVING THAT SYSTEM WE
STREAMLINED SOME OF THAT RIGHT
AWAY- THAT- RIGHT AWAY PROCESS.
A GOING FORWARD SO THINGS LIKE
LAND CONVEYANCES AND SOME OF
THE- ACQUISITIONS WE CAN DO IN
A QUICKER PACE- SO WE'VE BEGUN
THAT PROCESS. NOW IN IN THAT
WORK IS GOING FORWARD ARE SPEND
RATE IS CLIMBING- I THINK THIS
MONTH I WAS JUST TOLD THE WILL
BE SPENDING. A JUST UNDER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THIS MONTH- ON
THE CONSTRUCTION HERE IN THE
VALLEY- AND SO- WE CONTINUE TO
JUST- GROWING THROUGH THE- THE
PROCESS HERE. AND ARE LOOKING
TO. IS MY CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER LIKES TO SAY. A
CONSTRUCTION LINE IS AN S.
SHAPED FIGURE AND YOU GO TO THE
FIRST ORDER ORDER OF WORK. AND
IT'S PRETTY FLAT BUT ONCE YOU
GET THAT DONE. YOU GOT YOUR
SPEND RATE JUMPS UP PRETTY
QUICKLY IS YOUR NOW ROLLING
THROUGH CONSTRUCTION. SO AS WE
COMPLETE THAT FIRST ORDER WORK
I EXPECT OUR SPEND RATE WILL
CONTINUE TO INCREASE- WE DO
REPORT THIS QUARTERLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE- NOW INTO OUR PER
HOUR PERIOD YOU GROUP. I JUST
DON'T HAVE THE DATA AND FOR ME
THE MOMENTS I APOLOGIZE NO IT'S
OKAY- IF I MAY I'D LIKE TO
CHANGE GEARS AND ASK ABOUT SB
ONE. WHETHER OR NOT IT- PEOPLE
TO FIND RAIL IMPROVEMENTS. AND
HOW MUCH MONEY FOR EXAMPLE HIGH
SPEED RAIL HAS RECEIVED FROM
THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE. SB ONE-
DOES PROVIDE DOLLARS FOR RAIL.
IMPROVEMENTS BUT IT DOESN'T
PROVIDE ANY DOLLARS FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL. THERE'S A PROGRAM
THERE ARE SEVERAL PROGRAMS BY
WHICH IS B. ONE CAN FIND. A
RAIL IMPROVEMENT THE- PRIMARY
ONE IS CALLED THE TRANSIT
CAPITAL AND INTERCITY RAIL
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM- AND THAT
FUNDS. A LOT OF COMMUTE
COMMUTER RAIL A PROJECTS
HOWEVER WE ARE NOT- ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT FUND AND SO
OUT OF SB ONE WE HAVE BEEN WILL
RECEIVE NO NO FUNDING. HAS THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE RECEIVED ANY MONEY FOR
RAIL- IN THAT REGION TO THE SP
ONE. YES. AGAIN MOSTLY THE I'M
MOST FAMILIAR WITH THE T. I. R.
C. P. PROGRAM AND THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM I THINK SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THAT PROGRAM
INCLUDING SB ONE DOLLARS AND
THAT REGION IS RECEIVED ON THE
WATER OF TWO POINT SEVEN TWO
POINT SIX TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. WITH THAT I
WILL CONCLUDE MY QUESTIONS AND
HANDED OVER TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU MISTER KELLY MISTER
RICHARDS FOR- BEING HERE AND
SPEAKING WITH US TODAY I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- MY FOR IS
IT ONE OF PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S VISION OF HOW THIS
PROJECTS GOING TO ROLL OUT AND
WHY- WE SHOULD BE. INVESTING IN
THIS SECTION OF PROJECT IS TO
DEMONSTRATE BY ABILITY. AND TO
HOPEFULLY ATTRACT PRIVATE
INVESTMENT TO HELP COMPLETE THE
REST OF THE SYSTEM AND I'M
WONDERING WHAT YOU SEE AS THE
SORT OF THRESHOLD THAT WOULD
DEMONSTRATE THAT- AND WHETHER
YOU'VE HAD ANY INTEREST FROM
PRIVATE INVESTMENT AT THIS
POINT SORT OF WHAT WOULD IT
TAKE TO TOLD THAT BALANCE. THIS
THAT AND SO WHERE WHERE IS
THEIR LEVEL IF YOU GO FROM ONE
TO TEN WHERE IS PRIVATE
INVESTMENT NOW ON THIS. ON
HELPING TO COMPLETE THE ENTIRE
PROJECT AND WHAT WOULD IT TAKE
TO GET THEM UP TO TWO TEN
THEY'RE KINDA IN. I THINK
IDEALLY FOR PRIVATE INVESTMENT
IN THAT THIS PROJECT THEY WOULD
WANT TO SEE A DEMONSTRATION
THAT- YOU CAN RUN A FOR PROFIT
SERVICES ACTUALLY THAT YOUR NET
REVENUES WILL EXCEED YOUR NET
COST- IN OUR VALLEY THE VALLEY
APPROACH FROM BAKERSFIELD TO
SAN FRANCISCO WE- WE SEE WE
PROPOSE THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO. TO DO THAT- SO THE
DISCONNECTION NOTICE RIGHT
CLOSE TO DEMONSTRATE THAT SO
HOW DO YOU DO THAT IN THIS
SECTION THIS SECTION WILL NOT
DEMONSTRATE THAT WITH THIS
SECTION WILL DO OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT- THIS
SECTION FOR US- WILSHIRE THE
ASSETS THAT WE ARE SPENDING
BILLIONS TO BUILDING THIS PART
OF THE STATE WILL NOT GO TO
WASTE. WE'LL PUT TO USE IT WILL
BE PUT TO USE FOR ELECTRIFIED
HIGH SPEED RAIL CONSISTENT WITH
OUR MISSION UNDER THE LAW IN SO
AND IT WILL REDUCE TRAVEL TIMES
TO CLEAN UP THE AIR- AND WILL
PROVIDE A BETTER TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM IN AN AREA OF THE STATE
THAT HAS LITTLE PUBLIC TRANSIT-
AND SO THAT IS. WHY WE WANT TO
START THERE AGAIN WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE- SORT OF
BREAK POINT ON THE OPERATIONS
VERSUS COST STRETCH IS. LIKELY
BAKERSFIELD ALL THE WAY THE BAY
TO SAN FRANCISCO. WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE MONEY WE NEED TO BUILD
THAT STRETCH YET IT'S STILL OUR
OBJECTIVE- BUT WE'RE GOING TO
FINISH THAT ENVIRONMENTAL WORK
AND THAT'S THE OTHER. POINT I
WANT TO MAKE. TO REALLY GET
ENVIRONMENTAL INTERESTS- IN
THESE TYPES OF MAKE A PROJECTS
MISSED THAT THIS TYPE OF
PROJECT. YOU HAVE TO REDUCE
RISKS OR THEY WILL NOT PLAY. IN
EYES SO I THINK THE WAY YOU DO
THAT IS YOU GET THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK DONE. IN SO
WHEN I TALK ABOUT GETTING ALL
OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL WORK DONE
IN THE NEXT. EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS. TO ME THAT AS A
PRECURSOR TO REALLY. INVITING A
LOT OF PRIVATE SECTOR
OPPORTUNITY ON THIS PROJECT IN
TERMS OF MEETING. HELPING ME
CAPITAL COSTS. BUT THE OTHER
THING I MUST SAY BECAUSE ITS
THE NEWEST AND MOST EXCITING.
DEVELOPMENT ON THIS PROJECT FOR
THE FIRST TIME. PRIVATE SECTOR
INTERESTED DEMONSTRATED WITH
THE VIRGIN TRAIN SYSTEM IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AGAIN
THEY'RE TAKING THE RISK ON. THE
FIRST SEGMENT OF THAT AGAIN A
BUILDING BLOCK APPROACH. LAS
VEGAS TO VICTORVILLE. AND THEY
ALL TO MILLIE ARE GOING TO NEED
HELP TO GET THE PALMDALE. BUT I
KNOW I'VE TALKED WITH. THEY
HAVE NO INTENTION OF HAVING A
LAS VEGAS RUN BE. LAS VEGAS TO
VICTOR. THEY WANNA GET TO
PALMDALE AND THEY WANT TO GET
TO LOS ANGELES. AND THEY WANT
TO DO IT ON SHARED. ASSETS THAT
WE BOTH HAVE. A BECAUSE THAT'S
HOW YOU DO IT UNDER THE
QUICKEST. TRAVEL TIME POSSIBLE.
IN SO- CLEARING THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK. ENTERING IN
M. WITH THEM ON HOW WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO PROCEED TOGETHER. IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO CLOSE
THAT LOOP I THINK. OF THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT STEPS IN FRONT OF US
BUT IN ESSENCE I GUESS WHAT I'M
SAYING IS. TO ATTRACT PRIVATE
SECTOR INVESTMENT. YOU NEED TO
REDUCE RISK. AND WHEN WE DO
THAT IS GET ALL THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK DONE. AND
THEN SECONDLY- YOU WANT TO
DEMONSTRATE THE VIABILITY OF
THE PROGRAM. SO IT'S THAT
SECOND PART THAT I'M ASKING
ABOUT YEAH AS I UNDERSTAND.
THAT THERE'S A PROPOSITION AND
THERE'S FUNDING AND- YOU HAVE
TO SPEND IT. AND I UNDERSTAND
THE PART ABOUT. DOING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK SO THAT YOU
REDUCE THAT RISK AND YOU GET
READY TO. LAY YOUR- PROJECT
OUT- IT'S THE BUILDING BLOCK
PART THAT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE LINK BETWEEN
THIS PARTICULAR BUILDING BLOCK.
AND THEN TRADING BY ABILITY. SO
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU WANT TO
SEE. OUT OF THIS IN TERMS OF
SORT OF INCREASE RIDERSHIP. AND
HOW DOES THIS. INTO THAT TO
REALLY DEMONSTRATE THAT I
ABILITY BECAUSE I AGREE WITH
YOU I THINK THAT DEMONSTRATING
THAT PEOPLE. ARE WILLING TO
TAKE TRAINS. IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO GETTING THE INTEREST FOR THE
SYSTEM WIDE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
BUT WHY IS THIS SECTION AND THE
INVESTMENT IN THIS SECTION
GOING TO DEMONSTRATE THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO. AND INVESTMENT
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE HAD IN
ANOTHER SECTION BECAUSE THERE'S
NO OTHER SECTION IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WILL WE CAN
REMOVE TRAIN TO TWO HUNDRED
MILES PER HOUR. ELECTRIFIED SO
WITH THAT AND WHAT WHEN WHY I
THINK THAT IS IMPORTANT. IS
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE YOU GET
THE TIME SAVINGS THAT YOU CAN
PRESENT WITH THIS KIND OF A
SYSTEM SO LET'S TALK ABOUT
THAT. SO NOW I TO I UNDERSTAND
THE TIME SAVINGS. FROM
BAKERSFIELD TO MERCED. IT'S A
BIG DISTANCE. AND YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A MUCH FASTER TRAIN. BUT
LET'S SAY YOU'RE YOU'RE IN
FRESNO YOU'RE RIGHT HERE IN
FRESNO. AND YOU WANT TO GO TO
THE BAY AREA. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM SPEAKING TO
YOU EARLIER IS THAT IT'S YOUR
HOPE THAT ONCE THE SECTION IS
COMPLETED. THE AMTRAK TRAIN
THAT RIGHT NOW IS REDUNDANT
WITH THAT ROUTE. THAT YOU'LL
HAVE LESS OF THOSE AMTRAK
TRAINS. WILL INSTEAD BE TAKING
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL. SO FROM
FRESNO. GO TO MERCED WHICH IS
ONE STOP. AND THEN YOU CHANGE
TRAINS. AND THEN YOU CONTINUE
TO THE BAY AREA OR TO
SACRAMENTO ON WHEREVER YOU'RE
GOING. NOW IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
YOUR TIME SAVING THAT POINT
BECOMES ESSENTIALLY A WASH.
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE HOW YOU GET
PEOPLE OFF THE TRAIN AND BACK
ON THE OTHER TRAIN WITH THEIR
BAGGAGE AND STROLLERS. I DON'T
KNOW FIFTEEN TWENTY MINUTES. I
TAKE THE TRAIN A LOT I HAVE TO
CHANGE TRAINS AT UNION STATION
ALL THE TIME AND YOU'RE TALKING
JUST METRO TO METRO OR AMTRAK
TO METRO. THAT AMTRAK TRAINS IS
THERE FOR QUITE AWHILE AND
THAT'S BEST CASE SCENARIO THAT
YOU ARRIVE ON HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND YOU'VE GOT THE AMTRAK
TRAIN. WAITING READY TO GO
THEY'VE PUT THE FOOD ON IT
THEIR GEAR THEY'RE READY TO GO
YOU'RE STILL TALKING AT LEAST
FIFTEEN MINUTES TO GET PEOPLE
FROM ONE THE OTHER MAYBE TWENTY
MINUTES. SO FOR FRESNO GROUP
WHO GETS ON IN FRESNO. IT
DOESN'T SEEM THAT YOU'RE
OFFERING THEM ANY TIME SAVING
BUT YOU ARE ASKING THEM TO
CHANGE TRAINS NOW IN THE MIDDLE
I THINK THEY'LL HAVE MORE THAN
ONE OPTION MY SENSE OF IT IS
ELEVEN OPTIONS THE
UNCONVENTIONAL RAIL. IN
SICKENING GO FROM FRESNO TO
OAKLAND OR PRESENT TO
SACRAMENTO UNDER THAT AMOUNT OF
TIME IT TAKES TO TRAVEL ON THAT
TODAY BUT YOU SAID THEY WERE
GOING TO BE REDUCING THAT YES
SEVEN TO NINE TRIPS A DAY TO
TREAT THEIR WILL WELL. AS I
SAID EARLIER SUBJECT TO AN
OPERATING GREEN WE HAVE NOT YET
COMPLETED. WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS BUT HERE'S HERE'S A
WE'RE INTENDING TO DO. RIGHT
NOW IN MERCED THERE'S AN AMTRAK
STATION ONE LOCATION AND NO A
STATION AT ALL. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE LEGISLATURE
INVESTED EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GETTING H. TO
MERCED. INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF TRIPS AND AMTRAK TAKE INTO
MERCED WE ARE PROPOSING TO DO
IS HAVE THE AMTRAK STATION THE
MERCED STATION IN THE HIGH
SPEED. SORRY THE AMTRAK
STATION. ACE STATION AND THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL STATION ALL GO
TO ONE PLACE IN MERCED. AND
THEN TRANSFERS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT WILL BE SIMPLER I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE TRAVEL TIME IS
FROM FRESNO TO MERCED BECAUSE
WE HAVEN'T ITEM MODEL THAT.
WHAT I HAVE MODELED IS MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD IN THE NINETEEN.
HUNDRED MINUTE REDUCTION VERSUS
TRAVEL TIME TODAY. SO YES IF
THEY CHOOSE HIGH SPEED RAIL THE
GET TO MERCED QUICKER THAN THEY
WOULD ON THE CONVENTIONAL RAIL.
ACROSS THE PLATFORM. GET ON
AMTRAK IF THEY WANT TO TAKE
ACTION FOR ACE. IN GETTING
EITHER THE BAY AREA OR
SACRAMENTO. AS I. AS AN INTERIM
MEASURE FOR AND BY THE WAY I'M
NOT ASKING YOU THESE QUESTIONS
TO BE ARGUMENTATIVE. OR TO SAY
THAT THERE'S ANYTHING.
NECESSARILY WRONG ABOUT THE
APPROACH BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT AS WE
MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS. WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THIS SO THAT WERE
ABLE TO MAKE CHOICES WITH OUR
FUNDING. THAT MAKE IT YOU KNOW
GET MY GOAL IS I WANT TO GET
PEOPLE ON THESE TRAINS WHATEVER
TRAINS THEY ARE. ONE OF ON THE
TRAINS AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE
EXPERIENCE IS GOING TO BE FOR
THEM BECAUSE I'M FROM A REGION
WHERE A LOT SOMETIMES. USE THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IS NOT
GOING IN THE DIRECTION WOULD
LIKE GOING DOWN NOT UP. AND AS
SOMEBODY WHO. YOU KNOW I GAVE
UP MY CAR FOR TWO YEARS AND
JUST RODE BUSES AND TRAINS.
THAT EXPERIENCE THAT USERS HAVE
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT. IF YOU
REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE THEM
TO USE YOUR SYSTEM SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE I'M NOT TRYING
TO ARGUE WITH YOU I WANT TO.
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE EXPERIENCE
IS GOING TO BE. FOR THOSE
WRITERS- SO LET ME ASK A LITTLE
BIT OF JUST. I'M SORRY THIS
WILL BE SORT OF MY LAST LINE OF
QUESTIONING AYE AYE. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'RE- A NEWER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR I WANT TO
ASK YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME
OF THE OLD PRACTICE OF- HIGH
SPEED RAIL. BECAUSE BEFORE I
WAS IT ON IN THE ASSEMBLY I WAS
A COMMISSIONER AT THE BURBANK
AIRPORT. AND HAD THE EXPERIENCE
OF. BEING MY BEING A
COMMISSIONER THERE AND- DEALING
WITH AN AIRPORT TRYING TO BUILD
A NEW TERMINAL FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO DON'T KNOW FLYING TO
BURBANK HOPEFULLY IN A FEW
YEARS YOU WILL HAVE A- MUCH
SAFER. NICER NEW TERMINAL
THERE. AND IT'S BEEN A VERY
LONG MAYBE TWENTY YEAR PROCESS
OF BURBANK TRYING TO. GET
PERMISSION TO BUILD THIS. VERY
IMPORTANT TERMINAL FOR SAFETY
EVERYTHING ELSE. AND IT
INVOLVES SELLING A VERY LARGE
PIECE OF PROPERTY THAT WERE AT
THE AIRPORT OWNED. AND IT WAS A
LOT OF MOVING PIECES THAT WERE
BEING PUT TOGETHER THAT WAS
THE- OF MANY YEARS. AND WEBER
WE WERE VERY CLOSE TO THE END.
OF GETTING OUR PERMISSIONS AND
SELLING OUR PROPERTY HIGH SPEED
RAIL. AUTHORITY AT THE TIME
SORT OF SHOWED UP OUT OF THE
BLUE. AND AT A PUBLIC MEETING
ASKS US TO STOP THE SALE OF THE
PROPERTY. TO CHANGE DIRECTIONS
TO MAYBE NOT BUILD THE TERMINAL
RIGHT AWAY. YOU KNOW. VERY
SURPRISING BEHAVIOR. FROM AN
AGENT FROM AGENCY TO AGENCY SO
MY AND I'VE HAD A SIMILAR
EXPERIENCE WHEN I WAS ON THE
GLENDALE CITY COUNCIL OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL TELLING US THAT
THEIR- TRAIN WAS GOING. THROUGH
HERE AND LOOKING AT THE MAP AND
SAYING THAT'S- THE DISNEY
CAMPUS SUCH GOOD REMARKS CAMPUS
THAT'S UP HIS STORE STORE TRAIN
STATION ON THE HISTORIC
REGISTER LIKE. WHERE ARE YOU
WITH AND A LOT OF YOUR ISSUES
COMING THROUGH LOS ANGELES. THE
ISSUE A VERY DENSE AREA WITH A
LOT OF DISRUPTION. BUT THE
SECONDARY ISSUE THAT IS DEALING
WITH A MULTITUDE OF CITY
COUNCILS AND NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCILS. AND EVERYBODY KIND OF
BEING ON BOARD AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT HAS TO
HAPPEN. SO WHERE ARE YOU WITH
COMMUNICATIONS AND HAVING A
BETTER WAY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE AS YOU GO INTO A
DENSE AREAS. AND COMMUNICATING.
MAYBE BETTER THAN THE PREVIOUS
REGIME. WITH ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND CITIES
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT HOW DO
YOU MANAGE THAT SO THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TREMENDOUS FIGHTS
WHEN YOU GO TO THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. BUT YOU DON'T. TELL
SMALL CITY LIKE CITY OF SAN
PRINT THAT THEY'RE GONNA LOSE
THEIR ENTIRE DOWNTOWN. THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL HOW DO YOU WORK
AROUND THAT. LIMITS PER SE I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR POINT ABOUT-
THIS IS A LARGE- STRATEGY OF
GETTING PEOPLE. TO USE BOTH
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND
CONVENTIONAL RAILS. THE
REASONABLE TO WORDS. AVAILABLE
I THINK I'M SO PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS PROJECT BECAUSE IT'S- IT.
IT IS THE MOST TRANSFORMATIVE
PROJECT I'VE SEEN IN TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF WORKING IN
TRANSPORTATION AND I THINK THE
IDEA. OF CONNECTING CITIES OF
CALIFORNIA. THROUGH ELECTRIFIED
HIGH SPEED RAIL WILL ENHANCE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL TRANSIT
SERVICES WELL. SO I AM A
PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT ON TO
YOUR SECOND. QUESTION STRICTLY
ON THE BURBANK EXAMPLE. ONE OF
THINGS THAT I'VE TRIED TO DO
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE IS WORK
TOWARD BEING MORE SPECIFIC AND
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING-
AND- THAT MANIFESTS ITSELF IN A
COUPLE OF WAYS FOR A LONG TIME
BEFORE I GOT HERE. THE
AUTHORITY HAD NOT- QUITE YET
EVEN ADOPTED THIS PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVES FOR SOME OF ITS-
WORDS INTENDING TO GO IN SO IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE COMPLETED
THE PREFERRED ALTERNATIVES FOR
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA.
IN IN THE BAY AREA WE COMPLETED
THAT JUST A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO- BUT DOING THAT HELPS THAT
ENHANCE THE COMMUNITY
CONVERSATION. BECAUSE IT DID
NOW ATTENDS THE FOCUS ON WHERE
WE INTEND TO GO AS A PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE. AND IT HELPS AS A
WORK THROUGH WITH THE CITY'S
MORE SPECIFIC ISSUES A CITY OR
COUNTY LOCAL PARTNERS MORE
SPECIFIC ISSUES. THERE ON THE
TABLE RIGHT AFTER WE ARE
PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE I FLEW
DOWN AND SPOKE WITH THE BURBANK
AIRPORT- I'VE GOT A MEETING
THIS WEEK WITH THE CITY OF
BURBANK. A TO TALK MORE ABOUT
THIS- ONE HANDICAP I CURRENTLY
HAVE IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION IS OF WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CHANGING OUT OUR
REGION DIRECTORS WHO WILL BE
PART OF OUR LEAD COMMUNICATION
DOWN THERE. BUT THAT SAID WE
HAVE CANDIDATES WERE
INTERVIEWING NOW AND WILL BE
REPLACING THAT AS WELL. THE
OTHER PRODUCTS THAT IS JUST
PART OF THIS IS THAT WE ARE
SITTING AND LISTENING- IT ON
THE FRONT END OF THINGS AND NOT
WAITING TILL THE END- DIRECT.
WE HAVE SOME IN A PROBLEM IN
TWO EXAMPLES I'D GIVE YOU A
THAT ARE. IN OUR STRETCH
BETWEEN BAKERSFIELD IN
PALMDALE- THERE'S THE SHOP AS
MEMORIAL A MONUMENT THAT IS UP
IN THE TO HATCH PEAS AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONSTERNATION IS A BACK AND
FORTH ABOUT- WHERE AND HOW THE
TRAIN WILL GET AROUND. THAT
SEGMENT WE DECIDED DELAYED
THINGS FOR SIX MONTHS DOES HAVE
CONSECRATED COOPER STATION WITH
THAT ENTITY TO WORK THROUGH HOW
WE WILL DO THAT. AND I THINK
WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT.
PROGRESS THE- US POLITICAL FOR
THE. THE SECOND. OTHER ISSUE
THAT WE WORK THROUGH WITH THE-
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS CAUGHT
A PLACE CALLED. THE LAKE WITH
HOW WE WILL GET THROUGH THE
LAKE. RATHER THAN JUST MARCHING
FORWARD NOT LISTENING IN HAVING
A FIGHT AT THE END. BUT WE'RE
ENGAGING EARLIER AND HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS- ON THE
FRONT END IN TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH THESE ISSUES SO. PART
OF IT IS TAKING THE TIME
EARLIER FIRST OF ALL IT'S-
BEING MORE SPECIFIC CLEAR.
ABOUT WHAT OUR INTENTIONS ARE-
IN IN THE END. UP TAKING THE
TIME TO HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS.
TO LISTEN TO THE COMMUNITIES
AND FIGURE OUT WHERE WE
DISAGREE. AND THEN WORK TOWARD
UP SOME KIND OF A SOLUTION. AND
SO. THAT'S THE APPROACH I'VE
TRIED TO I'VE TRIED TO BRING TO
THIS SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE. I
THINK IT'S THE APPROACH THAT MY
BOARD INSISTS ON- IN TERMS OF
HAVING A BETTER- OUTREACH
EFFORT AND COMMUNITY- RESPONSE
EFFORT- IN SO THAT. IN SHORT
THAT'S WHAT I'M WHAT I TRY TO
DO. IT IN- AS THANK YOU AND
I'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
BEFORE BUT YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
WHEN IT COMES TO BURBANK
AIRPORT- IT'S A MAJOR
TRANSPORTATION HUB. BEING MAJOR
REGIONAL AIRPORT. THERE'S ALSO
TWO METROLINK TRAINS TO
BUILDING A TERMINAL. AT SOME
POINT YOU MAY BE BUILDING A
TERMINAL THERE AS WELL AND IT
WOULD JUST BE GREAT IF FOR
PASSENGERS THEY HAVE A SEAMLESS
EXPERIENCE FROM ONE OF THESE
TRAVEL MODALITIES TOGETHER. I
DON'T SEE THAT PLANNING
HAPPENING QUITE HONESTLY I SEE
THEM BUILDING A TERMINAL.
WITHOUT ANY THOUGHT TO HOW IT
CONNECTS WITH WHATEVER IF
YOU'RE GONNA BUILD A TERMINAL.
I KNOW IT'S FAR FROM THE FUTURE
MAYBE IT HAPPENS MAYBE IT
DOESN'T BUT I STILL DON'T SEE
THAT KIND OF COORDINATION AND-
THERE'S A LOT OF. APPOINTING OF
THAT OTHER COUNTRIES AND THEIR
EXPERIENCE WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND I DON'T SEE THE SAME
ATTEMPT TO TIE. AIRPORT TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL. THE WAY THAT WE'VE
SEEN IT WORK EFFECTIVELY IN
OTHER PLACES I STILL HAVE THE
SORT OF NIGHTMARE. THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BUILD THEIR TERMINAL.
ONE DAY YOU COME IN YOU BUILD
YOUR TERMINAL AND PEOPLE HAVE
TO WALK A HALF MILE TO GET FROM
ONE TO THE OTHER OR SOMEBODY
HAS TO BUILD SOME EXPENSIVE.
THING TO BRING THEM BACK AND
FORTH- AND I JUST HOPE THAT AS
WE THINK ABOUT. REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION HUBS THAT WE
REALLY THINK OF IT THAT WAY AND
GET OUT OF OUR SILOS AND WORK.
TEMPTED AND WORK. IT FROM THE-
VIEWPOINT OF A USER AND A GOOD
USER EXPERIENCE AND HAVING
SOMETHING THAT IS. A PLANNED IN
ADVANCE SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE ADDITIONAL EXPENSE OF
HAVING TO GO BACK AND RETROFIT
AND BUILD TRAINS TO AIRPORTS
LIKE WE'RE DOING IT LA ACTS
AND- EVERYTHING ELSE- THE ONE
WE JUST SAY THAT- RIGHT NOW I'M
IT'S SORT OF THE MID POINT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH- THE BURBANK
AIRPORT. THE CITY OF BURBANK IN
THE FAA. ON EXACTLY HOW WE'D
COME IN THERE AND WHEN AND-
EVERYBODY'S GOT THEIR OWN
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT- SO
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MAKE THAT WORK- BUT- EVEN
THE LEAD AT THE BURBANK AIRPORT
SAID TO ME IN OUR MOST RECENT
MEETING- HOW IMPORTANT WAS
THAT- WE'RE MAKING A VERY
EASIER FOR THE PASSENGERS TO
YOU. KNOW GET THERE AND GET-
FROM A TRAIN STATION TO THE
TERMINAL- TOLD MILLIE FLY IN
SO. OF A GUY CLEARLY- THAT'S
SOMETHING WE WANT TO GET TO.
THE QUESTION IS INTERESTS OR
GETS TO A PROCESS ISSUE. HOW
YOU DO IT THE BASS WHILE HAVING
EVERYBODY MOVE. ON THE
ENVIRONMENT REVIEW PROCESS AND
SO THAT'S- CONVERSATIONS WERE
ENGAGED IN. IN REAL TIME RIGHT
NOW. AND I'M HAPPY TO MEET WITH
YOU ON THAT GOING FOR IF I MAY
JUST FOR ONE MOMENT. THE MAN I
AM AWARE OF WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING SO OUT EARLIER. WITH
BURBANK THE INTENTION. WAS
ISSUED TO THE ISSUE. MORE OR
LESS TO FIND OUT WE WORK
TOGETHER. AND GENERATE A
TRANSPORTATION HUB THAT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US. AND
CLEARLY IMPORTANT TO BURBANK.
THE CHALLENGE WAS A MESSAGE ON
OUR SIDE WAS REALLY NOT VERY
CLEAR. AND CERTAINLY
MISHANDLED- I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT- OVER THE YEARS
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT A
INTERACTION WITH. THOSE P. IT
WITH THOSE SAID STAKEHOLDERS
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH IN
AROUND- THAT WAS A VERY
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE I REALLY
DID SEE THE OPPORTUNITY. WITH
WHAT WE COULD HAVE DONE
TOGETHER WITH BURBANK AT THAT
POINT. WELL AGAIN I'M NOT
TRYING TO MAKE THIS ABOUT
BURBANK I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING YOU NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF AND THE ENTIRE.
ACTION OF YOUR PROJECT YOU KNOW
I ONLY EXPERIENCE AND ONE IS
BUT I IMAGINE THAT YOU'RE
HAVING THE SAME KIND OF-
INTERACTIONS WITH OTHER
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE AND
IT'S A CONCERN OF MINE. THANK
YOU WITH THAT THANK YOU. WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK DIRECTOR
KELLY AND VICE CHAIR RICHARDS
AND INVITE THE SECOND PANEL
COME FORWARD. AND AS THEY'RE
COMING FORWARD I WANT TO LOOK
KNOWLEDGE THE BOARD MEMBERS OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
WHO ARE PRESENT. WE HAVE. DANNY
CURTAIN OF COURSE VICE CHAIR
RICHARDS HENRY PEREIRA AND JIM
GILL MATTIE WHO ARE OUR NEWEST
MEMBERS. SO NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE DANTE CURTAIN EVANS
HELEN KIRSTINE LEWIS THOMPSON
STACEY MORTENSEN AND STEPHANIE
WEAKENS
. IF WE CAN- JUSTIN-
TRYING TO KEEP THINGS THE SAME
TO I MAY START WITH MARK EVANS
AND THEN TRANSITION TO DANNY
CURTAIN SINCE YOU HAVE A
PRESENTATION TO MAKE. YES THANK
YOU I MARK EVANS- REPRESENT THE
EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR I WORK
WITH THE DEUTSCHE BAHN
ENGINEERING AND CONSULTING USA
AND- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AND
FELLOW. COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES
I'LL PUT THIS IN A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTEXT FOR YOU LAST- SO YOU
HAVE A PAPER COPY IN FRONT OF
YOU. SO AND RIGHT BEHIND YOU
THAT IS THE PRESENTATION LAST
SPRING OF THE EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR COMPLETED A STUDY
LOOKING AT- TO POTENTIAL EARLY
OPERATION SEGMENTS ONE BEING
THE PENINSULA. FLOOR WHICH IS
FOURTH IN KING THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA- DOWN TO
GILROY STATION AND THE OTHER
CORRIDOR. WAS THE- CENTRAL
VALLEY QUARTER SO A MERCED OR
MADERA TWO POPLAR AVENUE AND
THEN LATER EXPANDED TO INCLUDE-
MERCED AND BAKER SEAL. THE
RESULT OF THAT STUDY IS ON
SLIDE TO. AND THE STUDY
BASICALLY LOOKED AT REVENUE
VERSUS OPERATING INCOME OVER
THAT OVER THOSE CORRIDORS IN
THE FUTURE. AND THE- CENTRAL
CORRIDOR WE DETERMINED THAT'S
WE COULD OFFER MORE TRADE DEALS
THAT ARE THE AUTHORITY BUT
OFFER TRAINING. THERE CAPTION
TRAVEL. PROFICIENT PASTA WHILE
YOU LOOK AT. SANDEL SEGMENT
ALSO FACED AND- BEING A TODAY
THE EIGHT SAN JOAQUIN LAW. ON
THE PENINSULA WHAT ARE WE
BERMAN THAT WITH. DURING ROBUST
ACUTE BILL NETWORK IN THE
FINANCE ORDER WOULD BE PAYING.
STRANGE THING FOR THE RIGHT
STATION INTO TWELVE FOURTEEN K.
BUT IT WOULD BE SOMEONE FROM
APPLE AND YOU ALREADY. AND THAT
WILL ASSIST. WELCOME XIN OF.
THE AND THE AND THE RESULT THAT
WAS PRESENTED IN THE PROJECT
UPDATE REPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA
SPEED RAIL FORTY. A DURING A
DEER IN THE PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT THERE IS A SLIGHT THREE
THERE IS A LOOK AT THE
INVESTMENTS REQUIRED. OF FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THESE
INVESTORS WERE LAID OUT FOR
FIFTEEN POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE- THE- MADERA TWO
POPLAR AVENUE LAKE. NOT
INCLUDING WERE SAID AND NOT
INCLUDING BAKERSFIELD AND IT
WOULD NOT INCLUDE THE PURCHASE
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL ROLLING
STOCK- THE NEXT BAR YOU SEE IN
THE MIDDLE IS CHAU SEVENTEEN
POINT NINE BILLION WOULD BE
REQUIRED IF WE- TEND ITSELF
BAKER. BUILD INCLUDE BUILDINGS
TALK THAT EXTENSION THEN THE
FOR A FALL RIGHT FOR SHIP. TO
BIGGEST INCLUDE. ALSO SAMPLING
STUFF WOULD BE TWENTY FOUR BIT.
QUESTION CAME UP. FIFTY SIX
BROUGH BUT THAT OKAY WHERE IS
THE FOUR POINT EIGHT BILLION
COMING WAS ADDRESS IN THE
QUESTION WAS IS THAT THE BEST.
TO AND THE FOUR POINT EIGHT.
AND SO WE AS THE EACH YOUR
COMMISSION TO THE INCOMPLETE A
SECOND STUDY. WHICH WOULD LOOK
AT THE A SIDE BY SIDE BY SIDE
COMPARISON. OF THAT FOUR POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS BEING
INVESTED IN PENCIL CORRIDORS
SUCH A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OR
CENTRAL VALLEY OR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE LA AREA. SO
WE STARTED IN THE SUMMER TAKING
A LOOK AT THAT ON SLIDE. FOR WE
OUTLINED WHAT I JUST SAID
VERBALLY BASICALLY IS WHAT THE
SCORES WOULD WOULD LOOK AT THE
SELL SIDE BY SIDE COMPARISON
AND BEST WAY TO INVEST. FOUR
EIGHT BILLION. SLIDE I'VE. HE
START OUR QUALITY IF IT TALKS
ABOUT QUALITATIVE ANALYSIS SO
WE BROKE TO STUDY INTO TWO
PHASES PHASE ONE IS A
QUALITATIVE PHASE. SHOT TO THE
STATE OF THE AIR SUCH AS- LÀ
SOME OF THE TRAINING CALTRANS
CAL STAR. AND WHAT REGIONAL
COMMITTEE IN AND OUT. WELL AS
AN- THE EIGHT. WE LOOKED AT.
HOW HOW BEST THE MONEY THOSE IN
THOSE AREAS AS WE GATHER DATE
TO OPEN OPEN SKATE OR NUMBER
ENDING UP OF WHAT THE PIECES IN
HOW WOULD YOU THE FUNDS THEY
ARE CONSTRUCTION. AND IN ONE
FILE. THEY'RE ALL OF MINES. AND
WE JUST PERCENT WE HAVE. IS
THAT WE FROM THERE AND SAW THE
POLITICS OF THEIR EARLY
INDICATOR OF HOW WE THINK THE
QUANTITATIVE PHASE WILL GO IN
THE QUANTITATIVE SPACE WILL
DEEP DIVE THEN INTO RIDERSHIP
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
CONGESTION RELIEF AND THOSE
THREE QUARTERS AND WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT NOW SO THE
QUALITATIVE ANALYSIS WAS
RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC I THINK
JUST A WEEK AGO. AND THE FULL
REPORT IS AVAILABLE ON THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL WEB
PAGE. SO I TAKE YOU TO SLIDE
SIX. ON SLIDE SIX THEN WE GET
REALLY INTO THE MEAT OF FOR
TALKING ABOUT. ALL ALL. TOWARDS
THE CHART IS A LOT OF. ON THE
FAR LEFT. THE THREE CORE FORCE.
CORD OR NO CASH COW BUT THAT
INCLUDES ABOUT FOUR DOOR
SOUTHERN BEFORE BORDER NEXT
CALL. ALSO PROVIDED AT COST.
THE THIRD ONE FROM THE HELP
BLESSED TALKS ABOUT STING
SCENARIO THIS IS WHERE WE ARE
TODAY BEFORE IT MULLIN. AND ALL
THROUGH THE MORE TELL. THE
CHART SCENARIO TO A LOOKS WHAT
YES MA'AM WE COULD PUT IT. IN
THOSE THREE CORRIDORS. HE WHAT
I DID. THIS WOULD BE REQUIRED.
AND IT'S THREE OR FOUR WOULD BE
BORDERS OPERATE IN FOR. SERVICE
IN THOSE QUARTERS BUT THIS PAST
WEEK. I JUST SIT HERE TO BE IN
MONEY THAT WE ARE THERE'S WORK
ON. NUMBER TRAINS DIRECT. THESE
NUMBER BIGELOW STREET. PORTER
WE HAVE A WE'RE MOVING TOWARDS
FOR UP TO FIVE CAL STRAIGHT.
OUR WITH THE OCCASIONAL.
ENHANCES ALIGNED CURRENTLY
BEING- IN CONSTRUCT THEY WILL
ADD THEY'LL HAVE TO SO CAL
TRAINS PER CORRECTION UP OUR
DURING FOR A TOTAL OF SIX
TRAINS BEING OFFERED- AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THERE IS NO
ENHANCEMENT TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BECAUSE IT'S THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM WHICH IS UNDER
CONSTRUCTION SO THERE WOULD BE
NO CHANGE AND THEN IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PRIMARILY
THROUGH METROLINK- YOU HAVE TO
EXPRESS TRAINS PER HOUR FOR
REGIONAL TRAINS PER HOUR PER
DIRECTION DURING PEAK FOR A
TOTAL OF SIX TRAINS. AND NONE
OF THOSE ARE ELECTRIFIED UNDER
THE CURRENT FUNDING SCENARIOS.
IF WE MOVE THE FOUR POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS INTO THE
PENINSULA CORRIDOR. WHAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
THERE IS WE WOULD HAVE AGE
CALTRAIN TRAINS RUNNING PER
DIRECTION OF PER HOUR DURING
PEAK- AND STE IT WOULD BE
ELECTRIFIED AS CURRENTLY. ON A
PLAN FOR THE BILLION DOLLARS
WITH A SAID WE GO FOR IT MOVE.
PACIFIC BACK. TO THE SIDE IN
THE DOOR- AND BRINGING TO WILL
PROVIDE TAX TO SUPPORT HIGH
SPEED UP PROFIT. AGAIN THE
MONEY GOING TOWARDS ENDING. TOP
END UP NORTH. BURKE. TINO SIR
BECAUSE COMPLETED UNDER THAT
SOME. IN CALIFORNIA. THE DISH
OF TWO REGIONAL TRAINS IN THE
TOP I DON'T TO SIX PLUS
RESTAURANTS EIGHT. OUR
PERFECTION IN THOSE ARE ELECT.
SHE POINTED OUT THE CALL TO DO
THE COPS TO A SCENARIO THREE
BOB THIS IS THE RUN BETWEEN
BURBANK AIRPORT ANNA STATION
ONLY THE ONLY AREA THAT'S EARLY
IN CASE. FOR YOU. WE ESTIMATE
THAT WILL REQUIRE I'M SO
BILLION DOLLARS TO CLEAN SENATE
BILL THREE. FOR THE BILL WOULD
COME FROM THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
FUND IT. SENATE BILL FOUR HOW
DO WHICH- WELL HI THE REAL
PERSON THE CORRIDORS. OF WHAT
HE CALTRAIN. GILROY TO JOSE. AS
COMPLY FIVE WE THEN RUN H.
CALTRAIN BRAINS TO SPEED IS FOR
TEN FULL. THE ADDITIONAL COSTS
THERE THREE AND ON TOP OF THE
FOR DINNER THREE AND WOOD. IT
WOULDN'T. INCLUDE HIGH SPEED
ONLY STOCK IN THE DISH FUNDS
WOULD NOT INCLUDE. USED OUT
HAVE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM
POOREST TRADE GO YOU DO HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT RICHARD
CONNECT IT TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. TO ACHIEVE TO EXPRESS
TRAINS PER DIRECTION THAT PEAK
PLUS SIX REGIONAL AND TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL TRAINS WOULD REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
ON TOP OF THE SEVEN AND
SCENARIO THREE SO YOU'RE
TALKING BETWEEN- TEN AND TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH THE
FOUR POINT EIGHT ONLY PARTIALLY
FUNDS. SO WHAT CONCLUSIONS CAN
WE DRAW FROM THAT. IF WE LOOK
AT SLIDE SEVEN. THE MAIN THING
WE'RE SAYING HERE IS THAT UNDER
THE PENINSULAR QUARTER WITH THE
INVEST IN A FOUR BILLION.
DOLLARS I CAN'T. DR THE TRIBE
FROM. WHY BUT YOU CANNOT IN
OVER A HUNDRED MILES AN BECAUSE
THE LEVEL PROCESS IN THAT
COURT. DEFINITELY. THREE EXIST
SYSTEM. BUT QUESTION IS WHICH
WE THREE OR IS THE FALL INTO
ARE YOU BRING TO THE- BILL FOR
ABOUT THE WE WERE BEFORE THE
BILL YOU HAVE A HIGH SPEED
SERVER. WE MENTIONED. IT'S A
HUNDRED AND- OUR AND WERE EVEN
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE. A STEP
CLOSER TOWARDS ROUTE THREE
ROUTE CITY FAURIA. LISTENER ON
THE HELLO NICK CORD. EVE READ
SOME PATIENTS BY. X. AS WELL
SELECT CATION. WELL IN
CALIFORNIA COST OF ROUGHLY OF
BILL OUR- ABLE TO USE. TEN
TWENTY FIVE MILE AN HOUR OR.
THE COUPLE OF MORE JUST
REITERATE WHAT I SPOKE ABOUT SO
I JUST HAD A FEW HIGH POINTS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA QUARTER
REQUIRES RE INVESTMENT ENDED IT
INTO THE HIGH ALAN SMITH AND
THAT'S ADDITIONAL LEAD AND
COMPOUND. AND THE BILLING
SYSTEM AND THIS PLAN HIGHLIGHTS
THE GLORY FOR NON HEIST ROLLING
STOCK IN RIGHT STERN OTHER
PEOPLE THERE MY PERSONAL
EFFECTS FROM STEP ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL SERVICE CLICK WITH THIS
PROGRAM. WHAT DOES ADDS
COMPOUNDS. BUT WE'RE NOT
TALKING BEHIND RAIL IN THE
CORPORATE. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SCENARIOS SIMILAR
BELIEFS. BEING THEM IF YOU OF
THE MONTH ENTER CALIFORNIA IT
DOES PROVIDE FUNDING FOR FEW
WHAT'S IN THE METRO SYSTEM. IN
ANAHEIM AND BANK. NOT ENOUGH.
YOU TOO LITTLE. AND IT WOULD
STILL IT WILL STOP AND IT'S NOT
CAN TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY STILL
I'M STILL ALONE SEGMENTS
WITHOUT ANSWER IN THE REGION
CONNECT THIS MOVE INTO THAT AND
HOT BURBANK. IT WON'T BE
BENEFITS THEY'RE- THAT IS TRUE
ABOUT. SANDEL HIGH SPEED RAIL
OPERATION BETWEEN MERCED IN
BAKERSFIELD AND WE'RE RUNNING
AT TO MILES AN HOUR- WE BELIEVE
WILL CREATE SIGNIFICANT VALUE
SIGNIFICANT TRYST AND WILL ALSO
IMPROVE THE OWNERSHIP EVEN
THOUGH I HAVEN'T ON THE
QUANTITY SECTION THAT'S BUT WE
BELIEVE IN THEIR OWN THE WRITER
WITH ACTION. ENHANCED ACE AND
ENHANCE WALKING. OUR SYSTEM. HE
SAID WE'VE IT POST CATION
INTACT WITH CAL STE IN THE
UPGRADE THE EIGHT SAN JOAQUIN
LAW. PETER LOCKED INTO THE
BACKBONE WORK CITY THE. THREE
MORE THAN DOUBLE REDUCTION OF
TRUCK TIME ALL SPOT FROM THE
PLAYERS YES- AND AGAIN THE
COMPANY IT HAPPENS. ONCE IF
LEAVE THE MONEY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IF THE MONEY IS REMAINS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SERVICE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OR EXCUSE ME IF
WE DO NOT. TAKE A LEAVE THEM
FOUR POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IF WE DO NOT LEAVE IT THERE.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL SERVICE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. WILL BE.
DELAYED UNTIL ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FOR VALLEY TO THAT OF THE
PROJECT IS NOT SO BAD. I HAVE.
HE. YOU'LL HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE BUT YOU
HAVE THE RIGHT START. WE'LL BE
RIGHT THE LIMIT A LIMITED RUN.
FULLER TO CONNECT WITH THE
NORTH THEN WITH MERCED IMMERSED
WITH A SINCE. WILL BE
PROBLEMATIC AS THE EIGHT NINE
WILL THEN DEAD IN TWO PERCENT
SINCE THEN WE- PUT FOLKS
LAWSON. TO MADERA THIS PROBLEM
TODAY OTHER RUN. ON THE SYSTEM
TO THE RIGHT HIGH SPEED RAIL
THE ONLY. OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
WERE BERMAN WILL BE S. NO WAY.
BUT HIGH GROUND AS YOU'RE USING
A DIFFERENT KIND OF SIGNALING
TECH BUDGIE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
SUPPORT FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL THE
USE FOR CONVENTIONAL SO WE'RE
ASSUMING THAT THE RAIL JUST
WOULDN'T BE LEFT THERE ON USE
THAT YOU WOULD RUN SOME
CONVENTIONAL TRAFFIC ON THE-
MADERA TO POP OR RAP. AVENUE
CORRIDOR OPERATIONAL EXPENSES
FOR THAN UNDER UTILIZED OF AN
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSETS SO WE'RE
BUILDING IT FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL
OR USING IT FOR A OF MORE
CONVENTIONAL SYSTEM SO WE'RE-
PROBABLY NOT USING. THE IT TO
ITS FULL EXTENSION AND
POTENTIAL. AND YOU CAN HAVE
LIMITED ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPROVEMENTS BECAUSE IT WILL
NOT BE- ELECTRIFIED. THE MOST
LIKELY BE SOME KIND OF A DIESEL
SYSTEM- AND SO YOU'RE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
OTHER CARBON FOOTPRINT-
OPPORTUNITIES THAT YOU HAVE A
HIGH SPEED RAIL OR NOT ARE NOT
THERE. SO IF WE- DO COMPLETES
THE HOT GO BACK TO SLIDE TEN IF
YOU'LL JUST BEAR WITH ME IF WE
DO COMPLETE THE- THE SEGMENT.
YOU'LL GET THE STANDALONE HIGH
SPEED RAIL OPERATE BETWEEN
MERCED BAKER'S SADDAM RATIONS
AND ALSO START. IT STARTS THE
SYSTEM HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
CALIFORNIA BELIEVE IT. CAN'T
VALUE BY NEXT TO OUR CITIES THE
QUARTERBACK KILLED THROUGH-
SAID I'M MORE TRIP MILE TREK
TRAVEL TIME. IT'S THE A WIDE
REAL PLAN YES MA'AM AND FOR A
DENTAL OPULENCE. SO WE DID OUR
QUALITY I DO NOT THIS AND NOW
I'M DEEP THE QUANTITATIVE
ANALYSIS AND AGAIN WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
SO- MISTREATMENT TO YOUR POINT
EARLIER WEIRD CLOSE
COMMUNICATION. I LOG CAL AND
CAL IS METRIC. THE LOS ANGELES.
NO BETTER THAN SOME OF IT AND
SPIEGEL- TRACK ARE TRANSLATE
THE HOUSE SAM WALKED WELCOME.
WALKING JOIN OUR THOUGHT TO
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION GET
BACK INTO ALSO MAKE SURE WE
CORPORATE. OUR PORT. THE FINAL
REPORT WILL SOME TYPE OF A CALL.
REGIONAL IF IT'S A NEEDS AT ALL
TAKE A LOOK AT AND QUANTITATIVE
DATA ON RACE RIGHT. GAS ACTION
AND I'M JUST REALLY. WE EXPECT
OF THAT. BOARD OF READY MADE OF
Q. ONE TWENTY TWENTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER EVANS AND
BEFORE WE GO ON TO DANNY
CURTAIN AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN SOME
QUESTIONS THANKS GIVEN HOW MANY
OF YOU THERE ARE THINK IT'S
EASIER FOR US WAS FOR ME TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF EACH YOU WHEN YOU
SPEAK INSTEAD OF. BY THE TIME
THEY GET DOWN THERE I WANT TO
REMEMBER WHAT YOU SAID- I HAVE
A QUESTION ABOUT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FULL BUILD SLIDE ABOUT
THE MORE EFFICIENT COST PER
MILE AN IMPROVED COST RECOVERY
FROM FAIR REVENUES PARK SO IS
THE IS PART OF YOUR ANALYSIS
ABOUT- KIND OF THE OF THE- FULL
BUILD. A NOW. I HAVE TO PUT UP
THERE OKAY IT'S NOT THAT
IMPORTANT THAT THE PUT IN THAT.
THE FULL BUILD BEING THE SORT
OF PREFERRED- SITUATION HERE IS
THAT BASED ON. THE FINDINGS ARE
BASED ON THE COST NOT
INCREASING THEM THAT WHAT
HAPPENS IF AS WE BUILD THE
COSTS GO UP IF IT'S NOT EXACTLY
WHAT WE THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
AT THIS MOMENT IF. AS COSTS
OFTEN DO ON LARGE PROJECTS
THERE ARE COST OVERRUNS HOW
DOES THAT CHANGE THE ANALYSIS.
WHEN WE DID OUR ANALYSIS WE
HAVE TO USE THE DATA THAT'S
PRESENTED NOW THE JETTA COULD
CHANGE FOR US ALL OBVIOUSLY IT
HAS CHANGED HIS FOR THE PROJECT
BUT- WE HAD TO KIND OF DRAW A
LINE AND SAY OKAY THIS IS WHAT
WE KNOW OTHERWISE WE START
GETTING INTO MULTIPLE SAY
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT LET'S
ASSUME THAT THE COSTS GO UP.
LET'S ASSUME THAT AS THEY HAVE
FOR THE ENTIRE HISTORY OF THIS
PROJECT THE COSTS CONTINUE TO
RISE. DOESN'T THAT THEN CHANGE
YOUR BOTTOM LINE OF YOU
DECIDING THAT THIS. AT ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT THIS IS THE
PREFERRED. OPTION BECAUSE OF
THAT COST ANALYSIS IF THE COSTS
GO UP. THAT MIGHT NOT MAKE YOU
MIGHT CHANGE YOUR- YOUR-
RECOMMENDATION OF THIS BEING
THE PREFERRED- ALTERNATIVE
CRACKED I THINK OF THE COSTS GO
UP WE WOULD HAVE TO RE LOOK AT
IT AND. RECALCULATED FOR SURE
NOW MY OTHER QUESTION IS. YOU
HAVE A LINE THAT SAYS EARLY
HIGH SPEED RAIL SERVICES CREATE
SIGNIFICANT VALUE. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN WHY WHAT WHAT IS THE
VALUE OF. QUALITATIVE A STAMP
POINT WE'RE LOOKING AT. THE
VALUE OF PROVING THAT IT CAN BE
DONE SO AS OF THE WOMEN I
HIGHLY RAIL IT'S BEEN DONE ALL
OVER THE WORLD I MEAN. NOBODY'S
SAYING YOU CAN'T RUN A TRAIN AT
TWO HUNDRED MILES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. BUT WHAT'S THE
VALUE OF THAT. I THINK IT'S
CHANGING CULTURE IT'S CHANGING
THE MINDSET OF THE- OF THE-
CITIZENS ALONG THE CORRIDOR BUT
ALSO OF POTENTIAL INVESTORS.
SEE I ACTUALLY DISAGREE WITH
YOU I THINK THAT. YOU HAVE THAT
THERE'S ONLY ONE WAY TO PROVE
VALUE. THAT'S RIDERSHIP. YES
THE ONLY VALUE YOU HAVE IT'S
NOT PROVING YOU CAN RUN A TRAIN
A TWO HUNDRED MILES AN HOUR WE
ALL KNOW YOU CAN BUILD A TRAIN
THAT RUNS TWO HUNDRED MILES OUR
IT'S OLD TECHNOLOGY. AROUND THE
WORLD SORT OF A GIVEN. IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD. SO WE KNOW
WE CAN DO THAT- THE ONLY WAY
YOU PRO VALUE. IS IF YOU
INCREASE RIDERSHIP OTHERWISE
IT'S ALL I MEAN WHAT IT WHAT
ELSE WHAT'S THE OTHER PURPOSE.
IT'S INCREASING RIDERSHIP AND
SO I'M SORRY YOU I UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS HEARING IS NOT ON
YOUR TWO YOU KNOW THIS THIS
JUST POPPED UP YOU KNOW. YOU
WEREN'T. DOING YOUR ANALYSIS
FOR THIS. BUT WHAT ALL RIGHT
WHAT WE NEED TO SEE IS THE
RIDERSHIP ANALYSIS THAT'S- AND
WHAT'S WHAT'S MISSING FROM ALL
OF THESE. IS THAT YOU ARE. VERY
DIFFERENT POPULATION CENTERS. A
VERY DIFFERENT NEED FOR MASS
TRANSIT AND ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT AREAS. AND EVEN WITH
THE BEST. MOST CONVENIENT
SERVICE IN THE WORLD YOU STILL
HAVE A CAPPED RIDERSHIP BASED
ON POPULATION WHERE PEOPLE ARE
WORKING ON WHERE PEOPLE ARE
GOING. SO WHAT WOULD I THINK
WHAT WE NEED TO SEE TO HAVE ANY
IDEA. OF WE'RE- WHERE WE
DEMONSTRATE. BY ABILITY IS BY
LOOKING AT THAT INCREASED
RIDERSHIP BECAUSE IN MY MIND
AND JUST TO CUT TO THE CHASE.
ANYTHING THAT WE DO ANYWHERE
ALONG THE SYSTEM ASSUMING THAT
OUR GOAL IS TO BUILD SAN DIEGO
TO SAN FRANCISCO WHICH BY THE
WAY I WANT TO SEE I WANT TO SEE
THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM MY
LIFETIME. I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
GO SAN DIEGO TO SAN FRANCISCO
BUT THE WAY WE GET THERE IS BY
INCREASING RIDERSHIP KIND OF
ANYWHERE ALONG THAT'S THAT
SECTION TO WHERE YOU HAVE A
LARGE POPULATION SAYING WE ARE
NOW. WE'RE IN ON TRAINS WERE
ALL TAKEN THE TRAIN TO WORK
WE'RE ALL TAKING THE TRAIN WE
GO AND CALIFORNIA WE DEMAND
THAT YOU GIVE US THE FULL
SYSTEM. RIGHT UNTIL YOU HAVE
THE RIDERSHIP THAT STARTS TO
DEMAND THAT PEOPLE WANT TO RIDE
THE TRAIN. BECAUSE YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO GET THE WHOLE THING
BUILT BECAUSE IT'S JUST
THEORETICAL SO WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
INCREASE RIDERSHIP KIND OF IN
REAL TIME. AND SO THAT TO ME IS
WHAT DEMONSTRATES. THE PROJECT.
NOT THAT WE CAN RUN A TRAIN A
TWO HUNDRED MILES AN HOUR
RUNNING A TRAIN AND TWO HUNDRED
MILES AN HOUR THAT NO ONE
TAKES. DOES THE OPPOSITE OF
WHAT WE WANT. RIGHT IF YOU
REALLY WANT TO GET INVESTMENT
YOU HAVE TO SHOW THE PEOPLE CAN
BUY THE TICKETS. SO THAT'S WHAT
WE NEED TO SEE IS WHERE DO WE
WHAT WHAT INVESTMENTS DO WE
MAKE. WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL
DOLLARS. THAT INCREASE
RIDERSHIP THE MOST. ALONG THAT
SYSTEM ANYWHERE IN THAT SYSTEM.
THAT SHOWS AN INVESTOR THE
PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO BUY
TICKETS ON A TRAIN. SO THAT'S
MY POINT AND THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO SEE IN YOUR ANALYSIS I
THINK TO REALLY. TOOK YOU CAN'T
HAVE A FINDING YOU CAN'T HAVE A
PRELIMINARY FINDING ABOUT WHERE
TO SPEND THIS MONEY UNTIL YOU
KNOW WE'RE RIDERSHIP. CAN BE
INCREASED THE MOST. SO THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN OF A
PRELIMINARY FACT FINDING THAT
HAS NOTHING ON RIDERSHIP SHOWS
ME THAT. YOU DON'T HAVE A
FINDING. I THINK THE QUESTION
IS WHICH HOW DO WE GET TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL. THE FASTEST IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHAT'S THE
MISSION OF CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. IS OUR
STANDING AS THAT THE MISSION
THIS IS TO PROVIDE A HIGH SPEED
RAIL SERVICE BETWEEN- IN OUR
PHASE ONE. OR THE VALLEY TO
VALLEY. BAKERSFIELD AND SAND.
SEVERANCE OKAY- THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE FOCUSED ON SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT WITHIN THAT CONTEXT
IF YOU HAVE FOR THE MONEY
AVAILABLE AND YOU CAN MOVE IT
ANYWHERE WITHIN THAT VALLEY TO
VALLEY LINE OR EVEN THE PHASE
ONE LINE. WHAT'S THE BEST PLACE
TO HELP YOU ACHIEVE YOUR
MISSION AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT AND I WOULD SAY ONE
MORE THING QUICKLY LOUDEST. AND
THE QANTAS IN A QUANTITATIVE
PHASE WE WILL GET INTO THE
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS AND BILL
WOULD PROVIDE THOSE TWENTY. I
HAVE THAT. I THINK SEE YOU'RE
THINKING OF IT. AS AN ENGINEER.
IS HOW DO WE BUILD THE FASTEST
TRAIN. THEN THE FACETS AMOUNT
OF TIME RIGHT THAT'S WHAT
ENGINEER WOULD SAY HOW DO WE
TAKE THE MONEY WE HAVE AND
BUILD A TRAIN THAT GOES REALLY
FAST FOR THE MOST DISTANCE. AS
A POLITICIAN I SAY HOW DO I
MAKE A TRAIN THAT GETS MORE
PEOPLE ONTO IT SO THAT I CAN
SHOW MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE THEY SHOULD INVEST
MORE MONEY IN TRAINS. I THINK
IT'S A DIFFERENT WAY OF
THINKING ABOUT IT AND WHEN I
HEAR DEMONSTRATING BY ABILITY
IT'S DEMONSTRATING THAT I CAN
GET A LOT OF PEOPLE THE RIGHT
NOW DRIVING TO DECIDE INSTEAD
TO TAKE THE TRAIN. SO JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT I THINK
THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT WAYS OF
DIAMOND OF VIABILITY MEANS HERE
AND I THINK WE NEED TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT IS THE ONE THAT IS
THE EASIEST TRAINED A BILL. IN
THE FASTEST MAN OF TIME AND
THERE'S THE ONE WHO ACTUALLY
GETS PEOPLE TO CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIOR AND I DON'T THINK YOU
CHANGE CULTURE BY DEMONSTRATING
YOU CAN RUN A FAST TRAIN I
THANK YOU CHANGE CULTURE BY
GIVING PEOPLE WHO NEED TO GET
SOMEWHERE A WAY TO GET THERE
QUICKLY AND THAT'S MORE
CONVENIENT THAN DRIVING. OKAY.
THANK YOU IF I MAY JUST AS A
COUNTERPOINT- AS WE PASSED PROP
NAY THERE ARE CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
MATT AND SO I WOULD JUST TO
INSURE THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
INITIATE HIGH SPEED RAIL AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE AS THAT WAS
THE DIRECTION OF VOTERS GAVE TO
US AND IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO TAXPAYERS WITHOUT I'D LIKE
TO NOW TRANSITION TO. DANNY
CARD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- SO MANY QUESTIONS
RATE BUT I'M GOING TO START
WITH THE WRITTEN STATEMENTS SO.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR INVITING
ME. TO TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
HAS BEEN REAL OVERSIGHT HEARING.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S NUMEROUS
COMPLEX QUESTIONS AND ISSUES
THAT THE SERVICE QUESTION AT
THE STATE LEGISLATIVE LEVEL-
THE PROBLEM THAT I AM SEEING AS
HOW THIS DISCUSSION IS BEING
FRAMED- AND IT'S VERY MUCH AN
US VERSUS THEM KIND OF
CONVERSATION ALL OR NOTHING IN
OR OUT. AND I WANT TO START BY
SAYING I AM VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN THE RECENT FRESNO BEE
EDITORIAL REGARDING HIGH SPEED
RAIL I'M GONNA QUOTE THAT
EDITORIAL SINGLE LARGE BRIDGES
AND OTHER STRUCTURES THAT ARE
TO CARRY THE HIGH SPEED TRAINS
ARE UNDER CONSTRUCTION HERE.
AND ONE FEAR HAS BEEN THAT IF
THE PROJECT WHEN FINISHED.
THOSE STRUCTURES WOULD STAND
OUT AS THE STONEHENGE LIKE
MONUMENT TO THE STATE UTILITY
ON THE BULLET TRAIN. I WAS
APPOINTED TO THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL- BOARD IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN BY THE SPEAKER. AND NO
DISCUSSION HAS EVER TAKEN
PLACE. IN PUBLIC OR CLOSED
SESSION AND I PER HEARD ANY
BOARD MEMBER PAST OR PRESENT
MENTION THE IDEA OF ABANDONING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. THOSE
FRAMING THE CONVERSATION IN
THIS WAY ARE ACTING RESPONSIBLY
IN MY MIND AND DOING A
DISSERVICE TO THE FUTURE OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THE VALLEY
AND IN CALIFORNIA. IN FACT
ACCORDING TO THE LAW OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY IS
REQUIRED BY STATUTE. TO BUILD
QUOTE USABLE SEGMENTS. THAT
WILL BENEFIT LOCAL TRANSIT
SYSTEMS IF WE FAIL TO COMPLETE
OUR PROJECT. I HOPE THIS
HEARING WILL HELP REFRAIN THAT
CONVERSATION SO REAL OPTIONS
CAN BE DISCUSSED. LET ME KNOW
HOWEVER THERE HAS BEEN REPEATED
MENTION AND CONCERNED ABOUT
COMPLETING THE BASIC CIVIL
INFRASTRUCTURE TRACK SYSTEMS OF
THE ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE
CENTRAL VALLEY CORRIDOR BY THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DEADLINE. AS
REQUIRED UNDER THE OUR
AGREEMENT THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED QUITE A BIT. SO
MOVING ON. IN A LEGISLATIVE
HEARING IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN SENATOR GALGIANI
POINTED OUT THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS WE WERE ABLE TO GET
HAPPEN TRADE FUNDING IS BECAUSE
OF AGREEMENTS WE MADE TO BUILD
CONNECTED SYSTEMS THAT SERVE
LOCAL AREAS AS WELL AS ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE. BRIAN KELLY-
HIGH SPEED RAIL STE HE AT THIS
TIME- AND- I'M THE SAYS AT THE
SAME LEGISLATIVE HEARING AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. OUR GOAL
HE SAID OUR GOAL IS TO PROVIDE
MOBILITY AND MAXIMIZE
CONNECTIVITY FOR CALIFORNIANS.
WHAT EVER IT TAKES SO THAT THE
PUBLIC CAN START RECEIVING
BENEFITS FROM THE SYSTEM
EARLIER. RATHER THAN LATER.
THAT'S THE DISCUSSION I'M
INTERESTED IN PURSUING. THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT IS IN
THE PROCESS OF PROVIDING A
VASTLY IMPROVED RAIL CARD OR IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. THAT MEANS
NEW DEDICATED TRACK NO LONGER
SHARING TRACKS DESIGNED FOR
FREIGHT TRAINS THAT MEANS
SEPARATE STRAIGHTER AND FASTER
AND MORE FREQUENT PASSENGER
TRAINS. THAT IS NOT IN DISPUTE.
THE QUESTION THAT IS NOT BEING
ADDRESSED IS SIMPLY THIS. IS IT
BETTER TO RIDE A ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILE PER HOUR TRAIN
FROM BAKERSFIELD TUMOR SAID.
BUT THEN HAVE TO GET OFF AND
WAIT FOR A DIFFERENT TRAIN. AND
I MIGHT ADD CAPABLE OF ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILES AN
HOUR. IF YOUR DESTINATION IS
SAN JOSE OR SACRAMENTO. THE UP.
THE ANNOUNCES THAT YOU'VE SEEN
BEFORE YOU IS BASED ON EXISTING
CONDITION NOT ON UPGRADING AN
EXISTING- TRAIN NINE ELECTRIFY
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILES
AN HOUR THAT IS THE ANALYSIS
THAT I HAVE NOT SEEN AND HAVE
NOT. BEEN COMPARED. OR IS IT
BETTER TO HAVE A ONE SEAT RIDE
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FROM BAKERSFIELD TO MERCED.
THEN ON TO SAN JOSE OR
SACRAMENTO ON A ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILES. PER HOUR
TRAIN- THAT GOES TO THE
RIDERSHIP QUESTION. I'VE ASK
PEOPLE THAT QUESTION MANY TIMES.
UNLESS THERE IS A DRAMATIC
DIFFERENCE IN TIME AND- I MIGHT
QUESTION THAT DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN- BAKERSFIELD AND MERCED
IF IT'S A HUNDRED TWENTY MILE
PER HOUR ON TWENTY FIVE MILE
PER HOUR. LOW EMISSION HIGH
SPEED DIESEL VERSUS A HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILE AN HOUR TRAIN
THAT'S A DIFFERENT COMPARISON.
BUT ASSUMING THERE IS NOT A
DRAMATIC DIFFERENCE IN TIME THE
ONE SEAT RIDE IS ALWAYS THE
ANSWER ALWAYS. BUSINESS
TRAVELERS PREFER THE SCHEDULING
CERTAINTY GETTING TO THEIR
APPOINTMENTS ON TIME. BECAUSE
THERE'S A SCHEDULE ON ONE
TRAINED IT'LL HAVE TO GET OFTEN
CHANGE IN THE CONVENIENCE OF A
ONE SEAT RIGHT SO THEY CAN GET
SOME WORK DONE OR TAKE A NAP.
FAMILIES ARE FAR MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SAFETY COMFORT AND
CONVENIENCE OF MOVING THEIR
CHILDREN ON A ONE SEAT RIDE-
YOU JUST HEARD HURTING CHILDREN
AROUND THE NAY- TRAIN STATION
CAN BE PRETTY COMPLICATED EVEN
IF IT IS A GOOD TIGHT-
CONNECTION. A CASUAL TRAVELERS
DEPEND ON ARRIVAL CERTAINTY SO
THEY CAN BE PICKED UP. OR BE ON
TIME FOR THE EVENTS THEY'RE
TRAVELING TO MUSIC
ENTERTAINMENT IT CETERA. SHORT
OF CAREFULLY CAREFULLY
COORDINATED INTER AGENCY AGENCY
SCHEDULING. IT'S VERY POSSIBLE.
THE TIME SAVED ON A HIGH SPEED
TRAIN CAN EASILY BE LOST OR
MADE WORSE BY TRANSFER
TRANSFERS EVEN SMOOVE
TRANSFERS. NEVER MIND THE
INCONVENIENCE. WHAT A TRAVELER
FROM FRESNO. AND I'M GOING TO.
MAKE AN ESTIMATE OR A
GUESSTIMATE WHO SAVE TWENTY TO
THIRTY MINUTES ON A HIGH SPEED
TRAIN AS COMPARED TO A HIGH
SPEED DIESEL AT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILES AN HOUR AND TWENTY
FIVE MILES AN HOUR. WITH A
BENEFIT IF THEY HAD TO TRANSFER
IN ORDER TO TRAVEL ANY FURTHER.
VIRTUALLY EVERY RAIL INDUSTRY
PERSON I HAVE EVER SPOKEN WITH
BELIEVES THAT WITHIN A
REASONABLY COMPETITIVE SYSTEM A
WANTS TO EAT RIDE IS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT WAY TO BUILD
RIDERSHIP GOING TO ASSEMBLY
WOMAN. FRIEDMAN'S POINT. CAN
THE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILE PER HOUR ONE SHEET RIGHT
PROGRAM BE BUILT AT LEAST
SEVERAL YEARS SOONER THAN THE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILE PER HOUR
HIGH SPEED RAIL TRAIN. THE
ANSWER'S YES WELL THE ONE SEAT
RIDE PROGRAM BE DONE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS CHEAPER THAN THE
ELECTRIC TRAIN. THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN PROJECT
UPDATE REPORT INDICATES THERE
WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS.
WOULD BE SMARTER TO WAIT TO
FIND ELECTRIFICATION AND
PURCHASE OF HIGH SPEED TRAINS
UNTIL THEY ARE ACTUALLY NEEDED
FOR A TRUE ONE SEAT RIDE
THROUGH A TUNNEL TO THE BAY
AREA. I BELIEVE WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION AND I'M GLAD
WE'RE HERE HAVING IT ACTUALLY.
THE QUESTION BECOMES WHICH
BUILDING BLOCKS CAN THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY FOCUS ON
TO ADVANCE THE GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM. THEY ARE CONGESTION
RELIEF AND INCREASED RAIL
RIDERSHIP. BY THE WAY THERE WAS
SIGNIFICANT DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE RIDERSHIP. STATEMENTS MADE
EARLIER- WE DIDN'T GET INTO
THEM HERE BUT I HAVE
INCREMENTAL VERSUS SIGNIFICAN
VERSUS INCREMENTAL- IF YOU HAVE
A VERY HIGH RIDERSHIP NEW
HAPPENING INCREMENTAL INCREASE
IN TERMS OF OVERALL RIDERSHIP
THAT COULD BE A LOT MORE
SIGNIFICANT IF YOU HAVE SMALL
RIDERSHIP AND HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE SO I WANT
YOU TO. UNDERSTAND THE NUMBERS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
ASSEMBLYMAN FRIEDMAN- ARE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT NOT NOT THE
TERMINOLOGY. SO INCREASING
REGIONAL CAN ACTIVITY. WHICH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT'S WHY
SEE THERE'S NOBODY ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY WHOSE EVEN
PREPARE TO DOT TALK TO TALK
ABOUT NOT CONNECTING. TO
HOPEFULLY THE A SYSTEM THE
AMTRAK SYSTEM. AND SOMEWHERE
BAKERSFIELD MAYBE A SYSTEM
COMING FROM THE SOUTH
EVENTUALLY BUT CERTAINLY THOSE
TWO SYSTEMS ARE MISSION
CRITICAL. LEVERAGING BUT LOCAL
MATCHING FUNDS AND I WANT TO
ADD THAT COMMENT HERE THIS IS
PART OF THE FUNDAMENTAL- CHARGE
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE
MISSION TO BUILD A HIGH SPEED
TRAIN AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. THAT
IS NOT. I MEAN A HIGH SPEED
SYSTEM IS THE WAY I VIEW THAT
NOT A HIGH SPEED TRAIN ANYWHERE
TO ANYWHERE. BUT HIGH SPEED
SYSTEM THAT WORKS AND IT MAY
TAKE A DIFFERENT BUILDING BLOCK
APPROACH BUT IN OUR CHARGE IN
THE IN THE ACTUAL- THE STATUES.
SELECTING CORRIDORS OR USABLE
SEGMENTS THERE OF FOR
CONSTRUCTION THE OCEAN
AUTHORITY SHALL GIVE PRIORITY
TO THOSE CAR DOORS ARE USABLE
SEGMENTS. THAT ARE EXPECTED TO
REQUIRE THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
BOND FUNDS AS A PERCENTAGE OF
TOTAL COST OF CONSTRUCTION.
WE'RE TOLD TO LEVERAGE MONEY.
THAT MEANS LOCAL MONEY FEDERAL
MONEY ANY MONEY PRIVATE MONEY-
FIRST ABSENT PRIORITIES
INITIATING CONSTRUCTION ON CAR
DOORS OR USE USABLE SEGMENTS.
SO BACK TO THE GOALS. AND I'M
GONNA SAY TRACKING PRIVATE
SECTOR INVESTMENT IS ONE OF
THEM BUT WE HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IT- BUT SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANTLY ADDRESSING THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER THEY
CAME OUT WITH RECENTLY AT THE
QUOTE INDUCED GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE
BUILDING A SUSTAINABLE
INCLUSIVE ECONOMY. THAT MEANS
LOOKING AT THE PACKAGE
HOLISTICALLY WHERE IS THE BEST
VALUE FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FOR INSTANCE. IT NO
DOUBT THE VALLEY NEEDS HELP
THERE BUT AS ASSEMBLYMAN
FRIEDMAN ALSO SAID THERE'S
PLACES IN LOS ANGELES THAT ARE
AS BAD IF NOT WORSE THAN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND IF WE CAN
INCREASE RIDERSHIP IN THOSE CAR
DOORS AT THE SAME TIME WE WILL
BE DOING A BETTER JOB OVERALL
I'M GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
WHICH I THINK IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. IF WE ARE TO
MAXIMIZE THOSE GOALS WE SHOULD
LOOK AT OPTIONS. I DON'T HAVE
THE FUNDS TO BUILD A TUNNEL
BETWEEN THE VALLEY. AND THE BAY
AREA OR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THIS IS THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION. AND I BELIEVE WE ARE
UNLIKELY TO COMPLETE ANY TUNNEL
IN LESS THAN FIFTEEN OR TWENTY
YEARS. IN MY OPINION UNTIL WE
HAVE TUNNELS IN EITHER
DIRECTION. BUILDING CATENARY IS
MAINTENANCE FACILITIES AND I
HIGH SPEED TRAINS IS
UNNECESSARY. CONSIDERING
ADVANCES IN HIGH SPEED
TECHNOLOGY WHICH I HOPE WE MAY
HEAR ABOUT TODAY IT MAY EVEN BE
PREMATURE. UNTIL THAT TIME WE
SHOULD WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS.
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP HERE TODAY X. AMTRAK
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA METROLINK
VERY CRITICAL THEY CAN HELP
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THE COMMUNITIES A LOT
BETTER THAN HIGH SPEED RAIL
COMING IN. WE SHOULD WORK WITH
THEM NOW TO BILL AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE IN HIGH SPEED RAIL
CORRIDORS WITH THE MONEY WE
HAVE. THIRTEEN BILLION INVESTED
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND
SMALLER MUCH SMALLER TARGETED
AND LOCALLY MATCHED INVESTMENT
IN THE BALKANS. IT THAT WAY
IT'S POSSIBLE WE COULD HAVE
THREE USABLE SEGMENTS THAT
BENEFIT ALL CALIFORNIANS
DELIVER BENEFITS TO THE PUBLIC
EARLIER RATHER THAN LATER.
THERE IS NO DOUBT OF ONE THING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WILL HAVE A
VASTLY IMPROVED RAIL TRANSIT
THAT WILL OPERATE AT LEAST AT A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILES AN
HOUR. HOPEFULLY IN A ONE SEAT
RIDE IF WE CAN JUST ARE
THINKING PERHAPS WE CAN DO
SOONER. AND AT LESS COST. THANK
YOU. IF I MAY I'M GOING TO ASK-
DIRECTOR KELLY DID COME FORWARD
IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS BUT- I MAY
START BY SAYING IT'S A BIT
DISINGENUOUS TO QUOTE PART OF
THE OP ED AND NOT. TO LOOK AT
THE REST OF THE WORDS. GOVERNOR
NEW SOME USED WITHIN THAT THAT
AND TORREI OPEN AS HE WAS CLEAR
ABOUT HIS INTENTIONS- I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT THOSE OF US WHO
VOTED FOR CAP AND TRADE. DIDN'T
VOTE FOR IT TO WORK ON HIGHER
SPEED RAIL AND AMTRAK WE VOTED
ON IT TO ENSURE THAT WE COULD
DELIVER HIGH SPEED RAIL FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO ASK DIRECTOR KELLY. IT IS A
QUESTION OF THAT I MIGHT
ADDRESS ON THAT- BECAUSE I'D
LIKE TO RESPOND. I WILL ALLOW
TIME BUT SURE STILL HAVE
DIRECTOR CAN. WELL THERE'S BEEN
A LOT SAID I WAS EVEN QUOTED IN
THE END OF THE TABLE SO I
MIGHT. KNOW RESPONDED THAT-
LOOK CONNECTIVITY IS A KEY
POINT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE LET'S BE REALLY CLEAR.
THE BOND BILL SAID BUILD A HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM THAT CONNECTS
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AREA IN THE
LOS ANGELES BASIN. HIGH SPEED
IS DEFINED IN THE LAW. TO MILES
PER HOUR MORE NINE HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILES IN THE VALLEY.
NOT ONE TEN AND I WANT TWENTY
FIVE. THAT'S IN THE LAW TODAY.
SO THAT IS WHAT WE ARE
INTENDING TO BILL. UNLIKE ANY
OTHER REGION OF THE STATE RIGHT
NOW. AND THE DECISION THAT WE
DO NOT MAKE YOUR ALONE. BUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S TO GET
STARTED SOMEWHERE THEY SAID GET
STARTED IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO THIS IS THE ONLY REGION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
HUNDRED NINETY MILES. INTO
CONSTRUCTION. SO THE QUESTION
IS. DO WE FINISH THAT
CONSTRUCTION AND HAVE A LINE
FROM MADERA TO POPLAR AVENUE.
IN THE MIDDLE OF AN ORCHARD.
WHERE DO WE EXTENDED TO CONNECT
THREE THE FASTEST GROWING
CITIES. IN THREE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING COUNTIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. MERCED FRESNO
BAKERSFIELD. WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL THAT IS CONNECTED. TO AN
EXPANDED A SYSTEM THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
RESPONDING. TO THE TUNE OF
ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS. ETS
EXTENSION NUMBER SAID- AND. THE
SAN JOAQUIN'S LINE TO OAKLAND.
AND SACK. MY VIEW IS YES I KNOW
I'M CERTAINLY NOT OF NOT A- SHY
ADVOCATE A WHAT I'M
RECOMMENDING TO MY BOARD. YOU
KNOW I HAVE A HUNDRED NINETY
MILES IN A CONSTRUCTION NOW.
AND WHEN WE LEAVE THE VALLEY.
I'M GONNA LEAVE THE VALLEY WITH
VALUE. AND THAT DOES NOT MEAN A
LINE. THAT IS NOT OPERABLE. AND
I WANNA BE REALLY CLEAR. WE
DIDN'T CHOOSE THIS OFF THE TOP
OF OUR HEADS. WE WERE VERY
CLEAR IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN. THAT BECAUSE WE
HAD FUNDING CONSTRAINTS WE WERE
GOING TO ASK OUR EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR TO LOOK AT OPTIONS AND
GIVE US ADVICE. IN KNOWING THAT
WE STARTED WITH A HUNDRED
NINETY MILES AN ABOUT. THEY
TOOK A LOOK AT THAT AND THEY
SAID. THE BEST LINE YOU CAN DO
IN THE VALUES IN IN A ROOM
SERVICE MATTER. IS MERCED
FRESNO BAKERSFIELD. THAT'S WHY
WE ARE PURSUING THIS. ON THE
RIDERSHIP QUESTION THERE'S NO
QUESTION. THAT RIDERSHIP GROWTH
IS KEY. UNDER THE EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR ANALYSIS THAT WE GOT
BACK IN OUR PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT WE'RE DOUBLING THE
RIDERSHIP. IN THE VALLEY.
DOUBLING THE RIDERSHIP. WE'RE
EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF TRAINS
THAT CAN BE DONE. BUT I CAN
OPERATE ON THIS LINE. WE'RE
DOING IT QUICKER AND WE'RE
DOUBLING THE RIDERSHIP. SO THEY
ARE NOW GOING THROUGH A PROCESS
TO WERE LOOK AT THOSE NUMBERS.
REFINE THEM THEY'LL COME BACK
TO MY BOARD WAS- A SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS. I GUESS MY
LAST COMMENT IS JUST THIS. IS
SAD WERE HAVING A CONVERSATION
THE WAY WE'RE HAVIN IS DANNY'S
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE- THE
SUGGEST THERE'S- YOU KNOW
THERE'S DIVIDE BETWEEN PEOPLE
WHO SEE THE WORLD THE SAME WAY.
I GUESS I THINK IT'S
UNFORTUNATE TO. THE IDEA TO
DIVERT MONEY FROM WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW AND SPEND IT ON
REGIONAL SERVICES TO ME. IS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH THE MISSION OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL THAT'S MY VIEW.
DAN IT'S GOT A DIFFERENT ONE I
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA. TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT YOU WANT TO BE LEFT WITHIN
CITY CALIFORNIA WHAT I THINK
WOULD BE A TRAGEDY. IS IT
DIVIDE THE DIVERTED THE MONEY
TO OTHER PLACES. AND YOU'RE
LEFT WITH GOVERNMENTAL SPEED.
IMPROVEMENTS ON LARGELY DIESEL
SIR. AT THE END OF INVESTING
THAT MONEY ELSEWHERE. AND A
HUNDRED NINETY MILE LINE
BETWEEN MADERA IN POPLAR.
SITTING IN THE VALLEY. THAT'S
WHAT I THINK WOULD BE TRAGIC.
AND SO MY VIEW IS. GET THE HIGH
SPEED ELECTRIFIED RAIL GOING
FINISHER ENVIRONMENTAL WORK.
AND THEN WORK ON FUNDING THE
GAPS. IN THE LA BASIN INTO THE
BAY AREA. AND WITH THE
EMERGENCE OF A PRIVATE TRAIN.
OPERATOR DEMONSTRATE INTEREST
SELECT A FIVE SPEED RAIL TODAY.
WE PROBABLY GOT HAD TO DO THAT.
THAT'S A BETTER CONVERSATION
LATER CERTAINLY THE ONE RIGHT
NOW. SO IF I MAKE- I THINK
WE'RE GONNA HOPEFULLY HEAR FROM
THE- PARTNERS WHO WILL ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS. BUT I
THINK- BRIAN POINTED OUT TO THE
US FOR STAND HE SHE PRETTY
CLEAR TO ME. AND I WILL READ
FROM THE EDITORIAL FOR A
SECOND- IT'S SIMILARLY TAKING
MONEY FROM THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT. AND DIVERTED TO RAIL
SYSTEMS IN THEIR READ. THAT'S
THE EDITORIAL FACT OF THE
MATTER IS AND WE'RE NOT
DIVERTING IT FROM HI FI RAIL
PROJECT TO PUT IT INTO OTHER
TRAIN OPERATION IF THERE IS ANY
DIVERSION IT'S GOING TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL TRACK THAT WE JUST
LIKE THERE IS IN THE BALLOT.
THESE ARE TRACKS THAT WILL HAVE
TO BE BUILT THERE ON OUR CAR
DOORS SO TO IMPLY THAT IT'S
SIMPLY TAKING MONEY FROM HERE
TO PUT IT OVER THERE AT THE
EXPENSE OF HIGH SPEED RAIL THE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES AND IT WAS
ABOUT IS OUR CHARGE TO GET A
HIGH SPEED TRAIN UP AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE OR IS THE BILL THE
SYSTEM THE BEST WE CAN UNTIL WE
CAN GET A HIGH SPEED SYSTEM
WELL. THAT'S A FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOT A
STRANDED ASSETS AGAIN THAT'S
THE US VERSUS THEM. IT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A COMPLETE SYSTEM
IN THE VALLEY THAT WILL GET YOU
TO THE BAY AREA. OR SACRAMENTO
ON A ONE RIDE ON A TRAIN THAT
CAN GO ON AND TWENTY FIVE MILES
AN HOUR. NOT A PODIUM TRAINING
FROM OF WHATEVER FIELD HE SAID
TO ANOTHER PLACE THAT IS NOT
THE OPTION WE'RE NOT HAVING THE
REAL CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT
OPTION. IF WE CHOOSE THAT
OPTION OR IF WE CHOOSE ONE OF
THESE OPTIONS IT DOES PRESENT
POTENTIAL FOR MORE MONEY TO BE
INVESTED INVESTED ON OUR CAR
DOORS. TO DO THE THINGS WE NEED
TO DO. ANYWAY TO GET A HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM UP AND I WANT
TO MAKE ONE POINT. ABOUT THE
FOR THE SPEED. THERE'S NO WAY A
HIGH SPEED TRAIN AND SO THE
CALIFORNIA OR IN THE BAY AREA
IT'S GOING TO TWO HUNDRED MILES
AN HOUR. PERIOD END OF
DISCUSSION A HUNDRED TEN TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE I BELIEVE
IS THE MAXIMUM POSSIBILITY. THE
ONLY PLACE THAT IS IN THE
VALLEY. YES WE COULD BUILD THAT
AND ZOOM UP AND. DOWN BUT WE
WOULD BE BETTER OFF CONNECTING
TO EIGHT. A SYSTEM THAT CAN RUN
AT A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILES
AN HOUR. AND MAKE IT BETTER CAN
ACTIVITY AND BUILD RIDERSHIP.
BUT THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION. IF I MAY THE IBM OR
PROP ONE A WAS VERY CLEAR ABOUT
NEEDING A TRUCK CAM THAT RUNS
TWO HUNDRED MILES PER HOUR BUT
LOST. SO IF WE ARE UNABLE TO
BUILD THIS CENTRAL ABOUT THE
SECTION WE ARE UNABLE TO THEN
MEET. THE REQUIREMENTS OF PROP
ONE ATTY AND UNFORTUNATELY I
DON'T LIKE TELLING VOTERS WHEN
THEY TOLD US QUITE
SPECIFICALLY. WHAT THEY WANTED
FROM US SO THAT WE ARE CHANGING
PLANS. SO DO YOU THINK THE
VOTERS TOLD YOU TO BUILD A HIGH
SPEED TRAIN. NO MATTER WHERE NO
MATTER WHY BECAUSE WE WANT TO
SEE HIGHS BE RETRAIN. OR THEY
WANT TO BUILD A HIGH SPEED
TRAIN SYSTEM AND GET THE MOST
BENEFITS OUT OF BUILDING THAT
SYSTEM. FROM NOW UNTIL WE
COMPLETED. THAT'S THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION IN MY
OPENING STATEMENT SITE
REFERENCE WHAT PROP ONE A
SPECIFIC. ASKED US TO DO THAT'S
WHAT I BELIEVE THE VOTERS WANT
US. TO DO. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW. MISTER JIM. YOU KNOW I
THINK THE- IT'S A FOR THIS IS A
THIS OR THAT CONVERSATION
BECAUSE. I THINK THE KEY IS WE
KNOW NOW IS WE HAVE A FINITE
BUDGET BEFORE US HERE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY OF MY
BUDGET A MISSION IN THE LAW
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
CONTROL AND- BUT WE HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO DO. THINGS
IMPORTANTLY HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
MILES IS NOT A CHUMP CHANGE.
ROUTE THAT'S A PRETTY LOW ON
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL ROUTE GET
STARTED IT IS THE BEGINNING NOT
THE END BUT WE START THAT WE
FINISH THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK.
ALL THE WAY FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I IN ANAHEIM AND THEN YOU WORK
ON THE FUNDING APPS AGAIN YOU
HAVE THE EMERGENCE OF A PRIVATE
ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL
OPERATOR. NOW ENTERING THE LA
BASIN FROM THE EAST AND- MAKING
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- BASIN
AN INTERESTING PLACE TO
CONSIDER HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
TOGETHER. BOTH THE STATE IN A
PRIVATE PRIVATE PARTNER. I'D
ALSO SAY THERE ARE A LOT OF
REVENUE STREAMS OUT THERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
BETWEEN CAP AND TRADE AND OTHER
THINGS. IN IT YOU KNOW THE
ISSUE IS HOW BIG IS THE PIE-
RIGHT NOW I'VE GOT A VERY
CONSTRAINED PIE THAT I'M
WORKING ON- BUT THERE ARE.
OTHER CAP AND TRADE PROGRAMS-
AND- THE IDEA OF UTILIZING SOME
OF THESE THINGS SO THAT WE CAN
DO MORE CONCURRENT INVESTMENTS-
IN THIS AREA SO THAT WE CAN
BOTH- CONSTRUCT WHAT WE WANT TO
CONSTRUCT IN THE VALLEY. AND
FORD EXPANDING REGIONAL
SERVICES IN THE LA BASIN AND
THE BAY AREA. I THINK THERE'S A
POTENTIAL THERE I THINK THE
QUESTION IS HOW CAN UTILIZE CAP
AND TRADE DOLLARS BEYOND WHAT'S
DEDICATED TO US. TO DO THAT. I
THINK WHAT WE REACT TO IS THE
IDEA WE SHOULD TAKE IT FROM
THERE AND SPEND IT THERE AND
THAT'S WHAT WOULD I THINK WE'RE
PUSHING BACK I THINK. THE IDEA
THOUGH THAT WE CAN. LOOK AT A
BROAD. REVENUE SOURCE IN
CALIFORNIA AND FIGURE OUT. HOW
CAN WE BEST UTILIZE THIS TO
CHIEF COLLECTIVE OBJECTIVES. I
HEARD ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN
SAY EARLIER. YOU KNOW SHE WANTS
TO RIDE THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
TRAIL. I WANTED TO RIDE THE
HIGH SPEED ROTARY. SHE ALSO
WANTS IMPROVEMENTS ON. THOSE
THE MORE TRADITIONAL SERVICES
IN- IN OUR REGION I WANT THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS TO. AND I AM
CONVINCED. THAT WHEN THE SPINE
SYSTEM THAT DOES GO FAST.
CONNECTION THOSE REGIONAL AREAS
IT WILL LIFT RIDERSHIP ON ALL
OF. THE BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN THE
EXPERIENCE AROUND THE GLOBE.
WHEN YOU TAKE A HIGH SPEED
TRAIN FROM ONE CITY TO ANOTHER.
AND YOU GET IN THAT CITY WITH
THE CONNECTED TRAIN STATION.
PEOPLE TEND TO GET OFF THAT AND
USE LOCAL TRENDS. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE LIKE TO SEE REPEATED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO IT'S A
HEALTHY ROBUST CONVERSATION. I
DON'T FEEL LIKE WE'RE ON THE-
OPPOSITE SIDES OF WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE AT THE END IT'S KINDA HOW
WE GET THERE. AND I THINK MAYBE
WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT HOW THAT
PIE COULD BE EXPANDED AND
UTILIZED. AS OPPOSED. TO TALK A
WAR BETWEEN REVENUES BETWEEN
DIFFERENT ENTITIES. SOMEONE
FRIEDMAN ANY QUESTIONS BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO HELEN CURSED.
WELL FIRST I AM REALLY
ENJOYING- THE CONVERSATION.
UHHUH MMHM I IS JUST REMIND
EVERYONE YOU TALK ABOUT PROP
ONE A ALSO IT WAS VERY SPECIFIC
THE PUT THE VOTERS AS A
CONNECTION BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES IT'S
NOT A CONNECTION BETWEEN PARTS
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS A MUCH
IS THAT'S IMPORTANT TO THE
SYSTEM AND WE HAVE TO KEEP THAT
IN MIND. AND THE RESTRICTION
ABOUT THE HIGH SPEED PART AS
FAR AS I KNOW WAS ON THE BOND
SECTION ON THE CAP AND TRADE
SECTION WHICH IS A MUCH LARGER.
PORTION OF THE FUNDING SO I
THINK WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WE
SAID WE'RE GOING TO SPEND THE
MONEY ON ONE THING AND NOW
WE'RE TAKING IT TO SOMETHING
ELSE NO NOBODY IS SUGGESTING
USING IT FOR SOMETHING ELSE
EVERYBODY IS SAYING HOW DO WE
DO WITH THE VOTERS ASSETS TO DO
WHICH IS TO BUILD HIGH SPEED
SERVICE AFFECTED TRAIN SERVICE.
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS
ANGELES AND DO IT IN A WAY THAT
BRINGS US CLOSER TO THAT VISION
OF BEING ABLE TO GET ON A
TRAIN. AT UNION STATION OR
BURBANK. TO GO TO SAN DIEGO BUT
AT LEAST FOR PROP ONE IS
PURPOSE. AND NORTH. OF AND THE
QUESTION IS DO WE DO THAT BEST
BUY STICKING THE COURSE AND
DOING THAT. TRUE HIGH SPEED
SERVICE. BETWEEN THE AREAS THAT
WE HAVE IT UNDER CONCERNED-
CONSTRUCTION OR DO WE- SPREAD
THE MONEY FURTHER UP AND DOWN
THAT LINE WHICH WAS THE GOAL
THAT WHOLE LINE. AND GET MORE
GET THAT MIND WORKING AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE AND
THEN- COMPLETE THE PROJECT AND
I DON'T THINK THAT PUTS US ON
OTHER SITES I DON'T THINK
THAT'S ABOUT MOVING MONEY FROM
ONE REGION TO ANOTHER AND
CHANGING THAT EXPERIENCE I WANT
THE PEOPLE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. TO GET ON THE TRAIN AND
TO DO THAT THEY HAVE TO HAVE
THE BEST AND MOST SEAMLESS
TRAIN EXPERIENCE AND I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT MR CURTAIN
POINTS OUT ABOUT HAVING TO
CHANGE TRAINS AS SOMEONE WHO'S-
HAD TO CHANGE ON A LOT OF
TRAINS TO DEAL WITH THE
STROLLER AND A BACK AN INFANT.
THAT MAKES YOU THINK TWICE
ABOUT DOING IT. AND SO I THINK
WE ALL NEED TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
THOSE SPEEDS ARE WHAT WILL
REALLY INCREASE RIDERSHIP AND
JUST SAY IF WE DO THIS WE
DOUBLE THE RIDERSHIP WELL WHAT
ARE WE COMPARING THAT TO WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY NOT DOING NOTHING
YOU'RE ON. INSTRUCTION WE WANT
THAT CONSTRUCTION TO BE
COMPLETED NO ONE IS TALKING
ABOUT WALKING AWAY FROM THAT.
HAVING A- BRAIN THAT'S SEPARATE
HAVING PASSENGER TRAIN THAT
SEPARATE FROM. RAIL TRAIN IS
VERY IMPORTANT MAKING THESE
IMPROVEMENTS IS IMPORTANT BUT
HOW DO WE HAVE A- EXPERIENCE
THAT GETS THE MOST PEOPLE ON TO
THE TRAIN. IS WHAT I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ASK ABOUT AND WHAT
IS THE- BASS LINE YOU'RE
COMPARING IT TO AND NO ONE IS.
I'VE HEARD PEOPLE SAY WE WERE
BANNED IN THIS PROJECT I DON'T
THINK ANYONE'S TALKING ABOUT
WALKING WHEN ABANDONING ANY OF
THE INVESTMENTS. THAT BEEN MADE
OR STOPPING ANY THOSE
INVESTMENTS. SO IF I MAY THOUGH
I MEAN. HERE WE STAND AT WHERE
THE HIGH RAIL STATION WILL BE
AND- INTO A KNOWLEDGE THAT ARE.
RAIL LINE IS ROUGHLY A MILE
PLUS FROM HERE. IT WILL BE
THROWAWAY COSTS IF WHAT YOU ARE
SUGGESTING NEEDS TO BE
FOLLOWED. SO I THINK THERE IS
QUITE A BIT OF DISCUSSION THAT
NEEDS TO BE HAD BEFORE YOU
GUYS. SEAMLESSLY SAY THAT
THERE'S A TRANSITION TO DIESEL.
OR THAT THAT'S EVEN A
CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
HAD IN THIS MOMENT. I THINK
WE'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
BEFORE AND IT'S ROBBING PETER
TO PAY PAUL. AND I THINK WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
DELIVER ON A PROJECT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. AND WOULD LIKE. THAT
TO BE THE FOCUS OF WHERE WE
GET. LET ME JUST ASK MISTER
CURTAIN I MEAN WHAT WHAT WOULD
WE PIECE OF THROWING I MEAN
WHAT. I THINK THAT WERE VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS ABOUT WHAT
PEOPLE ARE INVESTING WHAT THE
SUGGESTION IS. I'M NOT SURE.
FIRST OF ALL I REALLY WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
OTHERS ON THIS BUT I'M NOT SURE
WHAT REFERENCE TO THROWING WAY
COST YOU MAY HAVE COMPARED TO
THE SORT OF ENGINEERING- THE
TRACKING SYSTEMS ISSUES UP THIS
IS MADE OF VERY VERY COSTLY
PROJECT- AS AGAIN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FRIEDMAN SAID IT'S BEEN
RARE THAT WE HAVE DONE- NOT
USED ALL OF THE CONTINGENCIES
ON OUR COSTS THERE ARE CONSTANT
PROBLEMS. THE REAL ISSUE IS
WHAT'S THE BEST INVESTMENT USE
OF OUR MONEY THEY AMOUNT WE
HAVE WILL BE THE BEST RETURN
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OF
COURSE IT WILL BE THROWN AWAY
COST I THINK YOU'LL BE THROWING
COST EITHER WAY YOU GO- YOU
KNOW YOU CAN ELECTRIFY STE-
TRACKS THAT ARE NOT ELECTRIFIED
THEY'RE DOING IT IN THE
PENINSULA. IT'S WHETHER YOU DO
IT NOW AND YOU PUT THAT OUT FOR
COSTS TEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS
BEFORE YOU NEED ELECTRIC TRAIN
TO PROVE THAT YOU CAN DO IT
THAT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
ME THAT THAT WILL NOT ATTRACT
INVESTORS THAT WILL MAKE
INVESTORS THINK THEY STILL
HAVEN'T GOTTEN TOGETHER ABOUT
HOW TO BUILD THE TRAIN TERMS TO
GET PEOPLE ON THAT TRACK THAT'S
THE WAY I VIEW NO MATTER OTHER
PEOPLE. INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR
MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT VIEW.
CERTAINLY DIDN'T COME HERE TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMENTS. I READ
THIS IN FACT IN THE FRESNO BEE.
IT WAS A LITTLE DISTURBING I
THINK THEY MISSED CHARACTERIZED
THE REAL ISSUES HERE. SO AGAIN
WE COULD GO BACK AND FORTH AND-
CHARM AS- SHE- KELLY AND I.
COULD DO THIS FOR A WHILE- AND
I'M ASSUMING WE CAN ALL DO THAT
BUT I'D- I'D REALLY LIKE TO
HEAR FROM. MY MOTHER'S HAPPY TO
MOVE FORWARD. HELLO CHRISTY.
HEARING MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK
TO YOU TODAY I HAVE THREE MAIN
POINTS I WANT TO DISCOVER VERY
QUICKLY I. AM OF THEM HAVE BEEN
TOUCHED ON BY PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
AT ONE OF THE LABOR THEM TOO
MUCH. I THE FIRST ONE IS REALLY
ABOUT THE PROJECTS FUNDING
SITUATION SO AS YOU KNOW THAT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM SOME OF THE
OTHER- PENALIZED- THE PROJECT
DOES FACE A SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
GAP SO RIGHT NOW THE
AUTHORITIES ESTIMATING IT. WILL
HAVE APPROXIMATELY THE AMOUNT
TO DO THE MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
MINE- BUT WE'RE ABOUT PROBABLY
BY THEIR ESTIMATES ABOUT SIXTY
BILLION SHORTEN THE FULL PHASE
ONE. SO I THERE IS THERE IS
REFERENCE THAT MAYBE THERE
COULD BE TAPPING INTO SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDS BUT AT THIS
POINT IT'S UNCLEAR WHERE THOSE
WOULD COME FROM- AND WE DO KNOW
THAT THERE IS A RISK THAT THIS
FUNDING GAP COULD GROW- THIS
PROJECT HAS EXPERIENCED- FIND-
COST INCREASES IN THE PAST AS
YOU'VE HEARD. US SO THAT COULD
BE A PROBLEM AS WELL IS. THERE
SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE
FEDERAL FUNDS- WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS HAS-
RAISE THE POSSIBILITY OF
WITHHOLDING- THERE ARE THREE.
POINT FIVE BILLION AND RE
SENDING SENDING THOSE FUNDS. SO
THE SECOND MAIN POINT I WANTED
TO MAKE- WHICH HAS BEEN TOUCHED
ON AS WELL IS THAT. REALLY THE
LEGISLATURE HAS. OPTIONS FOR
MOVING FORWARD SO CERTAINLY
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD IS ONE I
THINK THIS IS A REALLY. VERY
HELPFUL IN PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION TO HAVE ABOUT
WHETHER THAT'S THEIR APPROACH
THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO TAKE-
OR WHETHER IT WANTS TO FIND
SOMETHING ELSE SO WE COULD
FIND. A SMALLER. PORTION IS
INITIAL CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT
TIED IN. WITH YOU A LONGER
SECTION- YOU COULD DO
ELECTRIFIED. RAIL AS WE TALKED
ABOUT YOU COULD DO DIESEL YOU
COULD DO SOME OTHER
ALTERNATIVE- TECHNOLOGY AS WELL
THAT HAD. YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN
PILING. PILOTING OF OTHER TYPES
OF TECHNOLOGY SO THERE'S A WIDE
RANGE OF THINGS THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED- WE THINK THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE REALLY
PRODUCTIVE MANNER AND ARE VERY
HAPPY THAT THE- THAT THEY'RE
TAKING PLACE. AND THEN THE
FINAL POINT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
IS THAT. WE THINK THIS IS
REALLY A CRITICAL DECISION
POINT FOR THE LEGISLATURE- I
SET. LEGISLATURE IS GONNA MOVE
FORWARD- AS CURRENTLY PLANNED
WE THINK THROUGH THE SOONER THE
AUTHORITY HAVE THAT CERTAINTY
THE BETTER- AND IF NOT. REALLY
MAKING THIS CHOICE NOW RATHER
THAN LATER I THINK IS ALSO VERY
VALUABLE SO THE AUTHORITY FOR
EXAMPLE HAS INDICATED. THAT
THEY MAY MOVE FORWARD WITH
PROPERTY ACQUISITIONS AS SOON
AS NEXT YEAR. ADDITIONALLY
THEIR PLANS TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH A TRACKING SYSTEMS
PROCUREMENT- WE UNDERSTAND IN
THE SUMMER. SO THAT WILL BE AT
A PRETTY. GET PROCUREMENT WILL
INVOLVE PURCHASING. THEY
ELECTRIFIED TRACK AND HAVING
THAT- THAT CONTRACT IN PLACE.
AND ALSO A MAINTENANCE CONTRACT
AS PART OF THAT AS- WELL. AND
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THE STATE
WERE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
CONTRACT AND IF IT. WERE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THESE
PROPERTY ACQUISITIONS- IT'S
GONNA MAKE IT PROBABLY A LITTLE
BIT MORE CHALLENGING FOR THE
STATE TO. CHANGE COURSE IN THE
FUTURE IF THAT. IF THAT
DECISION THE LATE LEGISLATURE
MAKES AT A FUTURE DATE FOR
EXAMPLE. SO WE THINK IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT REALLY
GOOD THAT WE'RE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS NOW THEY'RE- NOT
EASY CONVERSATION THERE A LOT
OF TRADE OFFS AS WE- AS WE
DISCUSSED ON. BUT WE THINK IT'S
REALLY VALUABLE TO HAVE THIS
BACK AND FORTH AND REALLY THINK
THROUGH. IS THAT THROUGH THE
STATE. THERE ARE PLEASE.
CONTACT GETTING THINGS. IN PROP
ONE NAY. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FRIEDMAN I APPRECIATE BEING
HERE TODAY TO YOU FOR THE
INVITATION. I'LL TRY TO BE
BRIEF- SAVE TIME FOR QUESTIONS
AS WELL I DO WANT TO MAKE A
COUPLE OF BRIEF POINTS FIRST. I
AM CONCERNED THAT THE HIGH
LEVEL OF THIS DISCUSSION WE NOT
FORGET THAT WE'VE GOT TO BUILD
TRACKS BETWEEN MADERA AND
POPLAR AVENUE. THAT IS THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE FEDERAL
MONEY AND THAT IS IF WE DO NOT
DO THAT EXPOSE OURSELVES TO A
REAL LIABILITY- ESPECIALLY IF
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION. IS
REELECTED I THINK THEY WILL DO
NO FAVORS TO CALIFORNIA AND IF
WE EXPOSE OURSELVES SO BE HAPPY
TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN. OF OUR
LETTER IN THIS REGARD OUR
LETTER OF THE AUGUST THE TWENTY
THIRD EXPRESSED A CONCERN ABOUT
THE- THE- PROPOSAL BY THE
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE A SINGLE
CONTRACT IT WILL COVER
ESSENTIALLY EVERYTHING FROM.
HERE TO SAN FRANCISCO WE THINK
THAT POSES A REAL DANGER TO THE
SIMPLE JOB OF GETTING THE TRACK
WORK DONE. SO THIS SHOULD NOT
THEY SHOULD BE CONSIDERED VERY
CAREFULLY AND I THINK OF A REAL
DELIBERATE DECISIONS SHOULD BE
MADE. IN OUR PAST LETTERS IN IN
TESTIMONY WE'VE STRESSED TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT YOU HAVE
OPTIONS THERE'S NOT JUST ONE
CHOICE ON THE TABLE THERE ARE
OPTIONS. REALLY RIGHT NOW OF
THE TWO OPTIONS THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT WOULD BE ONE TO HAVE
A KIND OF A CONVENTIONAL SYSTEM
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THEN
SHIFT MONEY TO THE ENDS. AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING THE OF FULL
HIGH SPEED SYSTEM FROM MERCED
TO OF BAKERSFIELD. ONLINE
FOCUSING ON THAT. IN SUMMARY
TERMS THE ADVANTAGE OF THE
FULLY ELECTRIFIED- APPROACHES
THAT YOU YOU WOULD BUILD HIGH
SPEED RAIL AND YOU WOULD
DEMONSTRATE TRAIN TRAVELING AT
HIGH SPEED. OF BUT I THINK IT
WOULD BE LESS LOGICAL TO DO
THIS ANALYST THIS ALSO IMPLIES
A FULL COMMITMENT BY THE STATE
TO FINISH THE SYSTEM. IT WOULD
NOT MAKE A LOT OF SENSE TO
COMMIT TO BUILDING JUST HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WITHOUT BEING COMMITTED
TO GOING ON FROM THERE AND
FINISHING THE SYSTEM. AND I
WOULD ADD THERE IS NO FUNDING
IN PLACE TO DO THAT. IN THIS IS
BEEN A REPEATED PROBLEM OF THE
PROJECT AND IT IS ONE WHICH
REALLY SHOULDN'T BE- SWEPT
UNDER THE RUG. THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO CONFRONT THIS ISSUE OF
IF YOU REALLY ARE GOING TO
BUILD A SYSTEM. THEN THE
OPTIONS FOR FINANCING THE
SYSTEM SHOULD BE EXPLORED IN
AND THE DENNIS FIGHT IF YOU
CAN. THE ADVANTAGE OF THE OTHER
OF PROVED AS IT WOULD PROVIDE
IMPROVE SERVICE- AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OVER WHAT YOU
HAVE NOW. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
GENERATE LARGE BENEFITS TO THE
PASSENGERS ON PATROL LINK AND
CALTRAIN IN THE NEAR TERM.
THERE WAS ALWAYS THIS QUESTION
OF WHETHER YOU SHOULD START AT
THE ENDS AND BILL TOWARD THE
MIDDLE OR START IN THE MIDDLE
AND I DON'T TO WHERE THE ENDS.
AND THAT IS STILL THE OPTION
THAT'S BEFORE US I THINK
THERE'S NO QUESTION BUT WHAT
SPENDING MONEY ON THE ENDS
GENERATES MORE IMMEDIATE
BENEFITS THAN SPENDING MONEY IN
THE MIDDLE. IN THE LONG RUN IT
DOESN'T MATTER AS LONG AS
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO FINISHING
THE SYSTEM. IN ANY EVENT THERE
ARE UNCERTAINTIES CAN BOTH
OPTIONS INCLUDING COST SCHEDULE
AND SCOPE THERE IS STILL WIDE
RANGE OF VARIATION ON EXPECTED
COST. OF TIMES TO COMPLETELY.
AND THERE WILL BE WIDE
VARIATIONS ON DEMAND FORECAST
NO MATTER WHO DOES THEM AND HOW
THEY DO. THAT THAT DAY OR AT
THE DATA DO NOT EXIST. IN THIS
IS A GREEN FIELD SITUATIONS
VITAL THAT WE'RE FACING SO.
WHERE IS DONE WILL BE SUBJECT
TO REAL UNCERTAINTY. ALL I
THINK THEREFORE WE SHOULD FOCUS
ON THIS FACT THAT IF WE GET
THERE ARE WERE DONE ON TIME
THERE IS NO REASON TO BE IN A
HURRY ABOUT THE OTHER DECISIONS
THAT NEED TO BE MADE. WE CAN
TAKE OUR TIME WE CAN HAVE THE
OPTIONS TO FIND CAREFULLY WE
CAN BE SURE THAT THE NUMBERS
ARE AS GOOD AS THEY CAN BE. AND
WE DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH
QUALITATIVE ARGUMENTS THAT
ALWAYS CONCERNS ME I WANT TO
SEE THE BEST ENGINEERING AND
THE BEST ECONOMIC ANALYSIS IN
QUANTITATIVE TERMS. I WANT ALL
IN ONE PLACE BEFORE I WOULD
RECOMMEND TO YOU THAT YOU MAKE
ANY DECISION AT ALL. THANK YOU
MISTER THOMPSON AND I TO LOOK
FORWARD TO THE QUANTITATIVE
ANALYSIS IF THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO NOW MOVE
ON TO MISTER MORTENSEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. THE ETL AND I HAVE A
RUNNING JOKE ABOUT THIS PROCESS
BECOMING A BEAUTY PAGEANT. AND
WE ALWAYS FEEL LIKE WOMEN NOT
MIGHT NOT BE THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
CONTESTANT WHEN ALL THE- THE
SCORES ARE AND- WE HAVE TO MAKE
LIGHT OF IT BECAUSE- THE
DIFFICULT. LOOKING AT MOVING
MONEY AROUND THE STATE AND
COMPETING FOR IT AND THAT
NONTRADITIONAL WAY THIS ISN'T
USUALLY HOW WE GO ABOUT- THE
FUNDING PROCESS. I REPRESENT
BOTH THE A SERVICE IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN SAID MANAGE THESE FOR
TWENTY ONE YEARS IN THE SEMI
CANS FOR JUST UNDER FIVE. WORK
SIDE BY SIDE WITH ALL OF THE
CEOS OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY SINCE MANY MORE
SHOULD WORK SIDE BY SIDE AND
FRANKLY OUT RIGHT TALENT THEM
AT TIMES. IN FULL DISCLOSURE I
VOTED NO ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
BOND NOT BECAUSE I DIDN'T THINK
IT WAS WORTH WHILE. YEAH CAM A
TRAFFIC ENGINEER WHO IT WAS
MOVED TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
BENEFITS OF RAIL AND ITS
TRANSFORMATIVE NAY- BUT I
WORRIED EXACTLY THIS WOULD
HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA WOULD
STRUGGLE TO PULL THAT OFF AND-
YOU KNOW I GRIND MY HANDS AND
HAVE A BATTLE OF CONSCIENCE ALL
THE TIME. IN MY ROLE ON THIS ON
THE PEER REVIEW GROUP AND THEN
AS NOW IN THE SEARCH THIS AND
THEN AFTER THE VOTERS DID VOTE
FOR IT I FEEL AN OBLIGATION AS
A BIRTH CONTROL TO PURSUE THAT
EVEN THOUGH. PERSONALLY YOU
KNOW I HAD MY DOUBT. IS A
WATERSHED PROJECT AND IT WILL
MEAN A LOT AROUND THE STATE AND
IT NEEDS TO GET BUILT
EVERYWHERE IT WAS PLANNED.
HOWEVER I'M NOT PLEASE GOTTEN
HOW THE AUTHORITY IS GETTING
THERE AND SO ARE YOU DO
STRUGGLE WITH SOME OF THE OTHER
PLAYERS ON THE PANEL. I JUST
DON'T THINK THE LARGEST PROJECT
OVER TIME SHOULD BE SUCH A
ROLLER COASTER RIDE. BACK I CAN
REMEMBER NOW THE FIRST TIME WE
SWITCHED AND ZIG AND ZAG- MY
REGION WAS A LITTLE DISMAYED
BECAUSE THE FIRST CONNECTION
WAS GOING TO BE BUILT TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT DÂN
LIVE IN AND I RAMPED UP OUR
REGION TO BE EXCITED ABOUT THE-
CONNECTION TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FROM THE VALLEY. WAS
IMPORTANT IT WAS ONE OF THE
TWO. OTHER LEGS OF OUR SCHOOL
BAY AREA SACRAMENTO IS ONE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS ANOTHER
ECONOMICALLY FOR FAMILY AND SO
WE RALLIED AROUND THAT CHOICE
AND WE HAD OUR REGION SUPPORT
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY.
WITH ZAGGED AGAIN NOW NOT GOING
ON SO. TO THE WEST. ILLEGAL
PULLED OUR STRAPS UP RIGHT DOWN
AND WE GOT EVERYONE TO SUPPORT
THAT MOVE BECAUSE IT MIGHT BE
OF AFFORDABLE AND WE GET THERE
SOONER BUT WITH EVERY ZIG AND
ZAG THE PUBLIC CONFIDENCE HAS
ERODED AND SO WHEN I GET IT
HERE NOW AND HERE YOU KNOW THE
REALLY DIFFICULT THIS TENDS
WERE HAVING I WORRY ABOUT
ANOTHER TURN IN THE DIRECTION
AND HOW WE CARRY THIS OUT IF
THIS IS THE MODEL WE SAY AGAIN
SAG. AT SO MANY TURNS NOT THAT
IMPROVE THE RAIL SYSTEM. GREAT
FOR THE THEY- LEFT TO ASK FOR
THE MONEY FOR THE ACE OF THE
SAND ROCK JOAQUIN ROUTES. BUT
WE GOT SOME OF THAT
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING THROUGH
THE OTHER STATES SOURCES AND-
I'M HOPING AND I WOULD WORK
VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE OF
THESE. OTHER URBAN PLAYERS ARE
FIRST IN LINE FOR SOME OF THESE
OTHER RESOURCES. BUT I WORRY
THAT IT WOULD VANCE HIGH SPEED
RAIL IN THE SAME MANNER AND TO
YOUR POINT ABOUT. DO WE HAVE A
SPECIFIC GOAL ABOUT THAT I
THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE EXPLORED
FURTHER. WE HAVE SOME VERY
PURIST IDEAS ABOUT HOW TO DO
IT. AND THEN INSTEAD OF LIKE A
MIDDLE IDEA WE JUMP TO ANOTHER.
SIDE I THINK THERE IS A MIDDLE
THAT WE COULD GET TO I DO
BELIEVE WE DEMONSTRATE HIGH
SPEED TRAINS AND DO RUN THREE
GRAINS. IT'S NOT ON ALL THE
PERSON WHO DOES NOT THE MODEL
SOME PEOPLE PREFER. I THINK
IT'S POSSIBLE AND I THINK IT'S
WORTH EXPLORING IF IT LETS US
DO. SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS
THAT MIGHT MY COLLEAGUES WOULD
LIKE TO SEE. I THINK MERCED IS.
A DEAL BREAKER I THINK YOU HAVE
TO HAVE ONE OF THE ENDS THIS IS
MY PROFESSIONAL OPINION ONE OF
THE ENDS OF THE SYSTEM HAS TO
BE ROBUSTLY. ACTED I THINK I
COULD FUDGE A LITTLE BIT ON.
THE SOUTHERN PORTION A LOT OF
THAT AS BEST CONNECTION FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. NOT
WITHSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE OF
MY CITIES IN THE SOUTHERN
VALLEY I THINK WE COULD KEEP
SOME NON COMPETITIVE SAN
JOAQUIN SERVICE FOR THEM. BUT I
THINK MERCED. BEING CONNECTED
AT THAT JUMPING OFF POINT IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I THINK
THAT'S CRITICAL BE VERY HARD
FOR ME TO SUPPORT SOMETHING.
THAT DOESN'T HAVE THAT. I THINK
ONE OF THE IDEAS WE'VE COME UP
WITH. THE EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR
IS COMBINING THE SYSTEMS I'M
INTRIGUED ABOUT THE VIRGIN
CONCEPT AND I HAVE REACHED OUT
TO THEM IF THERE'S A WAY TO
TAKE. A SAID THIS MY CANS AND
WHATEVER OPERATE THIS FIRST
SEGMENT AND REGION THE BUSES
THAT GO TO. IN CALIFORNIA THERE
WE HAD KIDS THAT WITHOUT. A
DOUBT. FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR
SOMETHING MUCH MANAGE MORE
FUNGIBLE MOVE YOUR PENCIL.
REVENUE IS AROUND. THE
PROTECTOR HAS EXPRESSED SOME
INTEREST BUT THAT TAKES A LOT
OF COORDINATION. AND A FULL
SECTION BEING BUILT. BUT JUST
SAY HAVING SINCE AND WAS PASSED
IN AND VERY I AM VERY GOOD
MUSCLES FROM WRINGING MY HANDS
OVER AND OVER SOMETHING HAS TO
CHANGE WE NEED A SERIOUS
SERIOUS LOOK AT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO GET THERE IT REALLY TAKES A
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT LUIS RIGHT WE'VE
SAID THAT FOR YEARS THERE HAS
TO BE A COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT. OR WE END UP IN
A PLACE WHERE WE JUST HAVE TO
GO TO A BUILDING BLOCK SO I'M
I'M HAPPY THAT YOU ASKED FOR MY
IMPRESSION IMPRESSION ON THIS
ISSUE AND- ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
IF I CAN HELP. YEAH I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU SAID
BUT- OF- THAT- YOU HAD TO HAVE
A JUMPING OFF POINT IN THAT IS
A DEAL BREAKER I DON'T
UNDERSTAND. WHAT'S THE DEAL
BREAKER. I DON'T I I'M SORRY I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT YOUR-
POINT I THINK WE'RE SAID FROM
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
PERSPECTIVE IT IS A PLACE BUT
THERE'S A NATIONAL TRANSIT
CONNECTIVE ITTY. AND PLANNED
INITIAL A BUS SERVICE TO WE'RE
STARTING BUS SERVICE TO SAN
JOSE FROM MERCED. IN
ANTICIPATION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
GETTING THERE. THAT THE A
SERVICES GOT THE SAN JOAQUIN
JUST GOT A LOT OF THE
CONNECTING BUS TO THE COAST AND
TO THE YOU SOMEBODY NATIONAL
PARK. IF THE JUMPING OFF POINT
IS THERE SAID FROM THE FIRST
PIECE INSTEAD AND WE'RE LIMITED
TO THAT NORTHERN AND- I BELIEVE
THEN YOU HAVE TO. AND POINTS OF
THE SERVICE GRANTED YOU WOULD
HAVE THROUGH TRAINS BUT YOUR
PORTIONS. AT HIGHER SPEED. ARE
ARE BOTH. LESS AND METROPOLITAN
AREAS WITH CONNECTIONS SO I'M
SORRY I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
MERCED THAT MERCED IMPORTANT
BUT WHAT ARE YOU SUGGESTING IN
TERMS OF THE TRAINS CAN YOU CAN
YOU BRING THIS DOWN A LITTLE
BIT FOR ME AS SOMEONE IS NOT A
YES I DON'T DO THIS EVERY DAY
TO SURE SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE
MAP I'M SUGGESTING THE PEACH
THAT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY IS BILL RIGHT NOW ALL
THE PEACE THAT THEY CAN. LEAD
ON THE NORTHERN AND COMPLETE.
MERCED RIGHT. AND THEN AT THE
END OF THE SEVENTH. TO BEGIN-
MISREAD DEAL BREAKER MEANING
THAT IS THAT THE CENTRAL MISS
FRIEDMAN I'D MAYBE THIS HELPS
OUR CURRENT NORTHERN
TERMINATION POINT MADERA. IN SO
WHICH IS ADVOCATING IS YOU KNOW
A BREAKER FOR HER IS IT'S GOT
TO GO TO THE ALL THE WAY TO GO
TO SEX RIGHT THAT THE PLACE OF.
RIGHT REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
IT'S THE TWO HUNDRED MILE AN
HOUR TRAIN OR THE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILE AN HOUR YOU
WEREN'T A PINING ABOUT THAT
JUST OKAY THAT'S WHAT I WASN'T
CLEAR THAT MIGHT IT THERE'S
VERY LITTLE DISPUTE ABOUT. THAT
CONVERSATION IS THIS QUESTION.
WHAT'S THE SYSTEM. WITHOUT ALL
NOW MOVE ON TO MISS WEEKEND CEO
OF NATURAL. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
AT THIS OVERSIGHT OVERSIGHT
HEARING. I AM STEPHANIE WE CAN
CEO OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY KNOWN
AS METROLINK WE OPERATE OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT ROUTE
MILES AND PROVIDE MOBILITY AND
CONNECTIONS TO PEOPLE IN OUR
SIX COUNTIES OF LOS ANGELES
ORANGE RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARDINO
VENTURA AND SAN DIEGO. 85% OF
THE WRITERS ON OUR SYSTEM OUR
CHOICE WRITERS WHO HAVE ACCESS
TO A CAR AND THE AVERAGE TRIP
LENGTH IS THIRTY SIX MILES ONE
WAY GIVEN THOSE FACTS WE ARE
EXCITED TO HAVE ACHIEVED RECORD
RIDERSHIP OF ELEVEN POINT NINE
MILLION BOARDINGS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN. OUR
RECORD COMES ON THE HEELS OF
FIVE YEARS OF CONSISTENT
RIDERSHIP GROWTH AT A TIME WHEN
MANY TRANSIT SYSTEMS HAVE
PLAYED TOTAL OR SEEN DECLINES
ARE RIDERSHIP REPRESENTS A 28%
REDUCTION IN TRAFFIC VOLUME
DURING PEAK HOURS. THE
EQUIVALENT OF TWO PARALLEL FREE
PLANES ASK THE SCHOOL YEAR
METROLINK REMOVE NINE POINT
THREE MILLION CAR TRIPS OFF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ROADS
ELIMINATING OVER A HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND METRIC TONS OF
GHG EMISSIONS IN OUR AIR BASIN
THAT'S THE EQUIVALENT OF CARBON
CAPTURED BY A HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND ACRES OF FOREST.
THE HEALTH OF OUR REGION CAN'T
WAIT I STARTED MY TIME THAT
LINK WITH A COMMITMENT TO
DOUBLE RIDERSHIP IN FIVE YEARS
THAT MEANS THAT WE WANT TO
ELIMINATE NEARLY TWENTY MILLION
CAR TRIPS FROM MARKET TESTED
ROADS THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
GET THERE. FIRST WE ARE
INVOLVING OUR CULTURE THE
FOCUSING AT LEAST CUSTOMER IN
JANUARY I MADE A COMMITMENT TO
BRING WIFI TO THINK THAT'S THE
MOST WITH THE AMENITY BY
WRITERS OF THE DAY EIGHT. JUST
WE LAUNCHED OUR FIRST BY FIVE
THAT'S TRUE. SHIP WITH EIGHTEEN
NO AFTER. THE TO THE BENEFIT
MISSION WHO ARE CULTIVATING THE
BALL THE WAY WE DO BUSINESS
WITH THE CUSTOMER AT THE TOP OF.
SECOND WE STARTED IMAGINING
CARES PROGRAM TO BETTER
HIGHLIGHT THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL IMPACT OF OUR SERVICE
THROUGH COMMUNITY FOCUS
PARTNERSHIPS WITH ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE NOT TRADITIONALLY
BEEN A PART OF THE TRANSIT
CONVERSATION SUCH AS THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION.
THEY RECOGNIZE WHAT WE ALL KNOW
WHICH IS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
OVERALL BETTER HEALTH AND
IMPROVED QUALITY OF LIFE WHEN
THEY WALK MORE AND PEOPLE WALK
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE WHEN THEY
TAKE THE TRAIN. THIRD WE ARE
INVESTING IN OUR SCORE PROGRAM
THIS CAPITAL PROGRAM IS MEANT
TO TRANSFORM THE MEASURE LIKE
SYSTEM BY THE TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC
GAMES. THROUGH THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL FALL FROM THE
SYSTEM MOSTLY FOCUSED ON
COMMUTE HOURS IN THE PEAK
COMMUTE DIRECTION TO ONE WHERE
COMMUTERS AND LEISURE TRAVELERS
CAN RELY ON US. HAVING TRAINS
OPERATING THROUGHOUT THE DAY
AND ADDITIONALLY THESE
IMPROVEMENTS BENEFIT OUR RAIL
PARTNERS LIKE THE STATE
SUPPORTED LOS AND SERVICE AND
OUR CLASS ONE FREIGHT OPERATORS
WHO HELPED FUEL THE ECONOMIC
ENGINE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THANKS TO A TRANSIT IN INNER
CITY CAPITAL RAIL PROGRAM GRANT
FROM CAL STATE WE'RE OFF TO A
GREAT START BUT AS WE ALL HOPE
MORE IS NEEDED. FINALLY I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT METROLINX ABILITY
TO BE A GAME CHANGER FOR AIR
QUALITY CONFORMANCE IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AIR BASIN.
OUR NEAR TERM FUTURE IS ZERO
EMISSIONS FUTURE THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT
ELECTRIFYING DOORS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND WHILE HIGH
SPEED RAIL MAY NEED OVERHEAD
CATENARY INFRASTRUCTURE
METROLINK DOES NOT. INSTEAD
METROLINK NEED AMERICANS A
QUICK THAT IS FLEXIBLE SCALABLE
TO ALLOW FOR YOU. TO SPEAK
BURBANK AND I. OR AND
THROUGHOUT. AND IF IT INVEST.
TO FUTURE AND RELEASED IN OUR
P. TO STUDY RETROFITTING LEGACY
DIESEL MODE LOCOMOTIVES WITH
ONE OF THE QUICKLY EVOLVING
TECHNOLOGIES. ALSO WE ARE
WORKING WITH NUMBER AGENCIES
AIR RESOURCE AGENCIES AND
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE PARTNERS TO
ACCELERATE EVALUATION AND
DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY. THIS WILL MODERNIZE
OUR FLEET AND FACILITIES IN THE
SHORT AND LONG TERM FOR THE
BENEFIT OF CURRENT AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS. ALL OF THESE
INITIATIVES WILL ACCELERATE
METROLINX TRANSFORMATION TO A
PREMIER SERVICE THAT CONNECTS
THEM IN CALIFORNIA. SO WHEN THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY ASKED US TO SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT INVESTMENTS
THAT COULD HELP THEIR LONG TERM
GOALS RELATED TO NETWORK
INTEGRATION AND EARLY
INFRASTRUCTURE DELIVERY. WE
LOOK AT THE BURBANK TO ANAHEIM
CORRIDOR AND ITS IDENTIFICATION
IN THEIR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN AS PART OF THE
PHASE ONE SYSTEM. METROLINK IN
ITS MEMBER AGENCIES ALREADY
INVESTING ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE QUARTER
THROUGH OUR CAPITAL PROGRAM.
AND THE BURBANK TO ANAHEIM
QUARTER CURRENTLY HAS A HUNDRED
THIRTY TRAIN MOVEMENTS EACH
WEEK WEEK DAY. LOOTING FREIGHT
AND PASSENGER TRAINS. SO LET ME
BE CLEAR. SHOWING HAS ASKED
ABOUT REPROGRAMMING OR MOVING
ANY FUNDS WE SIMPLY RESPONDED
TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITIES REQUEST DIED BY THE
INVESTMENT NEEDS AND BENEFITS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. ANY NEW
FUNDING WE CAN SECURE FROM THE
STATE EIGHT THOUSAND METER LEE
LEVERAGE. PROGRAM FDA'S OR
CAPACITY POTENTIALLY BLING IN
NEW STATE INVESTMENT. THE
RESPONSE WE RESPOND THE
RESPONSE WE PROVIDED TO THE
AUTHORITY. LINES THE BENEFIT
AND ASSOCIATED PRODUCTS IN TWO
PHASES. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT A SIMPLE
THEY ARE FULL. AND IT. VISION
FOR. THIS FREQUENCY IS AT
CONTRACT TIME SAVINGS IN THAT
CORRIDOR REPRESENT A COMPELLING
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTRACT NEW
PASSENGERS. DO G. EMISSIONS.
CURRENTLY METROLINK HAS OVER
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION ANNUAL.
BOARDINGS ALONG THE BURBANK AND
HOW QUARTER OVER TIME. THESE
IT. WILL REDUCE THE PASSENGER
TRAVEL TIMES BY 22% WELL
TRAFFIC CONGESTION IN THE
REGION CONTINUES TO GROW GIVING
PEOPLE BACK THEIR TIME IS
PRICELESS AS ANYONE WHO NEVER
GET SOMETHING CALIFORNIA
TRAFFIC KNOWS. IN CLOSING WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AS YOU REVIEW THE BEST WAYS TO
ADD VALUE TO THE RAIL
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK IN
CALIFORNIA. INVESTMENT A
METROLINK IS AN INVESTMENT IN
OUR SHARE PRIORITIES OF
CONGESTION RELIEF IMPROVED AIR
QUALITY AND SAFE RELIABLE
MOBILITY SOLUTIONS. THESE
PRIORITIES ARE FURTHER
ARTICULATED BY THE STATE IN SB
SEVEN FORTY THREE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER. REDUCING VMC AND REFUSED
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS IS WHAT
INVESTING AND MORE RAIL IN
CALIFORNIA WILL MEAN. I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT MORE FUNDING IS
NEEDED FOR ALL REGIONS IN THE
STATE. THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY I WELCOME
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU MISS WILLIAMSON MISSY
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN HAS
ANY QUESTIONS IF NOT IN.
RESPECT TO THE PUBLIC- TO COME
HERE TO TESTIFY. I WILL HAVE
DIRECTOR KELLY CLOSE THIS PANEL
AND THEN WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. A MINUTE MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THINK I JUST SORT OF
WRAP UP OUR PERSPECTIVE BY- YOU
KNOW NOTING WHERE WE SAID IT
MAKES US A LITTLE BIT UNIQUE
VERSES BUDDY ELSE AND THAT IS
THAT. CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY HAS STRICT
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
HAVE TO MEET. A IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE DO NEXT IN THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE TO GET DONE IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS WE ARE
COMMITTED. TO MEETING THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THAT MEANS
COMPLETE ALL OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK. STATEWIDE
IN GETTING OUR A HUNDRED NINETY
MILES CONSTRUCTED IN THE VALLEY
PLUS TRACK- IN THE VALLEY AND
THAT IS OUR FIRST PRIORITY- THE
QUESTION IS WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
AVAILABLE. TO US AFTER THAT.
THE VEIL FUNDING TO UP TO THAT
WE WITH THOSE. THAT WE DO THE
LINK PERCENT WE HAVE A- URBAN
LINK AT THE SOUTH END AS WELL
IN BAKERSFIELD AND THAT WE GET
THAT RUN. GOING ONE OF THE THAT
MAKES US UNIQUE VERSES
METROLINK BARK OR. CALTRAIN OR
LA METRO OR ANY OF THESE OTHER.
IS WE DO NOT HAVE ACCESS. TO
FUNDING OUTSIDE OF THE FUNDING
IT'S DEDICATED US IN THE BOND.
WE GOT ZERO OUT OF SB ONE- IN
THOUGH THE WERE THOSE FUNDING
POTS GROW. THERE ARE YEAH WE
HAVE CAP AND TRADE WE'VE GOT A
PERCENTAGE OF CAP AND TRADE.
THAT WE HAVE BUT ASIDE FROM
THOSE POTS- WE GOT WE DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO OTHER FUNDING
POTS- IN SO THE PROGRAM LIKE
THE D. I. R. C. PRO. P. PROGRAM
THAT'S AVAILABLE OTHER TRANSIT
ENTITIES. IS MADE UP OF TWO.
FUNDING POPS CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS GO TO THE C. T. I. R.
C. P. PROGRAM. ASIDE WHAT COMES
ASIDE FROM WHAT STYLES. IN SB
ONE BOLSTERED THAT PROGRAM AND
WE DON'T SEE ANY OF THAT. SO
THE ISSUE IS AGAIN- I'M NOT IN
IT I'VE NOTICED. WITH THE
IMPROVEMENTS. THAT METROLINK
WHAT TAKE I THINK THEY'RE GREAT.
THEY DID PROVIDE A RESPONSE TO
US AT A COST OF ABOUT NINE
POINT EIGHT. MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A SERIES OF CAPITAL
PROJECTS THAT. OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS. IF YOU DIVERTED
EVERY TIME WE HAD JUST LA THAT
BE ABOUT HALF OF THAT AMOUNT-
AND SO. YOU KNOW RATHER THAN GO
DOWN THAT ROAD AGAIN I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND A WAY
GOING FORWARD- TO HAVE US USE
THE REVENUES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR US. TO BUILD THE SYSTEM
THAT WE ARE REQUIRED TO BUILD
AN MANDATED TO. BUILD WITH THE-
AND FIND WAYS TO EXPAND OTHER
RESOURCES- TO BOTH. EXTEND OUR
SYSTEM AND INVEST IN SHARED
CORRIDORS WE CAN. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. THE WEIRD LÀ
TOGETHER IN THESE CORRIDORS FOR
EXAMPLE I SAID EARLIER ALL OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK THAT'S
GOING ON NOW IN THE CORRIDOR
BETWEEN BURBANK IN ANAHEIM. TO
ADD TO ELECTRIFY PASSENGER
TRACKS TO THE CURRENT FREIGHT
LÀ. DOWN THERE IS WORK THAT
DOESN'T JUST BENEFIT HIGH SPEED
RAIL. BENEFIT HIGH SPEED RAIL
WILL BENEFIT METROLINK. IT'LL
BENEFIT LOS UP. A AND THE SAME
IS TRUE IN THE BAY AREA. THE
STATE CAN ELECTRIFY THE
CALTRAIN SYSTEM ALL THE WAY TO
GILROY. AND WE CAN- MAKE OTHER
INVESTMENTS- I IN STATION
MANAGEMENT- THE DIVERT ON
STATION FOR EXAMPLE A MUCH LIKE
THE LA UNION STATION IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS PROPOSED
TO BE UP A MAMMOTH- STATION
THAT SERVES ALL KINDS OF
PROVIDERS NOT JUST US. SO
THERE'S GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THINGS THE OTHER WHAT I'M
HOPEFUL IS AT THIS CONVERSATION
COULD MOVE FROM LET'S YOU KNOW
TAKE MONEY THAT ARE FAIRLY
WALLED OFF IN TERMS OF WHO HAS
ACCESS TO THEM AND FIND WAYS
TO. LOOK AT HOW WE CAN- ENHANCE
THAT PIE ROW THAT PIE IN A SURE
THAT WE CAN GROW BOTH METROLINX
OF THE WORLD AND ALLOWS TO
BUILD TRULY ELECTRIFIED HIGH
SPEED RAIL THE FIRST STATE IN
THE NATION TO DO THAT. AND OUR
VISION IS TO GET THAT DONE SO
THANK YOU MISTER. WITH THAT I
KNOW THIS IS AN ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION HEARING BUT TO
REFLECT MY COLLEAGUE EX OFFICIO
MEMBER ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY BOARD. SENATOR PELL
HE HAS TALKED ABOUT HOW WE GROW
THAT. AND WHETHER OR NOT THERE
NEEDS TO BE EXPANSION IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT- ALL SECTIONS OF
HIGH SPEED. BUILT WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO
COME FORWARD AND MAKE THEIR
COMMENTS AND WANT TO THANK THIS
PANEL FOR THEIR TESTIMONY
. IF
WE CAN TRYING KEEP OUR COMMENTS
TO A MINUTE THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED YOU WILL START TO
HEAR THE BEEPING ONE THE MINUTE
COPS. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SAYS WHOSE VARGAS PRESIDENT AND
FOUNDER OF THE S. C. A SMALL
BUSINESS FOCUSED. ON PROVIDING
LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOUR. MY
DREAM AS A CHILD WAS TO WORK
WITH PLANES TRAINS AND
AUTOMOBILES I'M LIVING THAT
DREAM I'M ALSO REALIZING THE
DREAM FOR MANY PEOPLE HAVING
HIRED. SEVERAL FOLKS IN THE FAT
AND THE VALLEY TO WORK IN
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. I
PLEAD THAT YOU KEEP THE FUNDING
IN THE VALLEY. WE HAVE PLANTED
MANY SEEDS TO CONTINUE WORKING
IN THE VALLEY AS MY FIRM. ON
I'M HERE SPEAKING AS A FORMER
OWNER. NOT REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE NOR THE CONFERENCE
MINORITY TRANSPORTATION
OFFICIALS NOR A HIGH SPEED RAIL
BUSINESS ADVISORY COUNCIL
MEMBER OF WHICH WE ORIGINALLY
HAD MEETINGS TODAY. I WAS
HOPING TO HAVE ANOTHER MINUTE.
ON THE INTENT IS TO REQUEST
THAT WE KEEP THE PROJECTS GOING
SO THAT I WOULD NOT HAVE TO.
LET GO OF STAFF THAT WORK FOR
THE FIRM THAT WERE HIRED FROM
THE VALLEY WE HAVE OVER 35% OF
THE OF MY FIRM OF FORTY PEOPLE.
THAT ARE FROM THE VALLEY
WORKING IN THE VALLEY I'D LIKE
TO NOT MOVE THEM. TO THE BAY
AREA NOR TO ALL A BECAUSE THAT
WILL INCREASE THE M. P. AND
WILL CAUSE HARDSHIP ON THEIR
FAMILIES. LET'S KEEP THE
PROJECT GOING ONE AND BUILD
WHAT WE INTENDED TO BUILD A TWO
HUNDRED MILE SYSTEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I'M DAVID SHOWN
BROWN I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT
FOR POLICY OF THE AND WRITERS
ASSOCIATION. OF CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE- AS AN ORGANIZATION LONG
RECOGNIZED CALIFORNIA'S NEED
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL HOWEVER WE
HAVE CONSISTENTLY OPPOSED THIS
PROJECT BECAUSE THE WRONG
PEOPLE DESIGNED IT IF THE
PRIVATE SECTOR HAD DONE THE
DESIGN YOU WOULD NOW SEE
SIGNIFICANT PRIVATE INVESTMENT
IN THE PROJECT. THE FACT THAT
THERE IS NO PRIVATE INVESTMENT
IS CONCLUSIVE EVIDENCE THAT
THIS PROJECT VIOLATES BASIC
RULES FOR A SUCCESSFUL REAL
BUSINESS THIS CEO FOR CHS OUR
RATE HAS BEEN QUOTED SAYING
COMPLETING THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT WILL DRAW IN PRIVATE
INVESTMENT WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT. THAT'S PREPOSTEROUS
WHAT BUSINESS IS GOING TO
INVEST IN A PROJECT THAT CAN
ONLY DEMONSTRATE ITS ABILITY TO
LOSE MONEY THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHECK REAL HAS- THE
ELECTED HEAD OF THE FRESNO
MADERA TO OUR KINGS BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL THIRTY TWO YEAR
MEMBER OF THE I. B. W. I DON'T
WANT TO MISS QUOTE OR MISSED
INTERPRET WHAT WAS ASKED
EARLIER AGAIN YOU KNOW. THERE
WAS A LOT OF THINGS THAT COULD
BE SAID OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST COUPLE OF HOURS BUT TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
COMMENT. BELIEVE QUESTION WHY
INVEST IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SECTION IT DOES A LITTLE BIT TO
DO THAT WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR THE LAST SEVEN YEARS SINCE
THE INCEPTION IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
IS PUT ON PRE APPRENTICESHIP
CLASSES. SEC PRINTERS OF
CLASSES. PREPARES THOSE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FOR
OPPORTUNITIES AN
APPRENTICESHIP. AT THOSE
APPRENTICESHIPS ARE GAME
CHANGERS THOSE APPRENTICESHIPS
ARE TRANSFORMATIVE. SO BRIEFLY
THE NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE THE
MOST UP TO DATE GOING TO THE TO
TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND WE
CONTINUE THE WORK TO THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
BOARD. THE FRESNO REGIONAL
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD AND
THE MADERA WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
BOARD. I HAPPEN TO SIT AS A
DIRECTOR ON ALL THREE OF THOSE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S.
SO WE HAVE PUT FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY UNDER SERVED IN HARD TO
SERVE COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THROUGH A PRE APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING. BECAUSE OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. OF
THE FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY WE
HAVE TWENTY TWO PERCENT.
BUILDING TRADES APPRENTICESHIP
PARTICIPATION. SUNRISE IF YOU
CAN TALK I APOLOGIZE THAT
THERE'S A LOT TO SAY SO THAT'S
A HUNDRED IN A STORY NEW
APPRENTICESHIPS IN THE SENATE
CENTRAL VALLEY. 81% THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY HAVE GONE ON
TO JOBS JOB PLACEMENTS SB ONE
FUTURE FUNDING. A DEAR DIRAC'S-
FIVE MILLION A YEAR EVERY YEAR
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WE
ARE IN PLAY ON THAT WE NEED TO
DO THE FRESNO WORKFORCE BOARD.
WILL BE. ASKING FOR THOSE FUNDS
AS FAR AS BRIEFLY I GOT TWO
MORE COMMENTS. RIDERSHIP I KNOW
THE COMMENTS WERE ABOUT
RIDERSHIP IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
I WAS FORTUNATE TO GO ON TO
TRIPS TO EUROPE. BASED ON HIGH
SPEED RAIL SEE IN THE RIDERSHIP
THERE WAS UNBELIEVABLE
ESPECIALLY IN GERMANY. THERE
WAS NOT A TRAINED WE GOT ON
THAT WASN'T FILLED TO CAPACITY
AND THOSE THINGS ARE DEVELOPED
OVER TIME AND I GET YOU WANT
THAT RIDERSHIP. I HAVE ASKED
THOSE QUESTIONS BOTH IN SPAIN
AND GERMANY AND THE RIDERSHIP
WILL BE THERE I AM FULLY
CONFIDENT OF THAT. THE LAST
THING IS ONE MORE THING THE
MULTIPLIER. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DRAW DOWN A LOT OF TRAINING
DOLLARS NOT ONLY FROM DC BUT
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TO CHANGE THOSE EYES AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE OF AYE.
WELL I ADVOCATE FINISHING HIGH
SPEED RAIL SECTION INVESTORS
ARE VALID PLEASE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
IT HERE OPERATE FRAZIER MADERA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD THIS YEAR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN TO YOUR
COMMENTS WITH BRIAN KELLY THE
COMMUNICATION HAS BEEN MUCH
BETTER SINCE THEN. WE STARTED
WE HAVE THE Y. MUSICAL OF THE
SPAGHETTI BOWL AND- WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT ALIGNMENTS SINCE
HE'S COME IN THERE'S BEEN MUCH
MORE DECISIVE- MEANINGFUL-
DECISIONS BEING MADE SO. I JUST
WANTED TO- TELL MY APPRECIATION
FOR THAT- YOU KNOW IF WE CHANGE
FROM WHEREVER GOING RIGHT NOW
IT NEEDS TO BE FROM
BAKERSFIELD- TO MERCED- THEY'VE
TALKED ABOUT IT BEING A TRADE
TO KNOW WHERE. AND NO OFFENSE
TO POP REVENUE AS EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT MADERA COUNTY IS A-
DESTINATION UNTO ITSELF- AND I
THINK YOU FOR ONLY CHORUS LESS
THE METROPOLITAN- BUT WE'RE THE
CONNECTION THAT. WHICH IS THE
GAP FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO
THE BAY AREA- YEAH THAT'S
THAT'S THE BACKBONE THAT'S WERE.
WHERE EVERYTHING IS AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AT
THAT POINT. WE HAVE- PEOPLE
TRAVELING FROM THE BAY AREA
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DOWN
OUR BACKBONE SUMMER HEAT CAL I
ALSO RISE RIGHT NOW THANK YOU-
IS THAT LIKE A SUMMARY SOMEONE
SOME RIGHT. SO YOU LOOK AT
THINK ABOUT WE TALK ABOUT
AIRPORTS THINK OF THE PEOPLE
MOVERS THEY PLACE THEM IN THE
LONGEST CORRIDORS OF THE
AIRPORTS TO GET PEOPLE FROM
WHERE. THEY NEED TO GO TO WHERE
THEY NEED TO GO THAT IS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WE NEED THAT GAP
RIGHT THERE TO TAKE PEOPLE AS
FAST THEY CAN'T THROUGH HERE.
REDUCE GROUP. GOT SOME IS. LEFT
IN OUR VALLEY THANK YOU SIR. HI
I'M MY NAME IS BRANDON I'M A
PART OF I WILL WRITE I HAVE
STUDENTS FOR A GREAT PRICE
PETER ALLEN HAVE BEEN. SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. I'VE BEEN
COMING TO THESE HEARINGS FOR
PROBABLY FOR. I THINK THREE OR
FOUR YEARS NOW SO I HAVE. WELL
AWARE OF THAT PROGRESS AND
STATE OF THE PROJECT. I WANT TO
KIND OF APPROACH THIS FROM A
MORE COMMUNITY BASED ANGLE LIKE
THE GENTLEMAN THAT CAME BEFORE
TALKING ABOUT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. WHEN YOU REMOVE
THIS FUNDS FROM THE VALLEY
YOU'RE NOT JUST AFFECTING THE
TRAIN PROJECT YOUR AFFECTING.
THE PROGRESS THAT THE MOST
IMPOVERISHED STATE PART OF
CALIFORNIA IS MAKING. I WORK
FOR A SCHOOL BOARD- I WORK IN
PRESENT A UNIFIED WE HAVE 85%
WE KNOW THAT KIDS DON'T LEARN
WHEN THEY'RE LIVING IN POVERTY
SO YOU'RE REMOVING SOME OF THE
RESOURCES. FROM THESE PARENTS
THAT ARE HOPING THIS NEXT
GENERATION MOVED FORWARD. THE
OTHER THING I WANT TO SAY AND
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT. I AM
SHAKING AND SO YOUR TD WITH OUR
LEADERSHIP IN IN OUR- POLITICAL
ROMS. AND ALSO IN THIS NATION
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE MOST PEOPLE
ACT LIKE CHILDREN. RENTS ARE
ONLY INTERESTED IN THEIR NEEDS
CHILDREN ARE ONLY INTERESTED IN
THEIR AREA CHILDREN ARE ONLY
INTERESTED IN WHAT THEY CAN GET
AND WHAT IS APPLICABLE TO THEM.
ADULTS ACTUALLY HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH THINGS ACTUALLY HAVE TO
COMPROMISE THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
TO SAY HEY THERE'S LOTS OF
DIFFERENT OPTIONS BUT WHERE'S
THE EQUITY IN THESE OPTIONS.
HOW DO THEY IMPACT- THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS SPENT AROUND. AND I'M A
RESIDENT SAID COUNTY. I'VE BEEN
NAPA HEAD OF THE EFFORTS OF A
FOURTH HIGHEST RAIL SINCE THE
ELECTION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT. AND CULTURE TO MERCED
COUNTY HIGH SPEED RAIL
COMMITTEE WHEN THE EFFORTS
BEGAN. CURRENTLY I SERVE AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY HIGHER EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM WHICH UP SERVICE
TWENTY SEVEN COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. HIGH SPEED RAIL WOULD
BE ESSENTIAL FOR THOSE
INSTITUTIONS AND FOR THEIR
STUDENTS SO I'D LIKE TO SHARE
THESE THOUGHTS WITH YOU. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PLAN. AND THE HIGH SPEED RAILS
POLICY OUR RECOMMENDATION OUGHT
TO PURSUE A MERCED FRESNO
BAKERSFIELD AND FROM OPERATING
SEGMENT WITH STOPS AT. KING'S
AND TULARE IN MADERA TO PROVIDE
HIGH SPEED. PLEASE NOTE THE
DIRECT CONNECTIONS AND WE'RE
SET TO ACE AND THE SAN JOAQUIN
ARE CRITICAL FOR CONNECTING. OF
FOR THE NORTHERN. SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY SACRAMENTO AND BABY.
REAL GINGER CALIFORNIA WILL
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM SLASHING
NINETY TO ONE HUNDRED MINUTES.
OF OFF THE TRAVEL. WE EVEN
MISERLY AND HIGH SPEED RAIL
FUNDS SHOULD BE USED FOR
IMPLEMENTING HIGH SPEED RAIL
ASK PROMISE TO THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WITH. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU SIR. AND THIS
IS A TIME I MAKE IT QUICK MY
NAME'S JOSE RODRIGUEZ- MEMBER
OF THE CITY COUNCIL FOR MADERA
AND ALSO A COMMISSIONER OF THE
MADERA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION.
FIRST AND FOREMOST AMONG THESE
SO HOW DO SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL. AND
LIKE MERRY LICCARDO OF SAN JOSE
AND FOLKS IN THIS ROOM. I AM- I
SHARE THE SENTIMENT OF
MAINTAINING THE VALITY VALLEY
INITIAL OPERATION SEGMENT. AS
THE ONLY VIABLE SOLUTION FOR
THE AGES ARE THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. WHY BECAUSE IT GETS
RIDERSHIP THAT MAKES IT
PROFITABLE AND THEREFORE TRACKS
PRIVATE INVESTMENT. AS WE
MENTIONED EARLIER. IT'S NOT A
PUBLIC IT'S ABOUT PRIVATE
PUBLIC. AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
FOR A PROJECT OF THIS MAGNITUDE
REQUIRES- THE PRIVATE SECTOR
MARIN HALL. WELL I DON'T- NEED
TO PREACH TO THE CHOIR BUT I'M
SURE THAT HOUSING SHORTAGE IS
AT THE CENTER OF CONVERSATION-
THE COST OF LIVING DRIES FLOCKS
OF PEOPLE OUT OF SAN JOSE BAY
AREA. AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BECOMES A VERY ATTRACTIVE
PLACE. THEREFORE CREATING A
MARKET FOR RIDERSHIP- SAM JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY HAS ADDED A
BUS ROUTE MADERA SAN JOSE.
HERE'S A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THE
DEMAND STEERING. BUT STILL
WHICH- LED TO A MAKES MOST
SENSE FOR STATE IN OUR
TAXPAYERS MEMORIES OF HIM THAT
WE ALLOCATE. FUNDS FOR THE
MARKET ATTRACTS BIBLE RIDERSHIP
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU SIR.
WELL BOUNCE SAVING AND I WANT
TO HEAR AT SOME A SHORTNESS AB
FAB MY NAME'S JOE WELL AND I AM
THREE COMPANIES FROM THE LA AND
I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK A BUNCH
OF QUESTIONS BUT I DON'T TO DO
THAT SO. I WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY FACES ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES. MORE SO THAN ANY
OTHER PART OF CALIFORNIA. YEAH
WITHOUT THIS WHAT OFF OUR BACKS
AND THE GOODS PRODUCED YEAR THE
ENTIRE STATE. ITS ECONOMY WOULD
SUFFER. TO REDIRECT ANY FINES
THAT HAVE BEEN PLEDGES AREA
THAT PROMISE TO GREATER ACCESS
TO GOOD JOBS WITHOUT. HAVING TO
LEAVE BEHIND OUR COMMUNITIES
WOULD TAKE AWAY HOPE- CRASH ANY
FAITH IN THE FOR OUR
BUREAUCRACY OF THE STATE. THE
CENTRAL SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
HISTORY A FEELING OF BEING.
ISOLATED FROM THE REST OF THE
STATE. THIS IS OUR CHANCE FOR
GREATER CONNECTION COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OUR GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
MATT CERRADO AND WITH THE CITY
MERCED A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN
THE CITY MERCED I'M HERE LONG
ALONG WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER
PEOPLE FROM OUR CITY TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR BOTH THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN AND ALSO FOR
THE MERCED TO- BAKERSFIELD
ROUTE AS WAS MENTIONED UP QUITE
A BIT EARLIER THAN A LOT OF VAN
JUST HAVING MERCED IS THE
NORTHERN TERMINUS. CONNECTIVITY
TO EIGHTY STICKING IN THE SAN
JOSE CONNECTIVITY WITH AMTRAK
GOING TO OAKLAND GOING TO-
SECOND WAS WELL ALSO WHAT WAS
MENTIONED BUT NOT DEVELOPED A
TOO MUCH WAS A CONNECTION TO
SENATORS WILL BE A FORTY FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR COMING
THROUGH OUR REGION ROUGHLY
GOING UP TO SEVENTY SEVENTY CAN
BE INCREDIBLY CONGESTED AS WELL
SO IT'S REALLY A WAY TO HELP
PRESERVE THE NATIONAL PARK AS
WELL AND REDUCE CAN GESTURE.
THERE NUMBER OF OTHERS AS WELL
CONNECTIVITY WOULD YOU SEE WERE
SET IN THE STATE INVESTMENT UC
MERCED YOU SEE BEING ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING PRIMARILY-
SERVING FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS- WHAT WOULD
REALLY DOUBLE. DOWN AND IMPROVE
THAT INVESTMENT HIGH
PERCENTAGES YOU. AS WELL-
CONGESTION YOU NAME IT ON ON
THE BENCH. GO SO WE WE'VE
CITIES BEEN. SUPPORTIVE OF
REMAIN SUPPORTIVE IT WILL BE A-
PARTNER IN AN ALL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS TROY HIGHTOWER I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROJECT OVER TWELVE YEARS.
MANY WHEN I WORKED AT- KERN
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS WHICH I
RETIRED FROM AND I'M NOW A
TRANSPORTATION CONSULTING. I'M
ALSO IN LOVE WITH THE SAME KIND
VALLEY REGIONAL RAIL COMMITTEE.
AND I'M PART OF A KERN
STAKEHOLDER GROUP DOWN A BIGGER
STILL- THAT CONSIST OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM PRIVATE
SECTOR ELECTED AGENCIES. AND WE
HAVE BEEN MEETING WITH THE JPA
LOOKING AT WAYS TO IMPROVE
SERVICE IN THIS ALLOCATE. I
WANT THINGS WERE SPECIFICALLY
INTERESTED IN AND MY MAIN
REASON FOR MAKING COMMENTS. IS
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF USING
THE EXISTING AMTRAK STATION IN
DOWNTOWN BIGGER STILL AS AN
INTERIM STATION. IT COULD BE
USED TO BUY EITHER
ELECTRIFICATION OR SOME OF THE
OTHER OPTIONS THAT OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED IT COULD WORK. AND
THERE IS THE PRESIDENT ELECT OF
GAYS IT'S GOING ON A CALTRAIN.
THE ALIGNMENT BROWN POPULAR TO
DOWNTOWN THERE'S BILLS ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED IN THE DOCUMENT.
TWENTY FOURTEEN ER YANKS
SUMMARIZE IF YOU CAN I ATTENDED
THE BOARD MEETING IN
BAKERSFIELD AND BROUGHT THE
SAME COMMENTS AND THE CITY OF
THEIR BILL HAS SUBMITTED A
LETTER OPPOSING ANY STATION
THAT POPULAR AND RECOMMENDED-
AT AMTRAK INVINCIBLES
INTROSPECTION. THANK YOU SIR.
HI HI I AM FRESNO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR STEVE BRAND OUT OF
DOCTOR RAIMES I THINK YOU FIRST
FACILITATING A VERY FASCINATING
CONVERSATION ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN- I REALLY APPRECIATED
YOUR COMMENTS YOUR QUESTIONS
YOUR LINE OF QUESTIONING I
COULD TELL COMES FROM SOMEBODY
THAT REPRESENTS CONSTITUENTS
AND SO YOU'RE VERY PASSIONATE I
REALLY APPRECIATE A COMMENT
THAT YOU MADE SOMEWHERE IN THE
MIDDLE- ABOUT WE SHOULD ASSUME
THAT ONGOING COST OVER RUNS ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN. I THINK THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. I THINK WE
SHOULD ALSO ASSUME THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BE A LOT OF OTHER
BLUNDERS ALONG THE WAY. I WAS A
FRESNO CITY COUNCILMAN NOW OR
FRESNO COUNTY SUPERVISOR I'M
GONNA GIVE ONE EXAMPLE THERE'S
A STREET ABOUT A MILE AWAY CALL
TO LARRY- OR EXCUSE ME VENTURE
A THAT HAS BEEN SHUT DOWN BEING
OFFICE SEGMENT OF BUSINESSES IN
DOWNTOWN FRESNO. IT'S REALLY
PUT THE HURT TO THEM WAIT TILL
THAT HAPPENS AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
YOU'LL FIND OUT THE KIND OF
PAIN. THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
BEEN LIVING WITH I WOULD LIKE
TO- ADD ABOUT THE PROPOSITION
ONE A THAT PROPOSITIONS. BEEN
BLOWN APART SO MANY WAYS IT'S
NOT EVEN FUNNY SO IT'S KIND OF
HARD TO HOLD ONE LITTLE ASPECT
OF THAT PROPOSITION OVER THE
HEADS OF THIS PROJECT FOR
INSTANCE- IT WAS TO BE DONE PER
AT NINE POINT EIGHT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. EIGHT HUNDRED
MILES OF TRACTOR SO MANY WAYS
THE PROP ONE BEEN BLOWN APART.
IT'S HARD REST ALL GO BACK
TODAY. THE HOLD UP TO THIS ONE
ASPECT. AS A CASUAL OBSERVER
AND I HAD NO INTENTION OF
SPEAKING TODAY. BUT AS A CASUAL
OBSERVER YOUR PARTNERS OR WHAT
OR MENTALLY WALKING AWAY FROM
THE PROJECT OKAY AND BRIAN
KELLY I APPRECIATE HIM VERY
SHARP I'M GLAD HE WAS INSERTED
IN THERE. BUT HE'S HOLDING THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL LINE THAT I
HEARD SIX EIGHT YEARS AGO AND
IT SOUNDS THE EXACT SAME BUT
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE ASKING
WITH OPEN MINDS THEY'RE ASKING
HONEST QUESTIONS ARE BEING SHUT
DOWN. I DO APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION TODAY MY QUESTION
FOR YOU AND THE PARTNERS IS
WHEN DO WE GET TO THAT POINT
WHERE WE HAVE TO CHOOSE ONE OR
THE OTHER. AND IF THERE'S A
POINT WHERE WE IT HAS TO BE
HIGH SPEED RAIL. YEAH THANK YOU.
CHEN ARAMBULA FOR MEMBERS
MISSION. SO I'M SPEAKING ON
JOURNALISM GOVERNMENT FOR MANY
OF THE CITY FRESNO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF MAYOR BRAND TO CAMP
HERE TODAY COLLEGE EYES IS
SOMEWHERE BROWN'S A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF GOVERNOR SINCE
PLAN AND THE HELP I SPEAKER
AUTHORITIES MAY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
TO PURSUE THE MERCED FRESNO
BIXEL INTERIM HIGH SPEED RAIL
OPERATING SEGMENT- THIS WILL
PROVIDE HIGH SCHOOL SERVICE AT
THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
LEVERAGING THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT.
OF CONNECTIVITY TO OTHER KEY
REAL SERVICES. THIS ALSO CREATE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS INCLUDING
FASTER MORE FREQUENT AND
RELIABLE PASSENGER SERVICE.
THAT IS CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY HERE IN
THE VALLEY. AND AS WELL AS
EARLY TESTING OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL OPERATIONS AND PASSENGER
USE AS WELL AS REDUCING RAMP UP
TIME FOR FUTURE EXTENSIONS. THE
SUCCESS OF THIS EARLY IN TERM
SERVICES A CENTRAL TOWARDS
IMPLEMENTING THE ULTIMATE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SERVICE BETWEEN THE
BAY AREA. LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
AND THE BAY AREA. SO FRESNO IS
A IS A CITY THAT IS WAS WORKING
TO CATCH UP WITH COASTAL AREAS
WITH THE STANDARD OF LIVING AND
QUALITY OF LIFE. BY ALMOST
EVERY MEASURE HIGHER THAN HERE.
THIS PROJECT IS CRITICAL TO
FRESNO FUTURE SUCCESS IT WILL
INCH THE SHORT TERM MAKE TRAVEL
FASTER TO NORTHERN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND IN THE LONG
TERM HOPEFULLY A HIGH SPEED
RAIL LINE. FROM LOS ANGELES TO
SAN FRANCISCO WHICH WOULD PUT
FRESNO AMONG OTHER THINGS LESS
THAN AN HOUR AWAY BY TRAIN FROM
SILICON VALLEY. THIS IS THE
REAL CHANGE THE PRESIDENT
NEEDS. THANK YOU SIR. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME AS WELL
ALL OVER I AM THE DIRECTOR
BUSINESS SERVICES FOR THE
FRESNO COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION. AND
FORMER CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND
MADERA. OF EARLY ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT WAS
CHARACTERIZED AS A BULLET TRAIN
FOR JOB CREATION WHICH TODAY
RINGS TRUE- ESPECIALLY FOR
AREAS SUCH AS A CENTRAL VALLEY
THAT HAS BEEN UNDER BETA BY
POVERTY UNEMPLOYMENT. AND POOR
AIR QUALITY. AND WHILE FOR MANY
GOOD REASONS- PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
HAVE TALKED ABOUT WHY WE SHOULD
CONTINUE OUR COMMITMENT HERE-
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
REITERATE THE GROUNDWORK. AS
OCCURRED HERE LOCALLY TO
PREPARE FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL. OF
FIRST AND FOREMOST THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. LAND HERE WITHIN A
STONE'S THROW AWAY OF THIS
BUILDING. ON THAT IS REALLY
HINGES UPON A FULLY FUNCTIONAL
SYSTEM AND STATION UNDER
OPERATION. FRESNO STATE
LAUNCHED THEIR FIRST
CURRICULUM- TO PREPARE HIGH
SPEED RAIL ENGINEERS TO WORK ON
THE PROJECT. AND WE'VE HAD-
HUNDREDS OF MILES WORTH
ACQUISITION OF RIGHT OF WAY. ON
THE WAY- SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE
HAD HUNDREDS OF BUSINESSES AND
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS
IMPACTED TO ACCOMMODATE HIGH
SPEED RAIL. WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY WORKED WITH THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO RETAIN
THOSE OPERATIONS. BUT I THINK
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT. IF
LEADERS WOULD EVER IT'S FUNNY
COMMITMENTS ELSEWHERE WE WILL
LEAVE BEHIND THE SENSE OF I
COMMUNITIES AND THOSE WHO HAVE
BRACED FOR THE POTENTIAL HOUSE
ON OUR FUTURE THOSE BUSINESSES
THOSE PROPERTY OWNERS. SO
ANYTHING LESS THE ANTENNA
VISION WILL MEAN THESE EFFORTS
WILL BE OFFER NOT THE
SACRIFICES AND DOESN'T MEAN
MUCH IN AGES ARE WILL BE A
BANNER FOR NOTHING MORE THAN
ELEVATED REYES SEPARATED. BY
PASS RATHER THAN A MEANS TO
CONNECT THE STATE ARE. TEACHER
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS DYLAN STONE ON THE
REGIONAL PLANNING SUPERVISOR
FOR THE MADERA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION THAT
IS MADERA COUNTIES IN PO- MUCH
LIKE THE OTHER IMPURE NEIGHBORS
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WERE
TASKED WITH DOING LONG RANGE
PLANNING IN RTP IN SCS I THINK
THIS PROJECT- SEEN MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT COMPLETED.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
PROCESS. LIKE THE OTHER REGIONS
IN THE STATE WE HAVE TO SHOW
IMPROVEMENTS TO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND CONGESTION
RELIEF. ON LIKE OTHER REGIONS
IN THE STATE WE DON'T HAVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES TO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
METROPOLITAN AREAS BUT WE STILL
HAVE TO. PROGRESS TOWARDS THESE
GOALS- THIS PROJECT AN ARRAY OF
DIFFERENT LEVELS SEEN IT FOR
PHIL TO ITS FULLEST EXTENT IS
IMPORTANT TO THOSE ACTS. HE
MORE PEOPLE ON THIS TRAIN
MAKING AT THIS AS EFFICIENT AS
IT CAN BE AS ATTRACTIVE AS IT
CAN BE TO A SERVICE TO TAKE
PEOPLE FROM THE VALLEY. TO ALL
THE OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE'S
REALLY IMPORTANT GETS PEOPLE
OFFER STATE SYSTEMS WHICH ARE
ALSO NEEDED PREVENT- IMPROVES
OUR HEALTH OUR SAFETY- WE ARE
FULLY IN SUPPORT OF SEEING THE
MERCED. TO BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT
COMPLETED AND DONE RIGHT AND
NOT A TRADE OFF THAT. ADDS
DISPARITY THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY IS HISTORICALLY FACED
WHEN JUXTAPOSED TO OTHER
REGIONS OF STATE. THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR COMING
TO FRESNO TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. MY NAME IS THAT
KENNEDY I AM THE FOUNDER OF THE
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE CHAPTER OF
I WILL RIDE- ADVOCATING FOR
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN MASS TRANSIT
IN GENERAL ALSO FOUND AT THE UC
BERKELEY CHAPTER AFTER I
TRANSFERRED THERE. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS A HIGHLY-
DISADVANTAGED AREA. WITH THREE
OF THE FOUR MOST POLLUTED
CITIES- INTO ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN LOOKING LONG
ASSOCIATION. AND BUILDING
AGENTS ARE IN THE VALLEY WILL
BE AN IMPORTANT MECHANISM FOR
US TO LIVE HERE TO ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO BRIEF CLEANER AIR- AS
ALL KEEPING THE FUNDS IN THE
VALLEY WILL HELP US LEVERAGE OR
POTENTIAL FOR PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. IT ALREADY HAS- IF
YOU WOULD SEE OUR DOWNTOWN EVEN
EVEN FIVE YEARS AGO COMPARED TO
WHERE IT IS TODAY IT'S VERY
EVIDENT THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL
CONSTRUCTION IS BEING A
MECHANISM- FOR- INCREASE
INVESTMENT AREA BUT ALSO TO PUT
PEOPLE TO WORK. YEAH ON A
PROJECT THAT'S LIKE THE SUCH AS
THIS WHICH YOU KNOW IS REALLY-
CREATING- OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WILL BE BUILDING TRADES FOR
FOLKS THAT WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS INTO THE
FUTURE ASSUMING THAT THAT
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
NOT THE LAST ONE. THE UNITED
STATES THANK YOU SIR. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON. MICHAEL MAY FEEL I'M
A STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I'M- UP AND
COMING BUSINESS PROFESSIONAL IN
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE. LAST
WEEK I GOT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC-
SUMMIT. AND I WAS INSPIRED BY
GOD GAVIN NEWSOM'S WORDS SAYING
THERE'S NOT A WHOLE AND YOUR
SIDE OF OUR VOTE. ON TODAY BY
TALKING ABOUT CUTTING FUNDS OUT
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
YOU UNDERMINE- MY RIGHT TO
CLEAN AIR- BEING RACE UNITS HOW
JOAQUIN VALLEY- IT'S- IT'S
UPSETTING TO SEE THAT THIS.
CONVERSATION IS GOING IN A WAY
THAT. HIS ADVERSE TO MY
PERSONAL HEALTH AND THE HEALTH
OF MY COMMUNITY SO IF YOU
CONSIDER THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. HI MY NAME IS LENA
GONZALEZ AND I AM AND I WILL
WRITE COORDINATOR. AT FRESNO
STATE- I AND I JUST WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT THE STUDENT BODIES
THAT REALLY SUPPORT THE PROGRAM
AND THE HIGH SPEED RAIL YOU
KNOW WHEN I. COORDINATE THESE
EVENTS AND I TALK TO THE
STUDENTS THEY REALLY CARE
ABOUT. THEIR FUTURE GOING ON
VACATION GOING FROM BERKELEY
FRESNO OR ANY AREA REALLY- YOU
KNOW IT'S FOR OUR FUTURE MY
KIDS. GRANDCHILDREN SO I REALLY
DESERVE OUR LEGISLATORS WILL
TAKE CARE OF IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. HI THERE THANK YOU FOR-
REPRESENTATIONS TODAY AND THANK
YOU FOR. ALLOWING US TO BE HERE
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE MY NAME
IS V. LIGHTLY AND WITH A MOAN
CULTURE TO YOUR CELEBRATION
HERE IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA-
EVERY YEAR WE HOST A VERY LARGE
EVENT HERE NO IT'S THE LARGEST
EVENT AT THE FRESNO FAIR
GROUNDS. WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT VISIT
1-002-002-0000 PEOPLE VISIT-
FOR THE SEVEN DAVID AFTER THIS.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT RIDERSHIP-
SIMPLY FRIEDMAN I WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT- AT THE TIME IT'S
AMAZING HOW ALL THESE PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY AND
SPECIAL OF A CALIFORNIA CAN
FIND THEIR WAY HERE TO FRESNO.
AND TO AND TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
US HERE I THINK THAT- KEEPING
THE FUNDING IN A CENTRAL VALLEY
TO KEEP- KEEP THE CALL OTHER
TRANSPORTATION MOVING HERE AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. OF ALL THE
FUNDING THAT WE CAN GET WOULD
BE WONDERFUL FOR OUR COMMUNITY
HERE AMONG COMMUNITIES HERE-
I'M NOT THAT WOULD NOT BE THE
ONLY. BUT. SHE FOR THE UNITY
AND FOR ALL THE EVENTS THAT.
ARE COMING UP I THINK THAT WILL
BE SURPRISED TO SEE IN THE
FUTURE. FRESNO MIGHT BE THE NEW
HUB RIGHT. SEN MIGHT BE THE NEW
UP WHY DON'T WE GIVE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY A CHANCE BY
ALLOWING THAT TO HAPPEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR. THE TEAM MY NAME IS RON TO
BROWN. I LIKE TO START WITH A
COUPLE OF OBSERVATIONS
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT HIGH SPEED
LINE ALIGNMENTS AND CLOSE OFFER
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA. HIGH SPEED LINES
ARE DESIGNED TO TRAVEL UP HIGH
SPEEDS BETWEEN DESTINATIONS.
THEY'RE DESIGNED LIKE FREEWAYS
AND USE CONNECTORS TO EXISTING
RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE TO CITY
CITIES ALONG THE ROUTE. HIGH
SPEED LINES DELIBERATELY.
BYPASS CITY COAL FOR RESTRICT.
IN DENSELY POPULATED AREAS AND
COSTLY IMPACTS ON EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. HIGH SPEED
LINES AND HAVE A FULL FREE
CORRIDORS FOR EXTENSIVE
DISTANCES. AND RICK RARELY FIVE
AT SPEEDS IN EXCESS OF A HOME
TWENTY FIVE MILES AN HOUR.
RECENT TEXTBOOK EXAMPLES HIS
VIRGIN TRAINS HAVE BEEN
OPERATING PROFITABLE REAL
CONCESSIONS YOU CASE LAST
TWENTY YEARS. THEY'RE BOOKED
INVEST HIM HOW BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE TO AROUND MILE HIGH
SPEED LINE IN THE I FIFTEEN
MEDIAN. BETWEEN PLACE OF IN AND
LAST WEEK US BUT THEY WILL NOT
BILL TIMELY HIGH SPEED TRACKS.
ANYWHERE NEAR THE VICINITY OF
DOWNTOWN. LAS VEGAS CAN I
FINISH YOU CAN SUMMARIZE ROLAND.
RIGHT SO WHAT ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
SAN FRANCISCO TO GILROY AND
BURBANK TO ON I AM I IN THE
CORRECT ALIGNMENT FOR HIGH
SPEED TRUNK LINE BETWEEN
CENTRIST TRINITY BUT THE CITY'S
BETWEEN MISS AT AND BAKERSFIELD
ON ON THIS LOWER LINE KNOWN AS
A FEEDER. AND THE CHALLENGES
HOW TO CONNECT THE CITIES AND
CITIES ON THE WEST COAST TO THE
HIGH SPEED LINE. AND I GO ONE
LAST PARAGRAPH YOU MY MATE.
STARTING WITH FRESNO FRESNO
NEED TO BE CONNECTED TO THE BAY
AREA FIVE DAYS AND VALUE. BUT
THE ULTIMATE FRESNO CONNECTION
TO THE BAY AREA HE'S HIGHWAY
ONE EIGHTY ON THE WE NEED TO
GILROY BY HOLLISTER. AND THIS
ALIGNMENT CAN NO LONGER BE
NORMAL BECAUSE I'M NOT TO PASS.
IS THE ULTIMATE ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
LATE. LAST SENTENCE. MOVIE ON
SOUTH KING SOLARI NEEDS TO BE
CONNECTED TO THE BACK BLOOM
VIED ACROSS IT COMIC TO. BAKE
THIS FIELD IS NOT AN ISSUE AND
THE TIME HAS COME TO RECOGNIZE
A PALM DALE IS ON THE LAS VEGAS
BRANCH NO DAILY. THANK YOU
WROTE. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
MCINTYRE MADERA CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE THREE NO. WE NEED TO HAVE
A SAFE SYSTEM WE NEED. WE NEED
TO HAVE RIDERSHIP. AND WE HAVE
TO HAVE THE DESIRE FROM THE
PUBLIC TO WRITE IT WE STILL
WANT TO WRITE ON IT ALL THE
POLLS ARE SHOWING THAT WE HIGH
SPEED RAIL STILL FAVORABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THE INITIAL
OPERATING SEGMENT THE ORIGINAL
ONE WAS NOT VIABLE THAT'S
MADERA POPULAR. THE NEW MADERA
MERCED TO A BAKERSFIELD IS THE
INITIAL REGIONAL INITIAL
OPERATING SEGMENT PLUS FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. NOT
LIKELY THAT IT'S GONNA BE
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN ABOUT
RIDERSHIP FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IS GOING TO BE
CONCERNED WITH. WE HAVE THE
FIFTH LARGEST CITY IN FRESNO.
AND THE THIRD LARGEST CITY IN
SAN JOSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THOSE GROSS
NUMBERS WILL ATTRACT PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. THE PEOPLE COMING
FROM SAN JOSE WE NEED IN THE
BALLET. WE HAVE THEIR HOUSES
THEY HAVE OUR JOBS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR. A GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS BRAIN DRAINING I AM A
PLANNER FRESNO COUNCIL
GOVERNMENTS FROM JUST. DOWN THE
STREET- I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME HERE
FOR BY PUBLIC COMMENT DURING
THIS HEARING. I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR
GOVERNOR NUISANCE PLAN AND ALSO
THE AUTHORITIES A POLICY
RECOMMENDATION TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE FRIES NUMBERS THAT
BAKERSFIELD. IN TERM OPERATING
SEGMENTS OF WE THINK THAT THIS
WILL PROVIDE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SERVICE TO CALIFORNIANS AT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME WINDOW
WHICH IS A HUGE PLUS- IN THIS
CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT WILL
ALSO PROVIDE PRESIDENTS AND
OTHER SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
RESIDENTS. WITH CONNECTIONS
BOTH NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I ALSO JUST ALSO
WANT TO QUICKLY THIS EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSED TO
PLACE THE MAINTENANCE FACILITY.
I JUST SOUTH DOWN THE NINETY
NINE A FEW MILES AWAY FROM
HERE- IN THIS WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF FOR NEWSPAPERS IN
EXPANDING ECONOMIC- WORKFORCE
AND WILL SUPPORT HIGH SPEED
RAIL FOR YOUR. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU DAN LEVITT
REPRESENT THIS TEAM JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY TO MANAGE
AGENCIES FOR THE AMTRAK SO
KEANE'S AND ALSO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY REAL WORKING GROUP
PROCESS TWENTY AGENCY WORKING
GROUP BETWEEN SACRAMENTO NUMBER
SAID WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN IN HIGH SCHOOL
FORTIES POLICY RECOMMENDATION
FOR THE MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
INTRAOPERATIVE SEGMENT. WE
BELIEVE THAT HI FI REAL FUNDS
SHOULD BE USED FOR IMPLEMENTING
HIGH SPEED RAIL AS PROMISED TO
THE VOTERS AND THAT THE
EXTENSION NUMBER SAID AND THE
BAKERSFIELD ARE NEEDED TO
JUSTIFY HIGH SPEED ELECTRIFIED
OPERATIONS. AND SILICON VALLEY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS ROB WAITRESS
SOME OF MADERA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AND UP I ALSO
SUPPORT THAT FUNDS REMAIN HERE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO
COMPLETE THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SECTION. AS HAS BEEN IS A
REQUIREMENT STRICT REQUIREMENT
OF FEDERAL FUNDING- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- I'VE NOT HEARD
TODAY IS. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT'S PUBLIC
SENTIMENT- WE HAVE TO GET A
VICTORY WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL WE
CAN'T JUST. GO THROUGH AND
HAVE- AS REFERRED TO IN THE
FRESNO BEE THESE MONOLITHS HERE
AND THERE IT JUST CREATES
FODDER CREATES VISUALS FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO SEE HIGH
SPEED RAIL. FAIL WE'LL SEE
PICTURES OF IN THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL LA TIMES. CHRONICLE
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN SO
WE NEED TO GET A VICTORY WE
NEED TO GET THAT UNDER OUR
BELTS AND WHAT THAT'LL DO IS A
HELP BUILD MOMENTUM. TO WANT TO
MOVE FORWARD HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
THE REST OF THE. OFFER SOME
REMEMBER FRIEDMAN ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE. SURE
WELL FIRST I WANT TO THANK
CHAIR FOR CHAIRING THE MEETING-
I WOULD WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
WHO CAME AND SAT THROUGH THIS
FELT. RELATIVELY LONG HEARING
HAND GAVE TESTIMONY AND STUCK
AROUND AND OF COURSE TO THE
PANELISTS FOR COMING TO FRESNO
AND SPEAKING I ACTUALLY WAS
REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE- THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE COMMENTS
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF AGREEMENT IN THIS ROOM. YOU
KNOW I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS PROJECT ACROSS THE STATE
WHAT YOU TEND TO HAVE IS TWO
SCHOOLS OF THOUGHT YOU HAVE THE
LET'S BILL HIGH SPEED RAIL
PEOPLE AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
LET'S NOT BUILD HIGH SPEED
WHERE PEOPLE AND WE DIDN'T HAVE
A LOT OF LET'S NOT BUILD. HIGH
SPEED RAIL OR IT'S NOT BILL
GREAT TRAINS IN CALIFORNIA IN
THIS ROOM AND I ALSO AGREE WITH
THE FOLKS WHO ARE WORRIED ABOUT
FINDING LEAVING CENTRAL VALLEY
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY BEING
ABANDONED CENTRAL VALLEY NOT
GETTING THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS
OF HAVING SUPPORTED. A
CONTROVERSIAL PRODUCT AND A
PROJECT THAT HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN
EASY. BECAUSE THIS ROB JEFF IN
A LOT OF COMMUNITY IN FRESNO
OTHER PLACES WITH BUSINESSES
HAVING TO BE MOVED IN. PEOPLE
GOING OUT IN A LINE AND SAYING
I SUPPORT THIS AND THIS IS WHAT
PUBLIC MONEY SHOULD BE USED
FOR. AND NOW SEEING THE
BENEFITS WITH JOBS IN. AND
BUSINESS AND DEVELOPMENT BEING
ATTRACTED INTO AN AREA THAT'S
STRUGGLED FOR THOSE THINGS. SO
I- ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT
WHATEVER WE DO WE CAN'T ABANDON
THAT PROMISE. AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A WIN
FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN THIS
PROJECT. SO I'M NOT ONE OF
THOSE LET'S BUILDER YOU KNOW
WHAT'S NOT BUILD IT. MY ISSUE
IS HOW DO WE BUILD IT TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
PROJECT. AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S A REALLY BIG
DIFFERENCE. NOW IT IS SOME
PEOPLE MAY THINK THAT BUILDING
A TRAIN THAT GOES FROM
BAKERSFIELD. TO MODESTO THAT
EVEN IF THAT'S THE ONLY THING
WE BUILD THAT SUCCESSFUL. THAT
MAY BE TRUE I MEAN IT MAY VERY
WELL BE THAT BAKERSFIELD IS
GROWING AND FRESNO IS GROWING.
AND MODESTO IS GROWING IN THAT
MAYBE A VERY EXPENSIVE TWO
HUNDRED MILE AN HOUR TRAIN THAT
IS ONLY. BOOK BY THOSE CITY IS
IT. IS IMPORTANT IS GOOD
ENOUGH. AND THAT MAYBE I JUST
DON'T KNOW BUT THAT'S NOT
ALWAYS PROMISED TO CALIFORNIA
BUT WE FROM. THEM IS LINKED.
WITH THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT ALL
LOOKING THE CENTRAL VALLEY. TO
THE BAY AREA AND- CENTRAL
VALLEY TO LOS ANGELES AND MAYBE
TO SAN DIEGO. TO ME THE
SUCCESSFUL PROJECT WOULD BE ONE
THAT ULTIMATELY. GET BACK. CAN
LIVE IN CENTRAL. A FACT TRAIN.
THE BAY YEAH AND TO TRACTIVE
THAT YOU DON'T WANT TO DRIVE OR
THAT YOU CAN TAKE A TRAIN. FROM
RIGHT HERE IN FRESNO HOPEFULLY
ONE DAY ALL THE WAY TO LOS
ANGELES TO THE HAVING TO TAKE A
BUS FROM BAKERS. DOWN BUT TO ME
THAT'S WHAT SUCCESS REALLY
LOOKS LIKE. SO I'M NOT SAYING
LET'S PULL MONEY OUT OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN ABANDONED
YOU. I SAY WHAT WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT IS LEGISLATORS IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHATEVER MONEY WE USE.
GETS US TO THAT SCHOOL SYSTEM
EVENTUALLY. AND AS FAST AS WE
CAN IT WAS THE WORK. WERE
FRESNO AND BAKERSFIELD MODESTO.
HAVE THAT CONNECTIVE ITTY TO
THE REST OF THE STATE. THAT'S
WHAT I THINK SUCCESS LOOKS
LIKE. SO THE QUESTION. IS HOW.
TAKE THE MONEY THAT WE HAVE AND
BRING THAT VISION TO FOR
RUSSIAN AS- AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. I KNOW. WHAT WORD
WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE IS NOT.
IS NOT. LET'S NOT BUILD IT
LET'S TO PULL MONEY OUT OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AND LEAVE THEM
ALONE IT'S HOW DO WE GET TO
WHERE THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
CONNECT TO THAT EXTENT. ALL THE
WAY TO THE BAY AREA AND ALL THE
WAY TO LOS ANGELES. SO JUST TO
BE CLEAR I THOUGHT I HEARD FROM
PEOPLE THAT THEY WANT TO SEE
AND I'M WITH YOU ON THAT AND
IT'S KIND OF HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WHAT AN- EVER
INVEST WE DO. GUESS AS TO THAT
THE FASTEST. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR-
STICKING OUT THROUGH THE
HEARING- I WOULD. PROBABLY
COMMENT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE- MERCED BUT- IT
COULD HAVE. BEEN A SLIP OF THE
TONGUE IN THE LAST STATEMENT- I
DO WANT. TO COME BACK TO-
GOVERNOR SOME STATE OF THE
STATE IF I COULD. WHERE HE SAID
THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL IS MORE
THAN A TRAIN PROJECT. IT'S
ABOUT ECONOMIC TRANSFORMATION
AND UNLOCKING THE ENORMOUS
POTENTIAL OF THE- IN TERMS OF
THE DISCUSSION TODAY I'D LIKE
TO FOCUS ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
HANDOUT FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
READ IT. WHERE THEY LOOKED AT
THE EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR REPORT
WHICH CONCLUDED THAT AN
INVESTMENTS TO EXTEND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENTS TUMORS
THAT IN BAKERSFIELD. WOULD
OFFER A SIGNIFICANT IMPROVED
SERVICE AN INCREASE BENEFIT TO
CENTRAL VALLEY PASSENGERS.
WHILE INVESTMENTS IN EITHER THE
BAY AREA OR SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA. WOULD YOU BUILD
LIMITED RIDERSHIP GROWTH AND
MINIMAL IMPROVEMENT IN TRAVEL
TIMES. I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
QUANTITATIVE ANALYSIS THAT WILL
COME FROM THE EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR AT IT WILL HELP US TO
FORM THE TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN. BUT I'D LIKE TO AND IF I
CAN WITH GOVERNOR NEW SOME
WORDS FROM JUST LAST WEEK. LET
US DO SOMETHING DEMONSTRATE OF
ALL. REAL TRANSFORMATIVE TO
THIS PART OF THE STATE AND DO
JUST THE PROMISE TO TAXPAYERS
WITH THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE
TODAY'S HEARING THANK YOU ALL
FOR ATTENDING